and new just awesome things to talk
about here with Unleashed. Starting off
with the XP mechanic. This is a brand
new one. We're having an additional
resource here to generate and and
actually be able to spend and even build
up to increase your level here. Amy,
what are you thinking about XP? I think
XP is not only a fantastic mechanic
moving forward, but also something that
allows you to circumvent the style of
gameplay that you're forcing your
opponent through. You're forcing them
through rings that they haven't had to
jump through before. You're forcing them
to play the game not to lose because the
advantage you gain from gaining XP and
the generation of that XP can be so
vital and can be crushing if your
opponent leaves it unchecked. Yeah, and
if there's one thing I like, it is a
miniame. And XP can be its own miniame.
Whether you are getting XP to spend with
cards like Kha'Zix and legends like
Kha'Zix or or if you're trying to get up
to a higher level with Master Yi and
other other cards like that. That is
really awesome.
>> Another mechanic in the XP vein, and
it's actually a one of the premier ways
to get XP in Unleashed, is hunt. So,
when you're conquering or holding with a
hunt unit, you're going to be getting XP
equal to its hunt value. So, if it's got
hunt two, you conquer, you're getting
two hunt. If you hold, even if you hold,
you're getting uh you're getting two XP
there.
>> I think that's a fantastic note because
being able to hunt to gain XP is going
to allow people to bolster that XP
faster. They're going to be gaining it
quicker than potentially their opponents
can handle. And again, we're creating
that extra miniame. Okay, I've entered
the frey with a unit that can hunt uh
like Mos Stomper and
>> that is going to force my opponent's
hand. They might have to change what
they were going to do on their turn.
They're going to have to react because
if I gain too much XP, especially if
we're talking about that Master Yi,
>> you can go up to a whopping level 16 for
an additional effect, which we had a
little look earlier is phenomenal.
You're going to want to make sure that
you're preventing your opponent from
being able to get up to those straights.
>> Yeah. And I think XP is going to be a
fun one because if you're building the
XP deck, you know how exciting and
strong that ability is. If you're
playing against that, if your opponent
is playing against you, they might not
know. They're like, "Oh, what is this XP
thing? I'll just let you have it." And
then all of a sudden, you're playing a
gigantic Master Yi that can't be
targeted. And all of a sudden, uh, the
game is over.
>> You've got this unstoppable movable
force of Master Yi in front of you. Okie
dokie. Um, what now, friend? And I think
that's the thing. The mechanic just adds
an extra level. It adds almost an extra
win condition, which I like. You're kind
of using that as an as an extra win
condition in that if you do make this
unstoppable immovable wall that your
opponent can't get through, then you've
essentially won the game because you're
going to get the points you need to
close it out.
>> Yeah. And the biggest thing for me is
XP. Even if you've played even if you're
playing the deck, you're planning to
play it when Unleashed releases, if
you're building these XP decks, we're
not really sure at a competitive level,
at a casual level, how strong XP is
going to be yet. We don't know how fast
we're going to be able to generate it.
So, it's like if you can get a uh an
early amount of XP, how good is that?
And it's going to be really fun to
figure that out.
>> What's maybe very fun if you're playing
it and not fun if it happens to you is
being ambushed by units. No spoilers for
another video we recorded, but I may
have been ambushed a few times here.
This is an ability that allows you to
play units directly to a battlefield
where you already have units. You can
come in and I'll just say it. It was Vi.
I got vied. I got I got punched right in
the face with Vi. Tell me a little bit
about Ambush, Amy.
>> Honestly, ambush was a fantastically fun
uh new keyword to unveil with unleashed.
It's very powerful and allows you to
have that element of surprise that we're
used to from hidden units, but actually
we haven't had the opportunity to
explore
the kind of heftier units that we're
able to put straight into a battlefield
adding to the frey. You don't need it in
your base. Doesn't need to be ready. It
can just hop straight in and you can get
some catastrophic levels of extra damage
in with that.
>> Yeah. And we saw a unit that didn't
technically have ambush in Spirit Forge,
which was Rengar. This is a whole
mechanic dedicated to Rengar. We're even
getting Rengar in Unleashed, which is
really cool, uh, as well. So, if you
were already ready and and knew how to
play around Rengar before, good for you.
I am not you in this case. So, uh, we're
going to all be learning this together,
which is going to be super fun. There's
a couple other mechanics in Unleash that
aren't necessarily gigantic ones, but
are really cool new additions. We've
taken some abilities that were in the
game and are now keyworded. The first
one is backline, which is kind of like
the opposite of tank where you have to
be damaged last and not first. So, what
do you think about that one, Amy?
>> I like it. We again, we did have um
snippets of of backline in previous
sets. Yes, we have had that, but now
there is an assigned keyword that not
only implies that we're going to have
more going forward, but also I think it
simplifies things. It makes everyone
know in an instant what that is
providing to that unit. And I think that
gives us that
>> ability to kind of
>> work your sequencing of your play to its
max. You know exactly what you're going
to be putting in and what's going to
survive and what's not. you're not
giving your opponent choices and that's
a really key
>> momento kind of you need to keep up the
pace of the game and being able to force
your opponent's hand and not let them
have the choice of which unit is going
to remain at the battlefield is huge.
>> Yeah, it's just another uh unleashed is
really unleashing a lot of new angles of
play in riftbound which is really cool.
Not just being able to go in trade your
unit for exactly what you want is very
cool there. Another mechanic here is
predict which allows you to is is an
ability on units. When you play them,
you can look at the top cards of your
deck and you can recycle one if you
want. This is going to give you a lot of
more card selection and be able to set
up those draws for you.
>> Yeah. Well, so we've got a lot of new
ways in which we can trigger predict.
We've had predict before, but not as
you've known it before.
>> We've now bringing a lot more with
unleash. And actually, we can trigger it
from battlefields. we can trigger it on
kind of more units in interesting ways.
Again, I think that unlocks more for the
future as well. Predict is very strong.
Being able to cipher through the deck a
little bit faster, gain knowledge, uh is
very valuable. And so, I think it's
something that going forward is going to
be very, very strong. And I think a lot
of people are going to be looking at
that battlefield thinking, "Ooh, that is
very tempting."
>> Yeah. And it's like deceptively strong.
It's like, "Oh, you just get to look at
one card. That's not a lot." It it's a
lot. lot. It's a lot. Uh, speaking of a
lot, coming from a little, it's not a
new mechanic, but we have our very first
one drop unit, determined sentry. I have
been determined to make this card work
cuz I am an aggro player, and this is
the most aggro card that we have seen in
Riftbound.
>> Cheap and cheerful is the way to go in
Riftbound. We need it. We need that
early game impulsive unit. We need We
want to be able to get into as many
battlefields as we can as quickly as
possible. Whether you're going first or
second, a one cost unit is impactful.
Being able to play multiple units going
first or going second, being able to
play a oneost and a twocost unit is huge
and it's going to change the pace of the
game.
>> Yeah, we're going to see some very
aggressive body decks coming up in
Unleash and I very excited to be the one
playing those. Uh let's shift the focus
from units and mechanics to new legends.
We've got a few
excelanc
reflection tokens of units and with her
signature spell, you can even make
reflection tokens of your opponent's
units. What are your initial thoughts on
Leblanc, Amy?
>> My initial thoughts are the potential
feels endless. Yeah,
>> your opponent not only needs to be
careful that their own units can't be
used against them with a copy, but you
also have to be knowledgeable in what
LeBlanc can copy on their own side and
manage those units effectively. It's
going to be a big It's going to be a lot
of mind games for Leblanc. a lot of mind
games because not only am I having to
make sure that my own units aren't too
big so that they can't get copied so
they can't be used against me, but I've
also got to be able to score points. So,
where's the limit,
>> right? Yeah, it is going to be
>> a mind game like you said when playing
against LeBlanc, but something a little
bit lighter. Maybe some cats and dogs
and porros and birds. How about Ivvern?
We've got our uh our first tag legend.
Well, maybe not our first because we had
Rumble, but a a new tag legend in
Ivvern. What are your thoughts on
Ivvern?
>> I love Ivan. I love Ivan so much. I'm
really excited to play uh I'm definitely
going to be building a deck that cycles
around Ivan, bringing extra power to
those dogs, cats, birds, and all those
lovely critters by replacing the
battlefield.
the first time we've had a battlefield
manipulation in Riftbound able to
replace it with their own
>> bush.
So good. And I mean this is certainly
this is definitely the first time we've
had battlefield manipulation and it's
it's definitely the only Battlefield
manipulation in the whole set, right?
There's not a way to make new
>> Oh, wait. I'm sorry to break you. There
is Baron Nasher who had a third
battlefield. So, not only do we have the
potential of Brush coming in and
replacing a battlefield, we also have a
third which can enter the fray when
Baron Nasher comes to play.
>> Yeah, absolutely crazy. This is
something that I thought of as a a
random thought many months ago when
before set one even came out. Like, what
could they possibly do that would be
unique to Riftbound? That's adding
battlefields is such a crazy thing. And
what a better, more iconic monster to
have that on than Baron Nasher. And
Baron Nasher is iconic for that reason
in this set, but also is the first card
we have seen at the ultimate rarity,
which is actually living just a few feet
over from us. I need to go check it out
after this interview. But
>> if I disappear suddenly, you know what
exactly where I am.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh my god. I saw that card for the very
first time today.
>> Yeah. And I was so blown away. You
looked at me and went, "Yeah, I know
what you're looking at."
>> Yeah, it's Baron, isn't it? Baron,
right?
>> Blown away.
Beautiful artwork. Stunning.
>> Brand new rarity. I can't wait to see
how everyone reacts when they get to
pull their first.
>> Yeah. Well, I'm hoping I pull my first
and second and third uh in rapid
succession. I'm hoping that is going to
be a a fun one to collect for sure. And
speaking of collection, we got a this is
something that we saw teased on the Bone
Shiver promos from Bolognia. This is a
new way to show alternate art cards or
really a new way to show text on
alternate cards or or rather a new way
to not show text on alternate cards. So,
we are now on al on alternate rarity
cards. We are no longer seeing the
reminder text on these cards. So, now
it's a it's a cleaner look. We're not
seeing all that reminder text saying
what assault does, what backline does,
all that is taken off for these
alternate art cards. Now, the regular
rarities are still going to have all the
reminder text. So, if you're a new
player or need to show it off, you can
do that. But for the alt arts, we're
looking at a clean look here.
>> We get to enjoy that artwork in all of
its glory. Just the keywords. It's got a
really clean look to it. And I can't
wait to see how that affects the look of
the artwork cuz we get to see that
undisturbed bottom of the artwork, which
usually is slightly obscured by the
text. So, I'm really excited to see
those come into play and to see how
streamlined a deck looks.
>> Right. We're going to start looking less
like game pieces and more like
fullyfledged art, which is really,
really cool. Uh I'm a I'm a Max Rarity
type of person, so I'm very excited
about that. But last thing that we want
to talk about here for Unleashed is a
brand new product that is coming out and
these are the vaults. Amy, tell us about
the vaults.
>> So, the vaults are really something
special. You not only get six booster
packs, but you also get 36 runes,
obviously very essential for building
your decks,
>> but the first time we've had three full
art tokens, but they're also
double-sided. So, you're getting full
art on both sides. It they're going to
be stunning. You also get some dividers
so that all of your new cards can be
kept nice and tidy. And so, it's a great
product for new and old players alike.
>> Yeah, it's a it's a great product. We've
seen uh I just know from my local game
store, one of the biggest choke points
is I've seen people literally printing
out runes because they didn't have them.
They didn't have enough. They didn't get
enough packs. That's fine. Now we've got
a nice way for people to get runes. I
did fortunately bring in some extra
runes for those players when I saw that.
Like that's not acceptable. But now
we're going to have a nice way for
people to get these runes and all these
other awesome products in at their LGs.
But that is a a quick little wrap on at
least some of the things that we can
look forward to in Unleash coming to
your local game store soon. I'm very
excited to play Unleash and I hope you
are too.
Hello everyone. Welcome back to RQ Ail.
I'm Blevens. That's Amy. And wait, where
where's my hat? I I just had it on two
seconds. And I'm wearing something
different, too.
>> I think I must have seen Aporo just nab
off with it before we came over. I'm
sorry. I should have run after him.
Well, we were busy changing into
completely new clothes here, but we are
ready to cast some action here, Amy. And
we've got an awesome match here. A Clash
of the Titans. We've got Draven.
>> You know him, you love him, you love to
hate him.
>> There we go.
>> It's a very standard Draven. We love to
see it. A powerful deck hit by the
bands, but still has phenomenal power.
We know how explosive the deck can be at
this point. It's a classic. We know it
well. Going up against Daughter of the
Void.
It's Kai'Sa. Wow. And all right off the
bat, I'm seeing not one, not two, but
three time warps. That is a lot of time
warps. That is 30 energy worth of card.
Uh, and of course the get excited as
well because you're not always going to
be casting those. Sometimes you're going
to be throwing them at your opponent's
units. We have got players already set.
You love when you don't have to wait for
an awesome match like this.
>> Speaking about getting excited, that's
exactly what we're doing as we run into
this round five here at the regional
qualifiers in Le. And we're rocking and
rolling straight on with a Draven turn,
I believe. Going first. Oh no, am I
wrong? Oh, we're mulliganing a very
important stage at this. No, we are
Draven first, but uh mulligan so
important to get that right starting
hand and an overzealous span is a
fantastic way to do that if you're
Draven.
>> Absolutely. You want to have that early
pressure though. You know,
two might units are not usually long for
this world against Kaisa. They have a
lot of answers to that at even a single
energy. We of course have our good
friend Hexte Ray who uh he doesn't like
the cuddy jib. He's going to be shocking
down those small units for sure.
>> Oh yeah, that's their expertise. But for
now, just a plundering PO and moving
back over to Vins, who's got just an
Overzell fan just pondering what to do
next. Overzel's fans a fantastic unit,
not over to not only to score those
early points, but also to give a little
bit of push back to the more aggressive
style decks who like to come in and
challenge that. Uh, Kaiser much more on
the spell removal side of things. So, a
little bit tougher to deal with if
you're Vince, but going with that stack
deck, one of the most powerful cards
we've seen in Chaos and continuing to
prove exactly why it's in practically
every single deck.
>> Yeah, it's a card it can't possibly be
bad, right? Because it just turns into
whatever card you need, right? That's
just just how it is. You you look at the
top three, you put one in your hand. How
could it possibly be better? We're going
to see it cast here. And I'm I'm
curious. This turn right here is
actually going to show the game plan of
Draven for this match. Are they going to
go in now, try to get that early point
or not? They are playing around the hex
tech. I kind of had a thought that this
might happen, not wanting to open
themselves up to that early removal.
>> I like it. I like it a lot. I think it's
a
unusual move for Draven not to be the
aggressor, but in this instance, you
know what you're up against.
>> The legend's right there. So, it's smart
at this point to take it easy, play
around the hex tech, and then once
you've got enough.
>> Oh, but it's not going to stop a falling
star. So unfortunately those overzealous
fans were just that rather overzealous
and regardless were taken down.
Essentially a board wipe and now another
plundering borrow hits the board. Of
course we gained a gold token from the
initial one conquering and now we're
into a Ferris 4unner. Wow.
>> Ferris runner are great. I mean an
amazing card. So much might packed into
a single card but we're we're behind. We
are on the back foot here on the side of
Draven. We're getting that very
important second point hitting those
even thresholds so that we're ahead on
point tempo. And now it is in the ball
is in the court of Kaisa.
>> Benadre is in a very very strong
position here. Although you might think
Amy there's only two porro on the board.
Don't be dramatic. We've already got two
points. We can keep these porros safe,
much safer than Draven can keep their
units. And we're coming in with a ferris
4runner of our own.
>> Yeah, you know, there's not a lot of
great answers to a ferris 4runner, but
uh playing your own is not a bad one for
sure. And we see both of these players
respecting the point tempo saying I
don't need to take this third point for
nothing. I don't need to throw away my
poro. Give Draven a free card. I got my
two points. I will get two more points
next turn. We'll figure out how to DO
IT. BUT OH, BATTLE OF THE FORERUNNERS.
HEY, you know, earlier I said that we
needed a counter for the sand tokens. I
think we need one for this this match
just for Ferris four runners.
>> I think uh I think that there may be
confetti and balloons that fall from the
ceiling if there are four four runners.
I think that is a that was a secret that
was a secret achievement of this dream
that I just made up and have revealed
now. Can we see it? This is a
possibility. I don't know if I've ever
seen it in my entire life.
>> No, I don't think so either. And I think
this might be other than playing a
casual game with Rumble. Although there
is a rumble doing well in this event
right now. I don't think I'll have seen
as many mech token potential out either
recently.
>> Hopefully we haven't. I might have to uh
run off stage and and hand production a
few of my mech tokens if all of these
4Runners pop.
>> Oh my gosh. I've I've legitimately never
seen this many. And they that is because
they do just give so much raw power.
They feel rather
>> kind of walllike. They're really
difficult to deal with. We do have the
singularity.
Oh, we can do that to both Ferris
Warunner, which will push them out. It
will allow the mech tokens to be
created, but it'll get them out of that
battlefield.
>> No,
>> wait.
>> We're at Trafarian War Camp. I was
wondering
>> gives them extra.
>> I was thinking what is this Traparian
War Camp? And I was trying to figure it
out before I brought it up, but we are
seeing the value here right now. We are
trading. I mean, one 4erunner for two
runners. Not a bad trade.
>> I say I say it's a good trade. I'd be
happy with that trade.
>> Yeah, but the problem is is that the
might is still there.
>> It is
>> did see I believe a falling star in the
hand of the Kai'Sa. And as we saw there,
I mean that war camp does give you the
break point to keep those mechs alive,
to keep the 4unners alive. You kind of
have to cash it in now even though it's
full price which Kaisa usually does not
pay.
>> Oh no. Kaiser really loves the discount.
She's in that discount aisle most of the
time.
the coupons for sure,
>> but not on this to count. No, now it is
time to fight back and put your opponent
on evenstead. Make sure they've got the
same amount of mechs as you got.
>> Mhm. Now, this is potentially the first
turn that we will see a card drawn from
the Draven ability, which is a key thing
in these highlevel Draven matchups. You
know, people talk about how Draven's
legend ability is very, very strong. It
gets a lot less strong when you are
actively trying to prevent your opponent
from drawing cards. We see a card drawn
here, which is obviously going to be
very good, but is it enough? I mean,
we're still behind on the side of Vince.
The point tempo is still in the favor of
the Kai'Sa player here, and this next
turn is definitely going to be pivotal.
Benetry has a very tough job here now.
Not only to deal with the mechs in those
battlefields, but they just need to push
forward enough to stop Vins from kind of
holding. I feel like if you're you need
to prevent Vins from getting that whole
point here. You want to be on four
before Vins is on four
>> quite desperately. That is going to
change the tempo of the game
considerably.
>> Mhm. And we see tide turner to possibly
swap some things out. We see a
switcheroo that could potentially be
hidden. A spinning axe which can be a
combat trick there. I mean, there's a
lot of trickiness here on the side of
Draven. And we'll see if Benadre is
going to be able to navigate this turn
unscathed.
>> Kaiser comes into play. Now it feels
like a bit of a mirror match. I can see
Kaisers everywhere. But you're right,
Benadre is doing a great job here of
demonstrating how Kaiser has always been
able to dance around the mechanics of
Draven. You're not allowing them to win
combat by simply not being in combat.
You're taking points
>> when the battlefields are empty. You're
clearing them beforehand and then not
allowing Draven to have that card draw
that he is so famously known for.
>> Mhm. Absolutely. Here, and this is one
of my favorite things about the hidden
mechanic and about these decks that run
hidden cards is that, you know, this is
not an open deck list. Benadryre does
not know exactly every single card that
is in uh Vin's deck. And even if they
did, there are multiple possible hidden
cards that this hidden card can be. And
it's really tough to play around all of
them.
>> I think we're just going to go in. We're
going to see what the hidden card is the
hard the oldfashioned way actually. Just
go on in. Couple of mechs. Off they
trot. It's the remnants of the Ferris
4Runner bottling it together and
staggering on over. It's
>> side turner. It
>> is side turner since we get to swap in a
Kai'Sa.
Okay, so now we are currently winning
the combat.
We're going to see a stupify.
>> Stupify. Kaiser feeling a little bit
worse for wear there. Lost a brain cell
and uh we get to draw a card. I really
wish that they would have just called
the card bonk on the head. I think that
>> we have Thamp.
>> We do have Thwon. We've got Wallop.
>> Yeah,
>> but just just good old just bonk on the
head. I think that that would have uh
>> I mean the
>> the artist Bon He's getting bonked on
the head.
>> Bonked. Yeah. I I mean there's the
future, right? Game devs, listen up.
>> True. Uh
>> that one's that one's free, right?
>> All right. Spinning axe usually goes on
a Draven. this time. Kaiser, really
great uh use of this um of this gear.
That's the word I was standing for.
Gosh, a really great
>> There's so many ways you could have gone
there. I was wondering where we're
>> uh No, great use of this gear regardless
of um its target other than maybe a
mech. I don't know. But still, Kais is a
great use of spinning axe as well, but
unfortunately didn't stick around to
tell the tale. But the spinning axe
does.
>> The spinning axe does stick around this
turn. This is a a notable it's a notable
thing here because a lot of times and I
see players shortcut the spinning axe.
They go, "Oh, when it becomes
unequipped, I just put it right in the
trash." Cuz a lot of times if it happens
on your opponent's turn, it ends up
going to the trash. So they shortcut it.
But when it's still your turn,
>> oh temporary, it happens at the at the
next beginning phase. You can re-equip
that right now if you so desire.
>> If you need it or you want it, it's
available. Now it goes away.
>> Now it goes away. But we did get to keep
those mechs in the battlefield. And
that's where this is changing
everything. Vin's now on five points. We
only needed really to get to four to
have the momentum in our favor in this
match. And now Benadre on the back foot
is going to be struggling uphill
constantly throughout this showdown to
try and see if they can take over and
put a [__] in the armor that Vins has
put up in front of him.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Now, normally you want to
get to those even break points, but if
you happen to get to an odd break point,
it's not a problem because you don't
want to overcommit to do it here. Well,
Vince just kind of naturally, yeah, just
kind of happened at five. And now
they're going to be able to either
>> spend next turn only needing to get one
point or they can potentially conquer
both points and then present that fork
of needing to conquer both battlefields
on the side of a Kai'Sa, which is really
uh it is it's a tough one to conquer.
>> Speaking of Kaisa, there's one fewer on
the board now as she succumbs to a
falling star. something we've seen
already today and might see many times
over. And a Kaiser reappears on the
other side of the board as Vins
reestablishes their own.
>> Yeah. What which side is playing Kai'Sa?
I see I saw a Falling Star followed by a
Kai'Sa. What What is Vince playing
again?
>> Oh, I suppose that's the glory of having
similar colors in your deck. You can go
ahead and utilize Kaiser in either. Okie
dokie. Let's see if Benadre can use this
turn to come back. We've got a lot of
power on the board. We've got a lot of
runes that can be used, but do we have
the cards in hand to fight back?
>> A battlefield. We've got a Trifarian War
Camp with obviously some extra tough
units on there and a hidden card. There
is void gate which is open but so far
not much that's going to knock Vins out
of that top battlefield which again if
they keep it going to six can be quite
troublesome.
>> Yeah, we see a pouty Borro come down as
well. So the board development turn
>> got some Yord. We got some Porro. That's
what we want to see. Some of my faves.
>> Oh, very strong. And there it is.
Another falling star.
>> That is going to kill So a threat to
kill tide turner,
>> not the mech though. Again, Trafarian
War camp doing a lot of work here.
>> Putting in so much work.
>> What I do like about the Falling Star
here is that if you were to take out the
mech as well, obviously the hidden card
would also go away and then you just
don't have to worry about that. Looks
like we're considering No, we're just
going to pass it over. I don't love that
that falling star didn't have its
optimum full potential. We weren't using
it to full effect. It would have been
nice if we could have finished off the
mech, but I appreciate the hidden card
scary,
>> right? Well, and it it it begs the
question of why not point both of the
targets at the mech, but of course, you
know, War Camp is is one that I have not
seen in Draven yet. So, I'm I'm not
surprised. I I certainly would have made
uh similar plays there and had similar
regrets about making said plays. But
we're seeing here that seventh point
scored from Vins now presenting both of
these battlefields threatening to win on
the hold.
>> Draven once again showing how scary it
can be. Although these decks work in a
similar way. More falling star.
>> The stars are falling all over the stage
today cuz we've had so many.
>> I'm looking around and making sure that
nothing is landing on my head. So many
falling stars.
>> Yeah, go careful. You haven't got a hat
anymore.
>> I know. hat is gone. The stars are
falling. Call me Chicken Little or
something. And the showboat in the
backline to say, "You know what? Uh, I
am absolutely massive right now. I'm
going to have a gigantic unit in the
backline regardless of what happens."
And it is an uphill battle from Benadre
here.
>> I love this unit being able to kind of
hold on until late game. My might is
increased by a point. Mhm.
>> That alone is a humongous jump in might
for one single unit and being able to
threaten that when you know something
like a watcher is about to come out.
Here they are.
>> Yep, there's a watcher which reduces the
might of all those mechs. But I believe
we saw a switcheroo earlier.
Not sure if that was the hidden card or
not. It would be excessively effective
right now.
If it is, and it looks like it is,
>> going to swap the might of those two
units, and we're going to shuffle up for
the next game as Vins takes Kaiser by
storm, bringing Draven back into the
limelight.
>> Yeah, I don't know if I I I've never
seen War Camp in Draven. Uh, maybe I'm
just not keeping my eyes on the on the
tech here enough, but
>> I don't know if I've seen a battlefield
be that impactful. I loved it in in a in
a battlefield that's like not Dreaming
Tree or Obless. That was I've not seen
Waramp be that strong in a matchup.
>> It was so effective. It made it really
difficult. If
>> it made it even more difficult to deal
with a ferris runner,
>> right? I mean, you don't need to do
much, which is crazy. But we see here
sideboard for events. You got a rebuke,
another switcheroo, hard bargain against
the odds. Uh, a couple of mind
spplitters, thermmo beam probably not
coming in. Of course, that falling star.
I mean, we saw I think the full
complement of falling stars. Two in
Vin's deck and three I'm imagining in
well, we saw three get played. So, three
on the side of Kai'Sa as well. Uh, so a
lot of falling stars here. And there's a
super falling star in the sideboard of
Benadree. That is rain.
>> A card which uh es especially in Origins
was uh very very firmly in that Kaiser
deck but has kind of lost favor in
modern decks. Uh but still a still a
great card and still very reasonable to
have it in your side deck ready for the
appropriate matchups. I don't think this
is one of them personally. I think maybe
get excited is something I'd consider
putting more of in now because again
you're avoiding combat and you're
dealing pure damage. You're not
reducing. You're just going here's a
butt ton of damage.
>> Can you do anything about it? And then
it's one of those ways that you can kind
of
>> get around the increased might of like a
showbo and things like that. So I think
you know to to balance things out you
might be thinking actually do I put some
more high cost things in the deck but
then actually have it get excited as
well. So I can either
>> I can use them both ways. I can either
pitch it away or I can use it for its
usual cost and use.
>> Mhm. Yeah. And get excited is the first
time I saw get excited in Kaisa my mind
was blown because I'm like why would you
you're not playing Jinx and it's like oh
you get an extra mode off of your time
warp. That is insane. and it's a card
that you already want to be playing at
least in some matchups some of the time
and it's like the match up is bad it's
just 10 damage to a unit which is I mean
obviously insanely good
>> especially when you're dealing with the
the D when you can kill a Draven
showboat at full
>> might that something else yeah exactly
and I think that's one of the things
that make makes me get excited about get
excited because it's one of those cards
that has flexibility oh gosh no I've
drawn loads of cards but all I've got is
my 10 sort of cost cards. What do I do?
Oh, wait a minute. I could just go.
We'll just we'll just use them anyway.
But with Get Excited. And it just gives
you that flexibility. It's it's they're
not stuck in your hand. It's not
something clogging your play. It's
actually enhancing it even when you
can't use it yet.
>> Yeah, we've seen many Kais have games
where they, you know, they're casting a
progress day. they're playing all of
their uh lecturing yortals and such.
Keeping that hand full and a lot of
times you're not able to play all the
cards.
>> No, you haven't got enough for all of
them cards. But what you can do is
utilize them in other ways. And I love
that flexibility.
>> Yep. All right. As we jump into game
number two, Treasure Horde on the side
of Draven Candleit Sanctum on the side
of Kai'Sa here. Kai'Sa believe going to
be opting to go first and is at a oneame
deficit.
They're going to be trying to scrabble
their way back in and bring us to a game
three.
>> Great choices I think from both players
in Battlefields here. Both looking to
strengthen their own play, but will it
be too much? Will they give their
opponents too much as well? It's why I
always I'm always rubbish at picking my
own battlefield because I never want to
give my opponent a great effect.
>> Uh and I'm always thinking, "Oh, I'm
gonna be really annoying and play this
battlefield." And then I realize, "Oh, I
have to go there, too."
>> Yeah. It's like, "Ah, every time you
conquer this, you're going to have to
channel or you're going to have to
recycle." Oh, wait. It's both players.
Oh,
>> but these are both really advantageous.
So each player is really going to want
to be going in there, which might be
beneficial for Vins, wanting to wanting
to maybe get in a scuffle or two.
>> Yeah, they it turns out Draven likes
combat. Uh surprise, surprise.
>> Draven also likes spending power and
treasure hunter is a way to get those
treasures. And even the treasure horde,
I mean overindexing on making those gold
tokens. We've seen value generated from
gold tokens. We've seen, you know, cards
that make gold tokens be fine. We've not
really seen an overindex, an overhaul on
gold tokens like we're seeing here. I
mean, treasure hunter into treasure
horde. That's a that is a lot of gold.
>> That's a lot of treasure. And treasure
it is because it does help us in so many
ways to be able to hold resources, hold
on to them, not let them go. And that
can be the difference between winning
and losing is who has more resources,
who can play those cards.
>> Well, if I've got more energy, I can
probably do it.
>> Mhm. And it makes a lot of sense
considering I mean, we saw two main deck
we saw two main deck falling stars on
the side of Draven. And of course,
unlike unlike Kaisa has to pay full
price every time, but if you can spend
some of that gold to get value from your
falling stars, that's I mean, like I
said, it's it's a small thing. It's an
incremental thing, but it adds up over
time
>> hugely.
Both players, equal energy, equal gold.
Who's going to make the best use of it?
>> Well, it was was equal gold.
>> Was all right, I'll eat my words. I'll
eat my words
>> with a treasure hunter. It's it's never
equal gold unless there's a treasure
hunter on the other side. In this case,
of course, not the case. at the
Plundering Pora, which is a bigger unit,
but does not generate gold at the same
clip.
So, we're going to see a little bit of a
gold advantage on the side of Bins
deciding. So, this is this is already an
interesting difference between this meta
and the the previous meta. If if it were
the previous pre-banned meta, we'd see
four energy. We'd be playing our chosen
champion. Now, we've actually got
decisions to make with four energy.
>> What?
>> It's crazy.
>> Wow. the deck doesn't play itself. I
mean,
no, that's fantastic. And we're going
ahead and hiding a card. Mysterious, one
of the most fantastic
>> mechanics in this game as well, just to
bring that element of uh of surprise to
a battlefield, being able to hide
information from your opponent, whether
it be in your hand, whether it be like
we say a hidden card. One way to
circumvent a hidden card being activated
can be to take out the unit that is
protecting the battlefield.
>> Yep. And this does play around a lot of
the range of cards. Tide Turner, this is
not super great against or titturner is
not super great against this. Uh Edge of
Knight does not do anything. Switcheroo
is very bad if this is a switcheroo. So
>> there's a lot. This hex tech ray is
coming in quite clutch and is just
getting the two for one. It was
switcheroo. Oh, disaster.
>> Disaster. That is what you don't want to
see is a hidden card get torn apart. If
the unit that is at the battlefield is
destroyed, then unfortunately there is
nothing holding on to that hidden card
and it also must go. So off switcheroo
goes to the trash. Unfortunately not
able to utilize it as successfully as
last game.
>> Yep. As we see Kai'Sa develops, gets to
play chosen champion Kai'Sa. Let's play
that in the backline. Of course, there
is the falling star possibility that we
saw from Vins. But if if you're if
you're one for oneing with a Kai'Sa,
obviously you'd rather have your Kai'Sa,
but you're okay. You've got quite a bit
of a board here. The potty por is not
putting on too much pressure. That's
putting Vins, it's spending both of
Vin's gold here, so I think they'd
probably be okay with it if it happened.
I agree. I I'm wholeheartedly agree.
Both players
are trying to build up this board.
>> Benadre has managed to
kind of really dismantle Vin's original
plan for this turn.
>> And now it's can can he rebuild?
>> Cuz if not, one porro ain't going to cut
it. And we can't rebuild as thoroughly
as we'd like to. having to prematurely
bring Draven Showboat in.
>> That is certainly a sign of weakness. If
you are
>> spending your turn to play a four might
no additional ability draven Showboat on
this turn of the game. That has got to
be a that has got to be a green flag for
Benadre here. It's a matter of how best
can they take advantage of this opening.
And we're going to start with Kaisa. go
ahead and conquer the candle lit
Sanctum, which if you're if you're new
here and you've not had this interaction
come up before, you get to stack the
abilities how you'd like. So, you can
actually do the candle lit Sanctum, look
at the top two, recycle one uh up to two
of them, and then you can draw the card
from Kaiso. So, you can basically set up
the deck how you want, and then draw
that card right away.
>> I'd say that's pretty powerful. That's a
pretty nice little combo there. And
honestly, you can't get a lot better
than that. It's like a stack deck, but
with a little extra
>> the falling star killing the Draven and
it was spent with two gold or was spent
with a gold and the Kaisa ability. The
the coupons have been clipped here and
unfortunately so is Draven.
>> Oh,
that feels so bad. Your chosen champion
is the unit that you want to rely on. is
your fall. They're your right-hand guy
and Draven just didn't stick around long
enough to not only not be very useful,
but also be incredibly lackluster when
it comes to the amount of power that he
was able to push out. Vins is severely
on the back foot. Now that candle lit
Sanctum is stacked. We've now got a
ferris 4runner. We've established how
difficult that is to remove and a
Kaiser. We've got a Porro and a Yord in
base to back him up. This is becoming
quite the tussle. Okay, we're starting
with a
rebuke.
>> Who are we sending back? Ferris,
>> we're sending good old Ferris here. And
then a spinning axe to combat the Kai'Sa
>> on a parro. I can't imagine a parro with
a massive spinning axe, but he's made it
work. Kissa's down.
>> And best way to deal with the Ferris
4Runner is of course rebuke. Kai'Sa
getting outmighted by a spinning axe.
And oh, by the way, Draven gets to draw
a card to boot.
Huge winter here.
>> Massive. Not only being able to deal
with two massive units, but also being
able to stick around in there. Grab a
point of our own. Conquer. Draw a card.
Candle it Sanctum. Uh, its effect now in
your control. Another pouty porro. You
know, they it's been a good egg. Now
we're going to put another one down. And
now Benadre can go ahead and start their
turn. They can replay that Ferris
4Runner, but it is a hefty cost. So,
let's see if they've got any other
actions they'd like to take instead.
>> Yeah, redeveloping the 4Runner always
good, but we've seen a few cards and a
candle at Sanctum proc happen from the
side of Vins, which you know, one rebuke
may lead to another rebuke, which may
lead to a game number three not
happening. But there it is.
>> Get excited. Excited.
>> What are we going to choose to discard?
We're going to deal exactly the amount
of damage equal to the card that we
discards um cost.
>> Yep.
>> To I imagine the palty porro with that
big axe and it Oh, we're using the
ferris 4runner. That's a unusual
decision in my opinion, but a very
effective one in this instance.
>> Yeah, you know, sometimes you just need
to get the porro off the battlefield.
does also get the spinning axe off as
well. So, not as egregious of a uh of a
toss of value there, but also value
doesn't matter if you lose the game or
uh if it causes you to win the game. So,
you really don't need to to worry too
much about that. Kais will get the cards
back and I'm sure they can find another
4erunner if they need it.
>> I'm sure they can. their ferris ball
runner. It's another one in the hand. Oh
my gosh. I had no need to worry. I
should believe in Benadra some more.
Look at me. Egg on my face.
>> Still had all these forerunners. And uh
speaking of a couple runners, uh see
another one in the hand of Vins as well,
but also a mindsplitter too. So going to
have to see which they are going to go
with on this turn.
I
>> imagine one is going to come down here,
but I guess we shall see.
>> Yeah, we've got almost quite similar
board states at this stage. We've
managed to catch up.
Okay, Ferris four runner down and it is
just a pass over to Benadre who's going
to go up to five points from the hold on
the Candlelet Sanctum and in a pretty
strong position. We've got some heavy
units. We've got the Yordlin base, one
gold, plenty of runes. Now it's just
what's in the hand to be able to keep
this a position. We're ahead. We want to
stay there.
>> Yeah. What do we have to do that? Oh,
that's a I see a time warp.
>> I do see a time warp.
>> And that can certainly end the game
relatively quickly here if they're able
to cast it.
might be a Brin here this turn
and then kind of get ready for a time
warp. Oh no, we're just Oh my goodness
gracious. We're just going to play all
the guys. We're going to establish a
huge board. Difficult for Draven to deal
with in one go when we've only got a
Ferris Ballrunner and a Porro.
>> Yeah. And you know, much like Kai'Sa or
some of these other interactive decks,
Draven tends to want to conquer and then
leave up energy to represent tricks.
Draven obviously makes very good use of
Brin here. But it's also quite good
against Draven. So it might catch Vins
off guard here if they are, you know,
going to play uh if they're going to
conquer here and then potentially leave
up interaction. Uh Brin here may be a
pretty big punish if that does happen.
>> Very much could be. Ferris 4unner going
into Candle Lit Sanctum taking up to
five trying to stay on par but looking
ahead looking at the turns in the
future. We can see a well an army over
the other side on the base just kind of
looking over the hill like huh that's a
lot of guys. Um weird fluffy things over
there. What are they doing?
>> What's happening? And uh they're all
going to start maneuvering towards the
battlefield soon. So as you say, Vins
might kind of leave. No, they're not
going to leave these standing. Mind
spplitter comes out and we get to see
the print here and the time warp. Which
which do you take?
>> The shrug of h
there's no good answer here, is there?
>> Yeah. No.
Oh gosh,
that is ferocious.
What a mindspplitter. We've gone for the
Brin here.
>> Mhm.
That is not a good day if you're Benre.
>> Yeah. Well, now we're going to move the
Porro back. We've got a lot of might in
the backline.
The good news for Vins is that if the
time warp does come out, there's not
much else that can be done in this turn.
>> We can't win on this turn with time warp
alone
>> necessarily.
>> Right. We've got seven and six. We I
mean we we have
>> we can take the battlefields.
>> Yeah,
>> I suppose. And then
>> four, six, seven. We're really I think
we have exactly enough.
>> My quick quick caster maps are we have
exactly enough to contest both
battlefields if we close our eyes and
say Vince has nothing.
>> Yep. That is the hope.
>> I think
>> that's what we got to do. It's like we
were saying earlier sometimes you just
got to throw everything at them and hope
they don't got it. Oh, but that's going
to make a difference.
>> Yeah. And that is the look of someone
who just saw the other person's hand and
knows that there was not a thousand
tailed watcher in it. just a second ago.
>> Oh no.
>> Well, this math got a lot easier.
>> Yeah. Right. Okay. Now we reduce
everything by three from the other side
and all of a sudden it's a lot easier to
contest those battlefields. Makes it a
lot harder for Vins to be able to pump
the numbers there. So, looks like we
might be having those battlefields.
>> Yeah. And Benadre is I'm guessing trying
to play around a spinning axe is the one
that I would think is uh is reasonable
to be able to play around.
>> I think that is understandable.
>> Yep.
>> And out the small units.
>> Yeah, going for those ones. Taking out
the majority.
That is a another watcher that is
slammed onto the top of the deck.
>> It was Yeah, I can do that again. That
was great.
>> Was pretty good. Let's do it again.
>> Let's do it again. Yeah,
>> that's working out quite nicely. And now
we can go and try for the other
battlefield if we choose. We can't use
the time warp this turn anyway. So, we
could just hold on and and uh wait until
next turn
>> and do it again. But there is now, of
course, two mechs and a
base to deal with as well. Y might be
worth just taking down this mind
spplitter while you've got it reduced
already.
>> Right. I think this attack plays around
spinning axe for sure. It also plays
against rebuke
on the 4Runner. It will be a trade which
is fine.
>> Yeah, there is a spinning axe. A really
heads up play from to
>> say, hey, I don't want to just throw
away units for nothing here. Let's let's
play let's let's think about a card that
my opponent could have and let's let's
pretend like they have it and play
accordingly.
>> Fantastic. Seeing the writing on the
wall, seeing that Vins has those two
energy, spinning axe being a very
prevalent threat when you're playing
against Draven, knowing that that can
come straight out onto that mines litter
and really change up the numbers.
Actually,
it's not quite so. There's still 4 to 10
might on this battlefield unless
Vins has a way out of this situation. It
could get a little bit sticky. We've
still got a lot of power even on the
candle atlet Sanctum with seven. So
Vince would have a really uphill fight
to be able to get through both of them
to stop Benedre from getting that whole
point.
>> Yeah. The other consideration I believe
there's a ride the wind and we are
actually going to see the mindslitter.
This is basically a uh expensive flash
in this case to ride the win the mind
spplitter back. It's only a four here.
It's not going to be getting value.
You're going to be conquering anyway.
We'll let that happen. And now we at
least have a mind spplitter still in
play and we can actually play the game.
>> Yeah, that's really wise. It was
expensive, but I think it was worth it
considering that we need the might to be
able to kick better out of these
battlefields. Otherwise, he just wins
the game,
>> right? We need to play not to lose at
this point and so we need to start
dealing with the threats in front of us
and the only way we're going to do that
is with numbers and might.
>> Yep. Absolutely.
So we've got
eight in might uh with the small units
and then we know we have that spinning
axe so we can get up to 10 on the mind
spplitter that will technically be
presenting dealing with this board
again. And if we close our eyes and say
Benadre has nothing, but then we
probably lose on the crack back. How?
>> Yeah,
>> but we can at least not lose right this
second is step number one.
>> That's the problem. Like I mean, yeah,
10 and seven on each side is really
quite troublesome. It's almost like
matching our numbers too perfectly.
>> We need that extra oomph,
>> right?
>> I'm not sure if we have it in hand. I
know obviously we have the spinning axe,
but we need kind of one extra. But we
need a little bit more.
>> Yeah, if we had a I mean, if we drew
another rebuke, that would be fantastic.
If we Yeah, if we drew maybe another
spinning X, that would be great. But
we're going to start here. Looks like
we're going to Okay, cleave. That's a
cheaper spinning X in this case.
>> Yeah, that's perfect. That's kind of
exactly what we want. Really low cost,
just one. And we get to make these guys
a lot bigger. And then, yep, we're going
eight into seven. Porro survives it. We
get the point for conquering Ben and
Dre's out of one battlefield. We need
the second one.
>> Yep, we do of course get to draw a card
from Draven winning combat and then we
get to proc the candle sanctum. Now, a
slightly different from Kai'Sa. The
layering and how Draven reads. Long
story short, you draw the card first
every time with Draven. Kai'Sa, you can
actually choose the ability uh order
because they're both conquers. Draven is
when you win combat. Uh I'm not a level
one judge. You can ask your local judge
exactly why that works, but just trust
me that it was done correctly here and
you have to draw the card with Draven.
>> Yeah, that's exactly how that works. So,
we do now have the extra mech that we
didn't need to send in to Candle Lit
Sanctum. So, we can go into treasure
horde with both of these if we need to.
>> In an ideal world, we want to keep
resources back because we still need
that extra push to get us to eight. So,
in an ideal world, we don't want to use
both of these. We want to use a spinning
axe maybe on one and send that in. But
in another world, we just need as much
as we can because our opponent does have
energy left over. They could use it.
>> And we're going on in with both units
and the spinning axe. Not taking any
chances getting as high up in mighty as
we can.
>> Yeah, but I really like this here. We're
putting the spinning axe on the mech. So
if I mean you would ideally want to
choose the mind spplitter as the unit
that you destroy here, but of course
that would uh leave leaves spinning axe
on the mech here. So we're going to keep
the spinning axe around. It's not going
to cost an extra power to re-equip.
Vin says
saved off defeat at least for the time
being. But uh Amy, I think we know there
is a uh a thousand tail washer that was
put on the top from that candle lit
Sanctum. So
>> yeah, we did get to put that nicely on
the tippity top and so we do get to grab
that back. So we're in a very very
strong position going for a falling
star. That will make the difference.
>> Now it's going to be a lot more
troublesome for Venadre to be able to
challenge both battlefields, which he's
going to need to do
>> if he wants to pull a win.
>> Yeah. And I it it is possible that
accelerating the thousand watcher here
would win the game. However, Benetrate
doesn't necessarily know that. Right.
Exactly.
>> There's cards in hand and energy up.
Therefore, game is not determined.
However, uh I don't know that they're in
a position. And in fact, I know that
they're not in a position to play around
anything. So again, if you can't beat a
card that your opponent may have, just
pretend that they don't have it and hope
that they don't and make the appropriate
attacks. Will it into existence?
Manifest it. They don't have it. They
don't.
>> Not yet.
>> Stack deck.
>> It is. Let's see if they get what they
need. The body language is not giving. I
got what I wanted. So, we're now we're
going to scoop it up. Benadre grabs game
one by the horns and takes down Draven
with Kaiser.
>> Oh, game two.
>> We get to get We get a nice little game
three here. The Battle of the Titans,
>> Draven versus Kai'Sa. And it was a tale
of two games there. I felt like in the
first game, the Draven was ahead the
whole game. Uh it was really it really
ended up being like falling star
dominance there. Like whoever had the
more impactful falling stars ended up
taking it down. But we see here the
sideboards coming up. Mind spplitters.
We saw we saw the falling star of
course. I'm wondering now that we've
seen uh they saw the time warps. I
wonder if we're if we're keeping hard
bargain. I would imagine we probably had
it in anyway, but I think once you see a
time war, it's like you want more. You
want
>> I don't want if you cast time warp and I
hard bargain it. That is a massive
swing. It might even be worth putting
more mind splitters in just to increase
the chance of seeing them so that you
have them when you need them so you're
able to remove effectively from your
opponent's hand and keep on top of that.
>> Cuz that that was one of the many
pivotal points in that game to be
honest. There were so many twists and
turns, but one of them was really being
able to say, "Oh, actually um yeah, no."
>> Yeah,
>> put that away please. Yeah, we saw both
both players actually dealing with
respective Ferris 4runners quite well. I
mean, they both are obviously playing
forunners. They both had forerunners
against each other's forerunners and
then they were able to deal with uh at
least parts of each other's forerunners
quite well.
>> After this best of three, I'm going to
wake up in the middle of the night going
Ferris for
>> absolutely. Yeah, it is certainly a
>> it's it it's weird that falling star is
one of the better ways to deal with a
ferris 4runner kind of. But it also just
feels awful doing it to either side,
right? Like if you have to spend the
resources to destroy the first half of
the 4Runner, they still have the mech
there. And if you spend all this time
and energy and effort killing the front
half of the 4Runner
>> and then you still have to spend another
two cards and two power to kill the max,
it's it's tough. That card is
>> it's so frustrating. Yeah. To play
against when you're playing it and you
don't have one to play against. It's
like whippy. But not not so much when
there's multiple on both sides of the
board. Both being,
>> you know,
>> pretty pretty agame menaces.
>> Yeah. Well, we see the battlefields for
game number three here. Targon's Peak on
the side of Vin. Vom's lair on the side
of Benadry. So, Targon's Peak is a very,
very strong battlefield. When you are
going first, when you're able to conquer
it first, it is really good. And that is
exactly what Vins is going to be going
for here. Looking for that early drop to
be able to contest that Targon's Peak as
early as possible
to be able to get that additional
value and those additional runes readied
on your opponent's turn. Yeah, leaving
runes available on your opponent's turn
is kind of what both of these guys want
to be doing. They both really want to
leave that threat open, especially with
spinning ax being h let me think two to
two energy. So leaving the runes ready
for that. Fantastic. Really fantastic
use of battlefields, but can come back
to bite you if you aren't the one
utilizing it as much.
>> Y
>> nice easy usual turn ones from both of
these guys. Cheap unit on both sides. We
love to see it. Now we're just going to
get straight into building up that pace.
And we'll see whether Vins takes a
similar approach to game one where they
kind of held back a little bit but then
were able just to overwhelm the board
afterwards.
>> Yeah, we see the hard bargain in hand.
So the thought process I would imagine
going through Vin's head is if I attack
here, they're going to hex tech. If they
hex tech, am I going to hard bargain? I
think the answer to all of those
questions is yes.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> No, it's not. Okay, see I don't care
about the hex tech ray. Don't care about
my two drop unit.
Oh, looks like we got a judge call
coming in here. So, we're going to jump
back to the desk here real quick. But
yes, the hexac ray took out that uh
>> that overzealous man was again bit
overzealous ray said not today.
>> No, no, no. Need to calm you down, sir.
Get away from our Lord Draven. Uh Kaiser
then comes into play as uh we utilize
the remaining energy from our turn. Uh
we can't accelerate her. We don't have
enough remaining, but are able just to
get her on the board. A strong unit. We
know that and is going to help out to
overpower some of the smaller units that
Benadre will be able to play at the
moment. So let's see how they can piece
together this turn. going to go ahead
and bring out their own Kaiser to
contest the Kaiser. Goan. Yeah. Passing
straight back over. Kind of feels like
they're playing a mirror match at the
moment. These are all different decks,
friends.
>> Yeah. This is just the uh the meme where
we pull the mask off Draven and reveal
that it was Kai'Sa all
>> all along. Yeah, it's exactly that.
>> Vins is the first player to conquer the
Targon Peak and the first player to get
a 4Runner down on the Targon Peak. And
oh, by the way, two runes readied as
well. So, good luck. have fun going into
that battlefield.
>> That doesn't look fun to me. I don't
want to go into that battlefield, but
you kind of have to. You have to push
forward. Do have was that singularity?
So, there's a little bit of flexibility
there considering the yord.
It's just Yeah, Vin's getting targets
peak that early and having 10 might on
it already.
It's kind of big. Yeah, this is a big
one though because we're seeing
Singularity and I think we're going to
see a hard bargain
slammed here at least potentially unless
I mean Fins may have the big picture
game plan of wanting to counter time
warp position. No, no, no, no. This is
this is good enough.
>> Hard bargain and it forces Venadry to
abandon that plan and just go they need
to keep pace into Valor's lair and score
their own conquer point.
>> Yep. getting that point in the biome
which does of course leave the Kai'Sa
stranded. There's not really a lot of
good ways to get her back. Of course,
there is recalls on the side of Kai'Sa.
So, you can bring it back to your hand,
but you're not going to be able to, you
know, you don't have access to Ride the
Wind. You don't really have access to
ganking in a lot of these Kai'Sa decks.
So, Kai'Sa is in Vi Ma's layer for this
game.
>> Yeah, she she's a little trapped there.
But speaking of ride the wind, we are
going to jettison the ferris warunner
into Balmore there to deal with that
Kaiser.
>> Yep, a nice value ride the wind there.
And you know, normally the forerunner
would be able to move back. Of course,
you can't with vile because of vile
maser, but also you're probably just
okay with it uh staying where it is.
>> Yeah, you don't mind that too much.
Again, it's a really annoying unit to
deal with for your opponent. your
opponent might have to leave something
else stuck in there and then you get two
mech tokens so it doesn't really feel
like you were that stuck after all.
>> Yeah, it's it's weird like the Vile Mos
layer, you know, crunches down on the
mechs and then the mechs just walk out
like they were like they weren't in Vom
layer. It's weird. It's uh thematically
maybe I guess you know I'm I'm I'm
guessing some sort of eject button
shoots them back into your base. There
we go. I've made it work thematically. I
was thinking of like a a little little
door that only the mechs can fit
through.
>> Uh I like both of those. Maybe both they
got ejected through a door that only
they can that only they could fit
through. I liked it.
>> We're getting the story together, folks.
>> Riot lore team. That's a freebie there.
We got the first one's free, remember?
>> Oh, but no, it's it's a good play. We
like to see it. We got the treasure
hunter as well now backing up Kaiser in
base. And now Betterre has a really
tough time of trying to bring it back.
Now Taran Peak is available.
But again, if you don't have the might
in original units, they're they're just
going to get beaten up by Draven. And
what don't we want Draven to do?
>> Draw more cards.
>> And what does Draven do when they win a
combat? draw more cards.
>> That's the problem.
>> Yeah, that's that's a real problem.
Yeah. Facing down contesting Draven when
they have energy up and cards in hand.
It's just it's so risky. You know, you
can you can lose a combat against
another deck and it's like, okay, I I I
figured that they might have a trick. I
got some cards out of their hand. You
don't even really get the cards out of
their hand against Raven cuz they just
draw them back up. Yeah, that's the
problem. Especially if you're allowing
combat, which we've seen a little more
in this game because Benadre really
hasn't had a choice on the back foot.
They've lost pace. They need to pick it
back up. We're going to try a Falling
Star this. See if we can get ahead just
by whittling away at Vin's board.
>> Yep, Falling Star is coming down. It
looked like they pointed at Kai'Sa. I'm
not sure if one or both are pointed at
the Kai'Sa.
>> Looks like it's a both situation. Kaiser
down which again does put a [__] in the
armor that Vins is trying to establish.
>> Looks like we're figuring out is it
worth it to conquer that Targon's peak
says no
>> doesn't even need to get that second
point here. the long game is in mind. If
you're Benedre saying, "You know what? I
need to deal with this board. I don't
care if they get the seven points. We
will develop the board. We'll deal with
their board and then we'll win in due
time."
>> I agree with that play wholeheartedly.
Holding back, building up your board,
making sure that your units are safe and
avoiding going into unnecessary combat
with Draven knowing that they've got
strong units to hand like Ferris
4Runner. Yes, the battle of the
4erunners currently two to zero on the
side of Vins and that is not a battle
that you want to be losing right now.
>> No, that's not particularly ideal and
they are so troublesome especially when
on separate battlefields and you don't
have much to contest it right now. Oh my
gosh. And an overzealous span which not
only makes it even more awkward to deal
with the overzealous span being able to
push things back in your direction
again. Nightmare. Yeah, very very tough
card to play around. Now, one way to
punish these overstacked boards is of
course that thousandtailed watcher. So,
we could see that come down, but we may
even have enough stats that they they
don't even really care. It's It's not
It's not a super easy attack like it was
last game.
>> No. And there are there are both
battlefields to contest with. It's not
urgent. I shall say that. So, we can go
a little bit slower if we need to and
just deal with them one at a time. And
you probably do want to go with
I don't know actually. I was going to
say I want to I would go with Val Mour,
but then we're kind of trapped there and
we can't get out. So, do we actually
want to go for target peak where at
least we can retreat later back to base
and then reestablish the units? I think
you've got to.
>> Okay, we're going for everything over on
the right side here. We're going to see
the overzealous fan push the thousand
tailed watcher. We're now seeing four on
the four to three. So, looks like the
Kaisa needs to do something and that is
extend the fist bump. I hoping that you
do something. They did not. And that is
going to be Vins on the Draven taking
down our first clash of the Titans.
Draven versus Kaisa. Draven may have
lost a lot of cards in the bannings.
Doesn't matter here for Vins taking it
down.
>> Vins really proving that Draven might
have lost some toys, but he has plenty
more to play with.
>> Yeah, I mean it's not a secret. I think
a lot of people who were paying any
amount of attention to the meta knew
that yes, some versions of Draven are
gone. Yes, we're not seeing the detonate
versions. We're not seeing the the
miracle versions at all. But mid-range
Draven, I mean, that is a that is a
consistent deck of consistent decks, if
I've ever seen one. You're playing the
best stated units. You're playing some
of the most versatile spells. And oh, by
the way, every time you win a combat,
you draw a card.
>> Yeah, I mean, that's pretty good as far
as abilities go. If I had to pick one
for myself, I'd want to always draw
cards.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think if you pulled most
card gamers from any card game across
all time, if you could ask them what
their favorite thing to do is, what the
strongest thing you can be doing is, uh,
what the most consistent thing you can
be doing is, it is drawing more cards. I
know many players will choose to draw
cards instead of winning the game. And I
am one of those players.
>> Yeah, honestly, same. And to be honest,
Draven proves why.
>> Yeah. And it shows us time and time
again that that ability being so crucial
>> can just wing the turn
so much in your favor.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's a problem.
>> Combat is a very natural part of this
game.
>> We need to see showdowns in Battlefield
>> to be able to progress.
>> And that's where Draven really pulls
forward. The only things that Draven is
going to naturally struggle against are
things which are not having combat
within Battlefield. If you're able to
remove and push things back,
>> that's much more advantageous against a
deck like Draven. Whereas in that
matchup, unfortunately, in game three,
especially,
>> combat was a moot point. We had to do
it. There was no other choices that were
going to stop the overwhelming mighty
units on board.
>> Yeah, it's it's just a really tough
thing to do to fight a deck that is
trying to get you into combat. Hey, I'm
playing this Ferris 4Runner here. How
are you going to deal with it? Well, if
you want to deal with it with spells,
it's going to cost you a lot and you're
going to fall behind that way. Maybe I'm
not drawing cards, but if you're
spending two cards to my one card,
that's kind of like drawing a card,
right? So, it's it's getting that card
advantage slowly and surely one way or
the other. And I mean, we saw it we saw
it come ahead there. And when the cards
you're drawing are also cards like
Ferris 4runner, that's not a bad place
to be.
>> No. And we've established that Ferris
4Runner, a great way to deal with it is
to play your own Ferris 4Runner. But
when one of you has an ability when you
win a combat and the other doesn't, even
if that original Ferris 4runner loses in
combat, you've then got the two mechs
which individually can then try again.
So no matter what, you're always trying
to get into these high combat
situations, even if you're just putting
a ferris out there to see if your
opponent will respond in tow.
>> Yeah. And as we saw in I believe it was
game one, Draven has a relatively clean
way to deal with Ferris foreigner. That
is a rebuke. It goes uh it goes to hand.
Kaisa does not really have that ability.
But one thing that we have Amy is a
winners interview ready. Let's throw it
over to the stage.
>> Thank you Vince. I'm standing here with
Vince. Congrats on your win. You're now
5 and0. And I would like to ask you why
Draven mid-range? Um, I feel like draven
mis range is the best choice when you
play against a lot of decks because
before the banet cards the people were
like building their deck to not go in
battlefield in the showdown. But now
it's not the case anymore because there
is less Draven.
>> So I feel like when you play against
like five, six, seven legends in the
tournament is good to pick it because
you will be nice. The problem is Ireelia
is the best legend in my opinion. So,
>> so yeah, I just took the control pick
and uh we'll see how it goes.
>> Yeah. So, you play mid Draven before the
bands as well.
>> Miracle.
>> Miracle. Okay. So, same as me. Anyway,
yeah, we I love that miracle deck, but
it is now Mid Tra. I wanted to ask you
the one thing since the ban of
Vanquisher got in. How did you solve it
in your deck? What do you do typically
on round two on turn two? Oh. Um, I
choose to play more uh two mana cost
because I was like, okay, the four uh
four mana champion is gone. You can't
play rail because it's not that good.
>> I feel like uh Rexai is not that good.
And I don't like also the rumble. I saw
some people doing that. So I just play
11 turn two instead of nine. So I hope
to do like turn two and then turn two
plus upful Noxus.
>> Yeah. and that's how I play. But uh
yeah, we just have Kesan now as a focus.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that that's true. But
anyway, so in this iteration of the meta
game, what do you think is your worst
possible matchup?
>> Um I feel like I'm okay against
everything. There is like some some
matchups that are dice roll dependent
like Ielia. If I lo the dice, I always
lose to one.
>> Okay. Um, mirror match is also dice roll
dependent I feel like because if when
you stack a battlefield in like the
first game it's really hard for your
opponent to to push.
>> Mhm.
>> So I would say I don't want to play
against Ireelia.
>> That is interesting because before the
bands it felt like worst match up was
actually mid-range raven. So what do you
think that is now that is different? Uh
the the big difference is rivers row
because with mid with mid-range draven
sorry before the bands you were able to
protect your uh units
>> by like putting back base but now you
can. So if you want to go to like 3 4.56
you have to put some units but I will
value trade them
>> and it's not that easy to go to the
classic brainer and rebuke.
>> It's not that easy I think.
>> Okay. All right. Well thank you very
much for the interview. Hope you're
going to win your next rounds. You have
still three to go, so still longer ahead
uh road ahead of us. And thank you very
much and good luck. And we're going to
go through back to the casters.
>> Wow, a lot of great insight there. And
it's really crazy how just a couple of
cards, I mean, a lot of pivotal cards
getting banned can change not only, you
know, some decks coming in, moving out,
but also changing the matchup spread of
a deck. We're seeing now, you know,
mid-range Draven used to be a really
good matchup into Aurelia. Now the the
player who is 5 with Draven says, "No,
that's actually my worst matchup right
now.
>> I don't want to see them anymore."
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I mean, that's the power of the
comfort pick as well, like you said,
>> being able to pick something you're
comfortable with, something you're
experienced with, and you know a lot of
the ins and outs of the matchups
already. So then you just need to adapt
to the little things. And if you do get
caught up caught off by a matchup you're
not too familiar with, you're so
familiar with your own deck that
actually you can figure it out along the
way.
>> Yeah, you can know what your deck is
doing. I mean, that's a part of the game
that you need to understand anyway. You
need to know the big picture plan. What
is your deck trying to do into other
matchups? when you've played your deck
across, you know, multiple sets
potentially and and you're just adapting
to the new things that are coming, it's
a lot easier to know, oh, okay, I don't
need to think about every single
interaction. I know roughly what I'm
doing. I know the the big picture plan
for my deck, and I know how to execute
that against this type of deck, even if
I don't know every single card in that
deck.
>> That's exactly what it's about.
>> Yeah. If I went up against a Rumble, for
example, I'd be like, well, I kind of
only just know what I'm doing. But I
know I know my deck and I know what I'm
doing. So, as long as I stay on track
with that and I'm scoring points, then
we're good.
>> Yeah, I know what I'm doing as Lucian
against most decks. It's the same thing.
And ignoring what my opponent is doing.
But one thing I don't want to ignore,
Amy, is some awesome interview content
that we have. Let's throw it over to
Barcode.
I'm here in the Grand Pal in Liil,
France for the Reebound Regional where
thousands of competitors have gathered
for only one goal, trying to win it all
and bring it home. For the next few
minutes, I'm going to show you the
entire venue and what it is all about
for this event. Come with me. Right now,
we're in the entrance of the event where
you can find those beautiful art of the
most iconic champions of League of
Legends and Rebound. Therefore, you can
see this orange, this Renata glass, but
also this very beautiful Darius.
Beautiful, isn't it? Now you have your
booster packs, but you don't know where
to open them. No worries, we've got you
covered. Let me introduce you to the
unboxing booth.
The opening booth is a really cool place
where you can just open your booster
packs in front of camera. That's already
really cool. But the coolest thing is
that let's see if you get a hit like I
wish I had. Oh, there is a chaos rune.
What you can do is basically press the
buzzer. Right now, I'm in front of the
main event area where all those players
will be gathered to try to win it all.
For now, the place is pretty empty, but
I can already feel the energy building
up. And in a few minutes, I'm sure that
there will be a lot of battling here. If
you feel like you want to do some posing
and get some memories of the weekend, no
worries because I've got something for
you. Here is the photo booth where we
can just get some pictures, print them,
and get them back home. Let's take one.
Wow, look at that. Don't I look amazing?
And right behind me there is one of my
favorites of this venue. This is the
gravity wall, which is literally the
living memory of what players do during
the weekend. So, if you feel like you're
being creative and want to do some
gravities, messages, whatever you want,
just take a pen when you have some free
time and write something down.
If you'd like to relax, chill, and just
have a few games outside of the
tournament, no worries. You can just go
into the free play area, and this is the
perfect space to have some chill games.
So, feel free to come if you have some
free time. You can just ask some people
to have some chill games. I know, I know
some of you don't actually know how to
play the game yet because we have a demo
area where you can just learn the game.
So, even if you don't know how to play
it and we've got some friends, you can
just come here and a lot of players will
just teach you how to actually play the
game and become a real champion. After
that, if you want to just buy some
cards, you will be able to do so. So,
feel free to come and learn how to play.
I'm sure that a lot of you are very good
at the games and I know that you will
earn some points. So, here is the prize
wall where you can use all your points
to just get some really cool products.
for example, display mats, sleeves, but
also some displays to get even more
cards. But most importantly, for only 40
points, you will be able to get your
hands on those beautiful metal cards.
And I'm sure a lot of you wants to have
at home. I mean, having this Diana, for
example, this Kazix, but also this Teemo
looks absolutely amazing.
There's a game going on. If you do not
want to miss any play, you can come here
in the watching area where you can have
all those game all day long. You can
even react with the crowd which is right
behind me. That's pretty cool, right? If
you do not participate in the main
events, no worries because there's going
to be a lot of side events all day long.
So, do not hesitate to register in those
events. And by the way, all the
registrations are literally made online.
So, this is very, very simple. And
there's going to be a lot of side
events, for example, the free-for-all,
deconstructed, but also the very awaited
2v2, which I know a lot of you are in
fond of. So, if you've got some free
time, do not hesitate and come get some
more tournament experience. So, whether
you're here to play the tournament, to
create some memories, or to just leave
and enjoy the game with the community, I
mean, this venue is literally made for
you. So, feel free to come here because
there is a space for every single one of
you. We'll be more than happy to welcome
you and to enjoy this beautiful game.
Rebound.
I'm now with a very special one. Voytech
right now at a record of 40. And you
would probably think that he's playing
maybe Draven, Kaisa, something like
that. But what are you actually playing?
>> I'm playing Crumble Mechanized Manz
and I'm doing pretty well so far for
myself.
>> I've been so far so good actually.
You're literally undefeated. The
question I had for you is basically why
did you pick this legend? because this
is not the best legend to be honest to
be fair and a lot of players have just
decided to play some Arzo legends. So
why did you decide to play rumble?
>> Yeah. So um basically I'm a big Kaisa
player player from the start of the
reband. So from set one and rumble is
pretty similar of course the same
colors. So it's pretty similar to Kaisa.
Of course you play still cars like
falling star like singularity but you
are more focused on the combat. And I
think after the bans actually rumble of
course it's not like the best leg
legends of course the the metal card
factor is still there but I think like
with the bans of uh especially fight or
flight uh it's like pretty good for
rumble because of course with the
hero ability that gives shield plus one
your ferros forrunner is seven on the
defense and like if people can't like
simply fight or fly the ferrus forrunner
h it's like pretty pretty good for Lambo
and I'm also experienced with the deck.
I played it as well in Bolognia. I made
day two with Rumble there as well. So
hopefully I can I can finish well on
this tournament as well. It actually
makes a lot of sense. I mean Rumble has
a lot for it and I mean you explained it
very very very well. The question is
where do you think you can just uh what
do you think you can just do with the
deck basically? Do you think that you
can win it all? Do you think that you
can expect a top eight or day two would
be very good indeed?
>> Yes. So I as as I said I already made
day two in Bolognia. So I'm hungry for
more than that. But I don't think that
yet we have everything in the deck that
the deck can top eight. But I think the
six top 64 and the qualification for the
regionals is like in the reach. So maybe
I'm hoping for that like maybe in like
some next set we will get some more
mechs and then the Rumble will will be
time to shine.
>> I mean this is actually so cool to see
you with such a big smile playing your
favorite legend. That's actually so
good. Wish you the best for the next
round. But for now we're going to jump
to some more content.
>> Thank you very much Barcode. Yeah, this
is what we're here for. It's back here
as well. all this riffbound RQ Leal.
James and Loth are taking you through
all of the action on the even rounds
today. We got rounds two, we got round
four, we got round six, and we'll do
round eight, you and I.
>> So, we're set up for success because we
go from six to eight as well so easily.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> And not from six to seven.
>> No, we we want to reach the uh the even
points. Although Amy and Leven, they're
just constantly playing uh Aspirin's
climb. They only want to be on the odds
>> and they're on the back foot all the
time. Ah, riff fan jokes, riffan jokes.
We We've got them in, you know, in
abundance. But ever nevertheless, we are
getting closer to round six. We're not
quite there yet. Um, of course, as as we
we say when we come back from another
round, uh, the pairings have to go up.
The players have to be ready. Um, there
are nearly 2,000 players in the
auditorium here playing. So, that level
of organization requires putting things
all in a row.
>> Look, I will tell you one thing. At
least we don't have printed out pay
rings anymore. Because back in my day,
you know, when they were going to a big
tournament that back, I don't know,
let's say 20 years ago, and you were
going to like a tournament where there
were like 800 people, 800 people had to
check out the pairings on a printed out
paper just somewhere there like on the
wall and you had to like climb through
people, mountains of people to just get
to your table, you know. So whereas
definitely upgrade
>> yeah a much bigger upgrade with cardio
uh who people will be familiar with that
if you are using uh the system at your
nexus night similar skirmish you'll have
all of that nice event information all
your pairings and stuff like that comes
all the way through so very much a
benefit in that and of course if you are
looking to get into the competitive side
of Riftband Nexus Knights is a great
place to start then summon a skirmish
and you can get yourself a buy for round
one of an RQ means you have to play
seven rounds of Riftbound on day one
instead of eight because if you think
about We're only on round six now, so
the people that had an extra hour sleep
might very well be feeling a bit better
about their day.
>> And I would say that maybe if you have a
buy on day one, then maybe you could
consider playing an actual deck that
plays a little bit, you know, prolonged
game
>> because your opponents out.
>> Yes, exactly. So you're playing a little
bit, you know, more complex deck, but
because you played one turn, one round
less, maybe you'll be less fatigued
because of that. Right. It was an actual
real concern in Bolognia when people
were trying out like playing the Ezreal
control list or um a miracle deck list,
right? Because they are both known for
like being a little bit more complex to
play. You have to do more with
decisions. So maybe if you actually play
one more round, it's not a wise choice.
>> Yeah. And and that's something that when
you are doing your deck construction and
your preparation for an event, those of
you that are not seasoned competitive
players, you may underestimate the speed
of your deck will determine the speed of
your breaks in between the games. If
you're playing a long lateg game deck,
do not expect to get time for food. You
going to have to go round into round
into round
>> or for toilet.
>> That's a very good one. That's the same
with us on broadcast. When you get a
long series, we're like, "Hang, how long
have we got as a as a break?" Now, as I
said, we we are keeping an eye on a lot
of players throughout the tournament.
We've kept an eye on performance. At
some point, we will drop back in on our
uh our featured players throughout the
day. I've spoken to a few of them.
Randy, I saw in between rounds. Uh does
have one. I believe he's 4 in one
following round five. Uh Kasanova is
also four in one.
>> I I met him at in the toilet.
>> You you had that break. You had the the
time to have a quick conversation. Um a
lot of course of good players here on
day one. And you know, fascinating. I
don't know whether we have the stats to
do this later, maybe uh after the
tournament. I would love to see the
percentage of players that got a buy and
how many made day two. Like how
successful is getting the buy with
regards
>> statistically speaking, most of them are
there's definitely going to be more
people with buys in day three than not
because of the reason is that they got
the buy in the first place, which means
they're winning. That means that they're
definitely the better type of players,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, at least they should be unless
they play like a skirmish with three
people or something like that, you know.
>> Support your skirmishes. Get out of
skirmish. Make sure those numbers uh
stay so that the good players get
through. Uh good players. Good players
in Riftband. If I was to pick one player
who I thought was really good at
Riftband, I might pick our champion from
RQ Bolognia. Let's hear from Alan right
now.
And we are back on the floor. I'm with
Alan ZQ, the one and only, the Azville
master. How are you doing, Alan?
>> Very good. Uh, so far a great
experience, good travel, no jet lag. Uh,
playing on the European soil is just
something else.
>> Oh, great. So, you are coming here as
the returning champion from Bolognia.
Does it add any extra pressure on your
shoulders?
>> Uh, definitely a lot of people rooting
for me and uh, there is no failure
that's accepted.
>> I mean, for now it's going pretty well
for you. How is going your tournament
>> so far? Yesterday was a 5-0 split. Today
it's 40. So goes as well as it can. Had
a nice various matchups so far. Last
round was a Darus. It was pretty close
uh in one of the games, but ended up
pulling it through.
>> So that's pretty cool. So you're still
playing Ezreal, which is your favorite
legend by far. You've been playing it
since the beginning of the set, too. And
you're pretty good at it. Let's face it,
you know. Um, the question I have to ask
you is, do you think that the control
version is still untouched or do you
think that the tempo version that we've
seen recently is better than this
version?
>> I mean, I'm playing technically the
tempo or control based on my card draws.
I can play both game plans based on what
I draw. And the problem with the tempo
is it has a lot of bad top decks if it
doesn't draw well. And it has way more
polarized matchups where good matchups
become even better and the worst
matchups become worse. So I'd rather put
myself in the middle where I can just
skill gap people instead of relying on
my cards.
>> It kind of makes sense to be honest. And
I've got a question for you, a personal
question. And I think that at home a lot
of you have literally the same question.
You always look so confident when you
are playing. You look like you just find
always the right move. Is there
something that you can just give as an
advice for people who want to do
literally the same thing at home?
>> I mean I just don't have a job that I
play reef bond for a living. So
definitely that helps. Don't take this
an advice. Absolutely not. Don't quit
your job to play Rand. But just make
sure you enjoy the game. Don't be result
oriented and make sure you play the best
game every time you can.
>> I mean, yeah, it makes sense. Another
question about that, but do you feel
some pressure sometimes or are you
always very relaxed?
>> Uh, between the runs maybe a bit, but
like when I'm in the game, there is
absolutely no pressure. There's just me
and cards and opponent. Finally. Are you
ready to win it all?
>> Oh, absolutely. Going to run it back.
Going to double it down.
>> Okay, that was Alan ZQ, the returning
champion for Bolognia and maybe the next
champion. Who knows? Back to you guys.
Welcome back to our Q Le here for
Riftbound. Uh, always lovely to hear
from Allan in that interview with with
Barcode. Um, and you know,
>> I love Barcode's enthusiasm for asking
everybody if they feel ready to win the
tournament. I will say Allan's the first
person when he's like, "Yeah, I'm going
to win the tournament." I'm like, "Uh,
yeah, okay, probably." If I had to
>> have a high chance of that actually
happening, you know.
>> I I believe it. I believe it. I I to to
give Alan the uh the PR spin on the
whole like I have no job so I'm playing
Riftbound. What he's saying is practice
a thousand games and you'll be great at
a deck. Uh and then you can win.
>> Card games are a game of knowledge.
>> So to gather knowledge, you need to put
the effort in to gather knowledge, which
means you probably have to play the game
a lot and then analyze the game and
learn from them. And I can tell you that
all of the top players are doing that.
Like they are putting the effort in.
They are not just like skimming through.
This is not like a dexterity based game
when you have like natural talent and
you're going to be winning because of
that. You actually have to put in the
reps. You need to understand what the
game is about, how it's revolving uh
around like new informations and how do
you adjust your deck as well. It's one
of the most important skills. How to
modify your deck to fit into the new
metag game or like expected metag game.
>> Yeah, that's a very fair point. That is
one of the skills you have to have to be
a player at the top of the game. And
let's look at some players that may or
may not be at the top of the game. I'm
assuming some of the people on this list
are like, "Why have you got me here? I
was just here for vibes." Like Kasanova,
who's on the second page, but Marshall,
you can see uh four and one. Allan,
yeah, no surprises to be undefeated on
5-0. Rap Solo 41. Vince, who we just had
in the feature match going to 5 and0 as
well.
>> Great interview by him by the way.
Really liked it with the answers that he
was giving me like around the Urelia
match up and so on. That's something
that we might actually bring up later on
when we see more Draven matchups.
Unfortunately, the right side of our
previous screen was not quite as
successful as we were looking, but they
are still in the running. Very many of
them. Castanova, as we said, four and
one has gone from the cast desk to the
player desk for the event and is doing
well so far. Uh, especially the the best
of Teemo from Bolognia, right? Is this I
believe so. I I'm pretty sure that's why
we've got him on the list. three and
two, not out of the running, but
certainly, you know, needs to convert to
day two, needs to have that that high
placement in order to look for that. And
I saw T the Bose uh post a little
earlier about unfortunately having some
some difficult matchups in the hunt for
the Garen best of um we'll see how that
actually goes through. So, let's look at
the stat
little bit.
>> Tell me all about it.
>> Olish is a friend of mine. He's always
was playing uh Kai'Sa in set one. Then
for set two he was playing Miracle
Draven a lot. But he actually swapped
after Bolognia
>> because in Bolognia he was playing
Miracle but he swapped to midrange
Draven because he said it's just more
stable. It's just more consistent. So I
would not be surprised. I mean of course
it has to be mid Draven now because
there's nothing else. So he's doing
well. 5-0 from
>> 5-0. And as we go down the list the
champions suddenly change in the middle
of the screen. Although now they uh as
we've swapped over two different legends
uh there actually are undefeated Jinx I
believe Ranata Glask Yasuos
>> Renata Glass undefeated.
>> We are going to step into our next
feature match up also highlighting some
lesser scene uh legends although we are
going to focus with the view of the meta
as well. Um so that's a little bit of
the the the standings as we go through.
There are some uh some updates that need
to come through on this one. But uh
>> I'll tell you one thing though. Yeah. If
Treecore, I I think that's how you read
his name, is five and zero of Ranata,
he's like single-handedly pulling up the
win rate of Ranata, like skyrocketing.
Like, it's crazy because in the matchup
spreads and like in in in some past um
tournaments, I believe Ranata was like
at sitting at like the bottom of like
20%
win rate, something like that. Here,
100% 50- Wow, that is
>> already
track. Yeah, that is like we could
basically start giving you the best off
right now. like it's it's there. All you
got to do is win one.
>> This is actually possible.
>> Exactly. It could very well be. So, uh
we are keeping track of a lot of
stories. Uh and somebody who is helping
us keep track of the weekend, keep track
of the stories, keep track of the best
of is Barcode. We're going to hear from
him right again now.
>> Yeah, tracking the stories indeed. And
for the rock strategies enjoyers, I've
got some very good news for you. I've
been walking near the top tables and
I've got some very interesting legends.
I've seen some jinx do really well in
the top tables, but I've also seen some
very interesting legends from the set
one, especially the set that I know a
lot of you like a lot. So, we're going
to keep track of those very rugg
strategies throughout the day and see
how they do. Can they do it till day
two? Can they do it till top eight?
We're going to see that very soon. But
for now, we're going to go back to our
commentators.
>> Thank you very much, Barco. That is us.
That is us. We're definitely ready. Uh
definitely good to get into game uh very
soon. I mentioned as we uh left the
standings that we were looking at that
we were going to go into some
interesting somewhat meta picks or at
least uh around the edge. Yeah, here we
go. It's a master Yi as an undefeated 5
and0 going up against Kaiser. So, one of
our top players as well is uh Louie
Fishbot.
>> Yeah, he's fishb bread.
>> Yeah, fish bread.
>> Literally fish bread. He's fishbread.
And uh taking Kaiser to this match up.
So, we we kind of know what Kaiser does.
Uh we we've seen a lot of
>> We can see two different archetypes.
>> True. So, one might be the more
mid-range based with like a lot of more
units or we're going to see the other
one which is get excited.
>> Here we have the deck list. Let's take a
look. The previous guys that we just
watched in the in the game before was
playing get excited. This one to some
degree looks like a sealed deck. What is
going on?
>> There's a rumble hot in here. There's a
gem jammer.
>> Gem jammer.
Interestingly enough, you can see like
some kind of usage of the rumble with
the singular game jammer because you can
like replay those units. You can recycle
them to get more more value out of the
mechs with the red rumble and red rumble
is still a forrop with no power cost.
>> I was going to say we did see mech
Kaiser right at the beginning like even
in the pre actual release spirit forge
people were like mechaiser is going to
be a thing. Uh, and then it turns out
that the other decks were were kind of
just better than that. So, a little bit
of that flavor coming through here. But,
uh, a legend that will get love even
more so in the next set with Unleashed.
Uh, Master Yi coming in undefeated at
this point. There are two different
Master decks.
>> Yeah, this is this is not this Master.
By the way, we are not playing the
experience one yet. We're playing the
auto. Ah, yeah.
>> Yeah, exactly. This one is the one we're
playing. I was going to say there are
two versions. The one we will not talk
about is Aurora, cuz you do not see an
Aurora listed here. This is mid-range Y.
So, it kind of puts big units uh at a
battlefield that are somewhat fair.
You're not cheating them out. It's not
huge units, but you you put sizable
things on a battlefield and then have a
lot of spells to keep them alive.
>> If I'm not mistaken, I wasn't like
counting fast enough, but I think he had
six two drops if I'm not mistaken um in
the mid-range mid-range master. There
were also
>> guardian angels if I'm not mistaken also
for copy. So there's a very pretty high
chance of actually getting a turn one
play um from this deck even though it
might be a guardian angel. But still if
you go like guardian angel into a
Stellacorn Herder that's something that
players love doing and Masi also would
love to be doing because this this
combination of colors which is green and
orange kind of struggle with the Katrol.
>> You have a lot of other stuff right
which is like the passive that gives you
just access to very high amount of might
by default when you're standing alone on
battlefield. It's hard to break for a
lot of decks. And in case of Kai'Sa,
she's going to have a problem dealing
with combat when it comes to master to
master units. But the the thing that is
going to be important for Kai'Sa is
actually drawing
damage based removal because that goes
around the master's passive.
>> Exactly. And and it's important that you
have to use it then outside of that
combat situation, right? It's like that
will only apply when the unit is
defending. Um whereas if Kai see you're
just using it anytime in your turn
you're you're you're good as long as
you're not in the middle of the
showdown. Rumble comes forward already
the one copy of the red rumble comes in
and is actually impactful because it has
assault one. So if this porro goes now
to the void gate then it can just get
run over by the rumble by default
because it's a five might. Yeah, that's
actually very true because once you
start piling on that uh master yi
passive as you were talking about would
give you defensive statistics. So
offering up the trade saying you can
lose your parro I want the card that is
what that uh two
>> two two cost unit is going to be is that
is uh an Aurelia played.
>> Mhm. And this is something that is very
annoying for the Kaiser to deal with.
Yeah. What how do you deal with this?
like do you just do a falling star in
the back and lose four runes? Not the
best idea.
>> It's an awkward uh mindset shift, right?
Is normally you see Aelia and you're
like, well, okay, she's probably going
to move around battlefields and then um
>> here it's completely different.
>> Exactly. It's like, okay, she might
actually sit at a battlefield for a
little while and then get a plus two
when she's defending and then you've got
to worry about the normal Aurelia stuff.
So, um excited to see this Mastery E.
It's one of the reasons why this is
picked for our feature match is I'm like
I want to see how it plays out at a
competitive level against good players
like uh Luis Fishb who as we said also
five and zero uh towards the top. So
this is a very important game cuz
getting to six wins uh qualifies you for
day two, right? This is winning in cuz
getting to 18 points
>> and X and 2 is essentially cut off to
day two. At least it was in Bolognia.
>> Yes, it was the same in Bolognia. Uh
lots of rounds of riftbound between then
and and now. So my brain is uh making
sure I've got everything. Yeah, it's 18
points needed to advance. So going to 6
and0 would be enough to qualify for day
two for these players.
>> Important match ahead of both both of
them. And here of wakes up in the turn
with the five might which is now also
important because we're playing against
a not a rumble. So this rumble on the
battlefield is a four might. And in this
case, oh we have to pay one more for the
deflect.
We'll see if that is being caught on.
>> Yeah. And uh just as a reminder, we
actually do not have an uh this is a
reminder for people at home. We are not
influencing the game. Um the judges will
be called if a player calls for a judge.
A judge is not there to mediate the
table. Part of that is because everybody
else in the hall does not have somebody
telling them every single rule. We don't
have like 2,000 judges uh to to follow
on from.
>> Imagine.
>> I know that every table with a judge
next to it. then you want the judges to
play like they'll they'll see the
tournament on top of it as well. So we
will of course keep our eyes on that as
much as possible but there are
situations where the players it is their
responsibility to pick up on that um as
we go. So the hexag ray is resolved. The
three damage is being dealt to the
irrelia fervent. Now she is on five.
That means that two will kill her.
Angard gives plus three in this case and
goes out of the lethal range. Ah, yeah.
You've always got to remember the the
Aurelia target as well on top of that
spell. That I think that's one of those
ones that that trips people up is it's
not just plus one and then plus another
one. There's one one more plus one from
the Aurelia being targeted. So, we'll be
able to get through that situation. Ruin
Runner comes out and this is a card that
ruins Kaiser's day a lot of the time
because so much of Kaiser's ability to
clear things is targeted.
>> When you think about it, the both of
Urelia and Ruin Runner have kind of a
similar function. essentially um ruin to
some degree I would even say it's worse
in this particular matchup you would
rather have probably irrelas that are
just capable of doing more on on uh
attack than the rune runner but and also
on defense like there are just less
>> if even if your opponent will interact
with them you can actually bait them
into burning a lot of their resources
because you can still have counter spell
right with rune runner they will just
not be played
>> as as good as perhaps it felt at moments
for the master we were talking how that
last exchange went there. This has been
a a consistent route to four points now
for uh for Luis who it's a little early
for what we would normally see a
thousand tailed watcher but in this
situation it has to break through the
Aurelia. You you can get through without
paying uh anything for deflect. Of
course, you have to pay for the
acceleration um on the thousand tailed
watcher which is why Louis has no uh
blue runes available anymore. But from
this point, normally it's a lot of red
runes that get played out from the
Kaiser. And here comes Master Yi
>> with the discipline goes over the
Watcher. And now both the the B is just
cleaned up. And if Kai'Sa doesn't have a
good way of coming back by deleting the
units, but also building a board state,
that is a problematic position to be in.
>> There's two things that that make this
difficult. One, you can't singularity
anyway because of Ruin Runner. And two,
you only have one blue rune anyway. So
even if you could target everything,
>> well, you can't pay with the Kaiser.
>> Ah, yes. That's always the benefit of
Kaiser. Thank you. That's You know what?
It's been so long since I've actually
played Kaiser that it's like I kind of
forget that that's there. You're right.
It is enough. But of course, can't
target Ruin Runner. Nevertheless, with
the uh singularity or anything that does
target that will be a stupify on master
to that is not something that you see
often by the way. um that we have a
vision from a unit being played.
>> Yeah, I uh always love the ability to
look at the top of the deck. There's
that
>> another por I mean sorry another two
drop and noxious. So now
>> master has an ability to set up
defenses. This is a very big deal
because he was completely tapped out.
That gives you a moment where you have
certainty of how much exactly power
might can be spent and and uh sorry
power can be spent to buff up the might.
But now with such amount of resources is
a 10 3 6 7 8 9 10. It's 10 resources 10
energy possible. So not only that if you
use the
>> forge of the fluff you can move the
guardian angel without even spending
your um runes. So, you're going to be
able to go up to 12 in the followup. So,
you're going to be able to have a
secondary wave of units coming from your
base even if those um battlefields are
broken for some reason, right? And ruin
runner most likely is going to have to
be attacked by a huge amount of might.
And we already have seen one watcher
being gone. So, that is one of the outs
a little bit like, you know, um the odds
of seeing another one are just smaller
because of that. So we can play with
this in mind.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So we play a ruined runner
>> that will turn off the the master. Okay.
But it would be reasonable as well to
just still have two units even in the
master e deck on a battlefield.
Sometimes it just makes sense because
when you think about it, it's just minus
two. But overall it's overall plus
whatever else you're playing. Exactly
that. And also it's very important to
understand that even if one of those
units can be like deleted before the
showdown, then the other unit will get
the bonus, right? So you kind of have
like an insurance to some degree.
>> Yeah. As uh we go back to Kaiser's turn.
So stacked the board of decent units at
least. Well, I say decent. Normally,
you'd think that they would do the job,
but against the master, it does make it
tricky to get past some of these uh some
of these battlefields.
>> So, it's eight might that is on the ba
in the base from Fish Pro. And in case
of the defenses here, we have a ruin
runner. Oh, there's the second washer.
That's crazy. That was actually our
second one. So now we're going to have a
five might on defense ruin runner on
forge of the fluff and a two might uh
four might uh ruin runner on voidgate.
>> And something for for newer players
perhaps that don't see thousand tail
watcher too much if your players at your
nexus knights don't do this. The reason
that it still applies to ruin runner is
watcher does not target the ability does
not target any individual unit.
Therefore, it gets around ruin runners
cannot be targeted uh claws on it. So,
still will give the minus three to
everything. That's a really important
interaction if you are on either side of
that matchup and and are less familiar
with it.
>> Yeah. And it cannot be not so faster
because of that.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
So it will be uh an influential moment
in the game now as uh Luis Fishbra
looking to get to six and Kaiser is
always in that moment of like all I need
is to get to six and then time warp is
online if I have it.
>> The thing is though that's still too
energy open for phase fuzz sorry I'm not
sure how to pronounce it but if there's
any punch first that will actually make
a huge difference.
>> Yeah that's very true. punch first. One
of the uh significant combat tricks uh
from Spirit Forge. I will say maybe it's
had a little bit less impact than I was
expecting now that we're looking back on
the entire set. Like
>> fight or flight was definitely making an
impact against
>> Exactly. I think that's half of that
reason, right? Is like when you punch
first and you get blown out by uh feels
horrible.
>> Recycling too and then you Oh, okay.
>> Well, it's actually punch last or punch
punch. Yeah, exactly. Uh and now that
fight or flight is out, we maybe have a
little bit more preman prominence in the
meta from some of our other domain
types.
We are in the middle of this showdown.
So we will see what the the what actions
are taken on either side.
>> Mhm. So we see a discipline in the hand
and that's going to do and that doesn't
make a lot of a difference for that
defense, but
>> it could be used to get additional card
draw and also maybe kill additional
unit.
>> Yeah, could be. Actually, no. It
wouldn't make no difference.
>> Well, he would be able to kill the
Noxus. Anyway, no point in discussing
this anymore. Let's go to the other one.
>> Yeah,
>> we have here a 7 to4. And if you're new
to the broadcast, you can see on the
bottom we actually have a very fast
updated amount of might on both
battlefields being mentioned at the
bottom of the screen. So, right now, we
can see it's seven for the Kai'Sa, zero
for the Master Y because he was the
unit, four on the other battlefield
because of the Noxful. So we can quickly
at the glance of an eye understand how
much might is actually present. This is
a very cool feature by the way.
>> Yeah, thank you to the team working
behind the scenes doing that one for us.
It helps us all keep in check
everything. That is another Ireelia that
has been drawn. Um
>> as we get keeper Yeah. will draw. Show
us the cards, bro.
>> Yeah. No, never never show the cards. Uh
just draw it to hand. Don't even look at
it.
It looks like it was uh
>> Zas.
>> Yeah,
>> I think that's Zas.
>> Oh, no, wait. Maybe that was Trinity
Force.
>> It looked like a Trinity Force to me at
first. I uh was going to say,
>> "Yeah, it might be Trinity Force."
>> Look, I have old I I have the excuse of
having bad eyesight.
>> The The screen is okay. This is just the
second half of the artwork. I'm like,
I'm pretty sure it is. That is tons of
damage uh in the hand of uh of FaZe.
kind of funny because it's not
>> No, I know, right? I'm like thematically
freak out there, League of Legends
commentator, uh, freak would be crazy
that they didn't just build in like
damage on Trinity Force.
>> Oh, we like giving plus stats to
everything
>> to everything. Yeah, I talk about being
old. I'm throwing you references from
like 14 years ago in uh in League of
Legends in the middle of a Riftband game
in 2026. But uh, Mastery is going to go
on the aggressive front. And of course,
we do now have um two energy up from
Kaiser. So that is plenty to do with uh
with this deck. Super is going to give
you another look at the top of the deck
as well.
>> That's about it. Now one energy is only
open. So the possible interactions are
limited. Typically on defense that would
only be like hexag in this case, a
stupify and nothing else.
>> Yeah.
>> Or the Kaiser. So now um Master has a
lot more information on how to approach
the fight on the auto battlefield. So we
got an we're getting a discipline goes
to seven, draws a card. We have Trinity
Force goes to nine and attacks into the
watcher and now basically cleans it up.
But there's a retreat and that will
allow most likely unless there's a defy
to set up a turn for Kaisan because now
we're going to be able to for seven.
Okay. The 100% he's going to have a
blue.
>> Yeah, blue runes coming off the top,
right? Like
>> So, he's going to have the accurate
option.
>> Yeah, the the math on the rune.
>> Oh, he already had a second one.
>> Yeah, they already did have a second one
that maybe we didn't see, but it would
it would come off the top as as the next
uh rune to be played.
>> But this also um tells you for Kai'Sa
here that there's absolutely no define
in the hand. So, you can have that
knowledge now in in this in this uh rest
of the game and play your spells
accordingly as well if you're going to
be wondering about it and if you're
going to be paying attention as well to
how your opponent draws your cards and
if he doesn't shuffle them in the hand,
although I know that almost never
happens with with tough players. But you
could read informations like which card
was drawn, which kind of was played and
then maybe even getting more
informations like which one could
actually be defy if it was drawn. Yeah,
shuffling your cards in hand has not
been banned in Riftbound.
Uh it is still possible to to mix it up
uh with what you've got as Louis Fishbot
looking to turn the corner on this one.
I think though with the bounce back of
the Thousand Tail Watcher. Yes, might be
able to play it here. No surprises that
it comes out of hand. What is on the
other side of this though? Where is the
rest of the turn? Because you have to
clear out both battlefields. So minus
three applied. So you got to go through
the ruin runner with the watcher because
you can't target the ruin runner with a
spell on the back end. So it has to be
watcher kills the runner.
>> Now you have something to deal with the
nasty falling star.
>> Falling star would be perfect in this
situation. And it lets you clear out a
backline, but it's going to be the hex
tech. Falling star still available to
clean out the rest or at least two of
the units in the back line.
>> They don't count as lonely when in base.
>> And now that means our master E player
has to clear out a thousand tailed
watcher. We know there was an Aurelia in
hand earlier
>> and that is not impactful at all
>> and no because you're not playing the
the legend. So you don't get the untap
ability doesn't get to enter ready. So
what else is available?
>> A charm would help for a little bit
because it will push away the watcher to
base
>> to move it and then you're not holding
you're you're just conquering.
>> Yep. Correct. Correct.
>> Ooh. What options are available? Is
there something? It looks like he's
cooking, but it's cooking slowly, so
it's not obvious.
>> Well, one more card to draw. That's
important to know because uh it is the
should be the winning point of the game,
but seven, of course, when you conquer,
you draw a card off that first conquer
of this turn.
>> H he looks phased.
>> Didn't didn't slam whatever it was that
came out of the
>> You didn't get my joke.
>> No, I I got it. I got
>> Okay. It was just not funny enough.
Okay. Oh, it was uh ah okay. I need to
what I'm what I'm hearing is I need
positive affirmation towards my co-
commentator in this game and uh some
positivity out of the hand is what uh
FaZe is looking for. Um
>> would love to see a hand so we can see
what he's thinking about. So we know
what is this
>> that looks like. So it's a charm and
Aelia. Um looking at what that second
one is. That's awk
Okay. Well, that actually is pretty
decent because pushing away if he really
does have a charm.
>> I'm pretty sure there is a charm in
hand.
>> He's moving the uh Trinity Force to one
of his units.
>> No, wait. What? Why you not doing it?
What? What?
>> With the the forge of the fluff, right?
You could
>> another equipment that we're thinking of
attaching
>> potentially. Potentially. So,
>> is there one in the hand? I'm dots.
>> Let the players figure this out. Who's
going to pay the charge?
>> Oh, we're actually trying to Okay. Okay.
Well, that actually Okay. Sometimes that
happens. Yeah. With the with thunk in
hand, it is going to follow up. Uh
>> like No, no, it's a good idea to put it
in the base so it can attack.
>> Oh, doesn't actually doesn't actually
use it. So looking to to keep the thunk
for an accelerated unit on the next turn
potentially as uh
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's a good setup. I like
it. It's way smarter than pushing the
unit to base.
>> Hey, you know, sometimes you just got to
win in an unorthodox way.
>> We are casting for I think already for
like my
>> Yeah, this is like nine hours of casting
essentially.
>> Sure. But these players have been
playing the entire time too, right? So
I'll give you yapping all the time. So
sometimes you will say something stupid,
you I I don't know whether it it matters
how long I've been casting for that. I
can still say something stupid. Don't
worry, I can do that day like round one
of the day for sure.
>> That was a smoke screen.
>> Yeah, not what they needed.
>> Scoop for game one, but a close game one
like really down to the wire. Um
correct.
>> Seven points against seven points right
at the end of things
>> for Luis Fish Pot, which is a very fun
name to say. um on the the Kaiser will
lose game one, but now we get to see
what comes in in the sideboard. So,
>> there's actually not that many cards
that actually matter.
>> Like bring here sure can help a little
bit, but it's not as important as
against Urelia for example, right?
Because you have actually more base
knight,
>> which is important, and you can still
reply with like buffs from hand with
discipline and guard and so on. From um
Master Yi's side though, what do we what
do we have here? Do you look at sabotage
coming in here?
>> Defy probably.
>> I guess not so fast is pretty key in
this. There's actually quite a lot of
cards here that I'm like I'd quite like
that in my sideboard in this match.
>> Yeah, I mean there's like considerations
I would say like three to four
considerations. Um not always everything
by the way because it does depend which
is very fun about refand is that the
uniqueness of site boarding when you're
going first or second.
>> Yeah, that's fair. So if you're going
second, you'll have more access to
runes. You can also plan if you want to
like maybe sideboard a card
>> that is uneven number of runes like
energy.
>> So you're able to play it on specific
timing in the game or for example if
you're going second you might side out
your two drops because you're having
like for example a champion unit that
you can play on turn one. So you don't
have to worry about a two drop when
you're going second, right? And in this
case you have more options when it comes
to sideboarding. And I always find, I
know it's actually not really that
impactful, but I always find when I'm
thinking about a 40 card deck and what
I'm sideboarding in and out, I'm like,
there is no room to make decisions
around like sideboarding too much out
because your main deck has to function.
Very few main decks have dead cards.
There are dead cards in certain
matchups, but in general, you're like,
well, these 40 are the ones that I need
to play the game. So, yeah, there's
there's a few things, but I always find
that interesting. kind of interesting
because in set one not many decks even
had any dead cards from what I at least
recall right now but in current metag
game some decks for example play main
deck equipment equipment hate
>> yeah like adeptatron and stuff like that
salvage yeah you can take those out in
other matches
>> rocket barage but barage has like two
options so it's not that unflexible but
the now in the current meta game there
is some potential to cards that are not
like completely unplayable in in a
specific matchuply So they're like dead
draws and you would definitely happy to
sideboard them out.
>> So really important game to here
obviously for both players but uh for
for FaZe or or FAZ however we're
pronouncing it. Um this would mean
having enough points to make day two
already regardless of their results in
the next two rounds. Of course, you want
to keep putting up the points because we
are obviously looking towards the top
start of the the standings and you know
there is always the conversation around
best ofs. Uh you want as many wins under
your belt just to put you clear of
everybody else that is playing the same
legend
>> specifically when you play those two
decks because they are actually pretty
popular. Both of them are in the like
top six when it comes to popularity.
>> Yeah, it would not surprise me would not
surprise me to see both of these decks
represented within the top eight. Um,
which of course then is uh, you know,
that's that's what you're looking for.
>> Although I will be honest with you, I
don't expect Aka into top.
>> You don't? That's a nice thing.
>> I don't because I feel like she doesn't
have a good matchup into Aurelia and
doesn't have good enough matchup to be
consistent against Draven unless you
build it in a way that it should punish
Draven, but then you're just losing
points in other matchups. So, I am not
personally expecting a Kaisen in the top
eight, but maybe I'm wrong. Who knows?
I'm just, you know, I'm just saying
stuff. No, I I think it's it's a very
valid thought. I mean, we had um believe
it was the same in Bolognia where like
Kaiser and and Aurelia performed well
day one and then as they hit each other
in the the the second round of day two,
we had some some really awkward matchups
for each each um deck. But let's focus
in on this essentially a win- in um as
we go into
our game two between these two. Valmore
up against the candle lit Sanctum. Um,
>> and we have a guardian angel opening.
So, what's this the followup? We see
punch first and a trinity force as well.
>> I mean, if there's Aelia, you got to
feel pretty good if it's in hand or Ruin
Runner would feel pretty good. Ruin
Runner with Guardian Angel for Kaiser
feels a bit nightmarish.
>> Yeah, but that's like two turns ahead.
Yeah. So, not really that important
right now because
>> in this case, um, we're going to have
we're going second as a master E. So,
we're going to be behind on board. We're
going to be behind on points as well
because we didn't play a two drop,
right? So, what is the plan on how do we
catch up over here?
>> And is that perhaps and and obviously we
don't know the sideboarding decisions
there is perhaps the sideboarding
decisions would say, okay, maybe we drop
one or two two drops as our sideboarding
uh like bringing in our our beneficial
cards. Maybe maybe the you're accepting
like oo I'm going to miss my turn one
but I know that my late late game is
stronger than it was in game one anyway.
>> We would have to ask him because that's
very hard to answer right now. What was
what was the sideboard in decision?
>> Which of course we don't show for people
that would give away a little too much
information.
>> And there's Rocket Bish over here that
let's see it's actually four damage to
Urelia.
And did we pay the deflect?
>> Once again, uh referring in that case,
uh the players of course are in control
of maintaining the board state. So, I
had glanced away at that moment and uh
>> I was going to say about the decision
there. Of course, some people might say,
"Oh, why don't you just take out the
guardian angel?" Well, Aurelia is going
to score points and you've already seen
that your opponent perhaps is low on
units in hand from no two drop. So, if
you keep the units down, guardian angel
does nothing on its own. It can just sit
in base all game and it has not affected
anything. And I feel like um Faza didn't
attach the guardian angel because he was
certain that if the opponent will just
do a falling star to kill the Ireelia
that's going to be so costly that he was
actually going to benefit from it. But
he didn't anticipate the um rocket bar.
That was really grim, right? That was a
really grim result um for for Faz. And
now let's see if he's gonna he for sure
should attach the guardian angel to the
master. No, because that's going to be
important. The ganking is an important
aspect as well of this character on one
of the battlefields because the other uh
other units the Kaisa and the Noxus are
actually stuck on the lair,
>> right? Because they they cannot return
to base from Vile Molay whereas as you
said ganking again for newer players
perhaps that don't play too much on
Voslayer uh prevents units from moving
back to base that also means from spells
and abilities doing it. However, ganking
you can move base uh you can move
battlefield to battlefield uh very
easily. Another rocket barrage. And
that's where you're like, really?
Really? You find it again. Uh, rocket
barrage into there's two runes turned
upside down. The falling star
>> is keeping on top of all of the units
from FaZe. And this is very quickly
going into Luis Fish Pod's uh favor. I
mean, five points to one. No units have
been able to stick from FaZe in this
game so far. Yeah, this is like a very
standard Kaisar like way of playing the
game. I'm just
>> punching your first repeatedly with a
lot of removal, a lot of base damage
removal. Sorry, damage base removal. So
for phase when he was not able to
counter spell anything or not so fast,
the guardian angel didn't get even value
because of the rocket powers.
>> Yeah,
>> essentially you're on mercy of your
opponent and in this case Kaiser draws
everything that was needed. the there's
some some tiny tiny tiny silver linings
I think for for phase as we up seven
points. Yeah, there's that's why I'm
saying it's a tiny silver lining. Can't
time warp this turn. Can't time warp
next turn. However, you'll lose the game
before that point because uh that is a
ferris 4runner going on to the candleit
sanctum. One ruin runner is probably not
going to be enough on its own with no ye
from the chosen champion zone. We'll see
what FaZe actually ends up pulling off
the top here. What's it going to be? Is
there anything really that can turn it
around? There's a lot of resources, but
are the cards even there?
>> I see.
>> He needs to push away two units. So, he
would need two charms, not into base.
And
>> yeah,
>> so you have to go over the Kaisa and the
Noxus most likely. But then again, even
if you kill
one draw, you you have the the combat
strength in hand. You just don't have
utility.
>> Two disciplines I think in hand. So
maybe you get lucky with like the two
best top decks. Is that two on guards?
Two disciplines.
>> There's one on guard. There's a trinity
force discipline.
>> I think the bottom card is an on guard
as well. Like the leftmost card. So
>> he definitely has.
>> You have the power. You just need the
the rest of getting everywhere.
>> So two charms back to back from the top
if he has potential card draw.
>> Maybe. Maybe. Let's see.
And that's still not winning, by the
way. That this is like surviving.
>> Okay, we're playing four. We're going in
to the Ferris um for a battlefield. So,
we're aiming to go for the sanctum to
dig a little bit for potential answers.
All right, there's the trade. I mean,
sorry, not the trade,
>> the the demolishing of of the the might
in that battlefield.
>> Confront and Aora. So the confront can
be drawn
>> kind of far again. But can Were there
any other units in hand? I
>> no that was a trinity for. So how much
energy do we have? We have still the
punch first. So if we if we play the
confront first we set it up. Confront
poro. So we can play confront for two
energy. Then play the draw the power
from confront. Play the porro. That's
four energy. It's ready. We can go up to
nine with the porro towards.
>> You're choosing between them, right?
Well, no. So, we just So, you're just
setting them up,
>> right? You're just setting them up.
Potentially has a way of breaking the
auto battlefield and living.
>> Is it uh discipline to draw the first
one?
>> Yes,
>> you get the confront.
>> Yes, confront. Now, you play the
confront.
>> It's going to be completely tapped out
by the way.
>> Yeah, this this being hellbent. Uh,
>> so there is the second card. So,
>> the tension the tension of the music as
well. I I'm I'm trying to do the math.
Is it even enough?
>> It is because it's eight on the
battlefield as our
>> Oh, he's going to show he's close. And
there's supery anyway. So, uh Luis
Fishbod uh lightning fast out of the
gate on that one in order to to to get
things done early on against the Y. And
that's one of the problems of this
mid-range Yi is
>> it has a lot of high cost units and if
they don't stick around, you're very
very slow off the mark of uh of actually
having that tempo. You said that that
maybe you know there's those two drops
in the board. We didn't see them. We
didn't see them in in this game too
dropping and and making an impact on the
battlefield early. Well, we've seen
Master Gi not equip the guardian angel
to the Aurelia on turn two and obviously
was setting up to play the Master G on
the follow-up, right? That was the idea.
>> Your most likely Aurelia survives
because your opponent doesn't want to
pay the deflect cost from like a falling
start. So, you're able to develop your
Master E from the champion zone. Then
after you do that, you can attach the
guardian angel either to Urelia or the
Master Y and try to take control over
the battlefields. Now the problem is
just one rocket barish just completely
nuked that plan because paying just one
cost of the rocket barriage with your
Kaiisa and then the deflect was just one
energy as well. Uh sorry, one rune as
well. It's not that high of a cost to
destroy the Aelia from the base. And
because we didn't have a two drop,
>> that's the reason why we just lost so
many points consequentially like
sequentially sorry uh during this game.
It it was really looking rough, but at
the same time, Kai'Sa had really great
answers in this game. It was really like
perfect moment for every single card.
The second rocket barrage was
>> huge at that moment where you're like,
well, you got both of them, so uh I
guess my luck has run out in in that
moment. Um really interesting matchup.
We of course will be going to game three
very shortly as the players are
sideboarding uh everything. Hello if
you're joining us late in the day or if
you're in America or perhaps another
region that has just woken up for the
day. Hello, welcome. Join us for some
Riftbound here at RQ Le. We'll be
watching your broadcast next week for RQ
Atlanta. So if you're in the area, make
sure that you uh get yourself over
there. I don't know where the tickets
are available. I'm assuming not anymore.
I'm assuming they have sold out.
Exactly. I'd be I'd be surprised too. uh
we wish you could join you as well but
we are having a great time in Le as our
players are trying to secure their day
two appearance. A win here for either
one in this game is going to secure
their spot among the day two
participants as they will reach 18
points. Uh it's not all over for the
loser. This isn't going home moment of
course. Uh you only have to reach six
wins throughout eight rounds today and
we still have two more rounds to go
after this. So on to Grover the
Godwillow on to Zorn Warren and I would
imagine Faze is the one that is going
first as being the loser in the last
one.
>> Pretty much you go first. Don't believe
the people that say you should play
second.
>> Don't believe him. There was maybe some
arguments to like go second with like
Lucian for example, but I
>> I don't believe those people that I
don't like what they're trying to sell
me.
>> Yeah, with the two build, you definitely
don't.
>> I I don't like what they're trying to
sell. Don't believe those people. Go
first. Play your cards first and uh and
play quickly as uh Okay,
>> we have a Yeah, we have a two drop. Oh,
okay. to drop into Stellicorn Herder is
like value town potentially for Miy only
red
>> available but Kaiser is there for uh for
for for tapping for four spells
>> but the thing is growth of growth of the
god willow will push Kaisa to try to
deal with the lonely porro
>> deal with the lonely porro Kaisa will
>> well I guess we have obviously combat
tricks available
>> could be also defy but preferably You
would probably do discipline to just
draw another one.
>> Draw a card and potentially
>> uh on guard would help as well as uh
>> oh not so fast. We're thinking others on
guard as well.
>> Everything does prevent you from playing
the teleorn herder though. So the other
option is do I just take the hit and say
yeah okay I hate that but I want to play
the teleorn herder and draw a million
cards. thing is if you just play the
Celicorn Herder, I'm the Kaiser. I am
playing a Falling Star if I had.
>> Yeah, I was going to say this is the
time where you're like, "No, actually
this is worth it. I will Damp. I will
use a big spelling in hand." So, you
just don't even give the draw. I'm like,
"I will damp for one in order to prevent
getting
>> the card draw of Stellorn."
>> Yeah, this is pretty big. Like imagine
we had the porro on the battlefield now
holding the grave of the god Willow and
the open of um open energy for the not
so fast as well or potentially any other
buffs. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Could have been pretty huge hold and now
Master Yi is again playing from the back
foot. We
>> behind on units. Yeah. And this is a
problem is when when you can only play
one unit a turn. Ruin Runnels will maybe
slow down Kaiser when you can only play
one unit a turn and Kaiser can use one
spell per turn and remove those units
quite effectively. It's difficult to
stabilize.
>> Of course, as we said,
>> Paris Pirana on the hold. Yeah. And now
we can see that the growth of the god
Willow actually will hurt actively the
master player. This is their choice when
it comes to the battlefield. And now
actually it pays pays dividends to the
Kaiser player.
>> That is not something that you expect.
And when you have access to almost
unlimited card draw as a Kaiser player,
well, you're just squirming. Like you
just
>> do we have enough in hand for phase to
get through this while the Kaiser's
shields are down
>> like Ferris four run. This is you know
that this battlefield is static at
eight.
>> Correct.
>> So you're like all I've got to do is get
over eight and then have enough on my
next turn because
>> there's guard only I think.
>> Yeah, there's an on guard. Yeah, I think
there's um I think there's a counter
spell in there as well.
>> So, and doesn't do anything.
>> Confront would be able to draw a card.
But the problem is if you actually just
play the Master Y with Unard, then
you're just losing your Master Y and
your opponent still has two mess in
base.
>> Yeah.
>> And if you leave them there, then the
problem is different kind of like this
is another card draw given to Kai'Sa
with the Grove of the Goodwill.
>> So, you have to roll the dice, look at
the top of the deck, and say, "Come on,
be be good for me. to me.
>> I don't know about that.
>> Or is there a world in which you uh Zorn
Warren discard a card, you have a
confront to play your next ruin runner,
and if it lines up, do you have enough
energy in order to
>> But ruin runner is not going to be
enough because the ruin run is a five.
Even if you on guard, it's only going to
be seven.
>> Five, six, seven, eight.
>> If you if you get another on guard, if
you rip another on guard, you barely do
it, right? five plus one for confront
plus one and one one for for two on
guards. It's it's like heart of the
cards top deck
>> moment to get through it if that's the
line.
>> Even if you do that, you're still giving
Kaisa the value of two max in base.
>> Yeah, that is very true. Who do answer a
ruin runner on its own?
>> Correct. So,
>> I mean, not not exactly because it's
going to be seven might and
>> Oh, because in master Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yes. That is a a great great thing to
remember. See, I told you these static
uh abilities do have a habit of uh of
getting forgotten as you go through
showdowns.
>> And what is the discard over here where
Okay, confront was being thought about
being discarded,
>> which is draw a card on it. I'm like,
>> well, essentially you just don't
pay for it, you know.
>> Exactly.
>> I think that might be the thinking.
Okay, show us.
>> Oh, and confront is two. Anyway, my math
was wrong. Um,
>> all right. We didn't see what was being
drawn. Oh, but it might It's a five. So,
I'm playing new, I think.
>> Ruin Runner or
>> Urelia
>> potentially.
Thinking about it,
>> man. This angle is killing me. Like, we
don't see the cars that
>> Oh, I think my math was wildly off
actually. Apologies to the stream for
that. I
It's been a long day.
>> There's the Urelia and a pass. So, Anora
draw. I mean, I'm not surprised. Like,
it's so hard to break this battlefield
with this with this setup from Kaisar,
but that's Anora card draw. That is
crazy.
>> Yeah, that is a lot of value coming from
>> another ruin runner. Sorry, Ruin Runner.
Ferris 4unner.
>> I mean, it is another runner. There's a
lot of runners. I wonder what kind of
shoes they have.
>> They do not have boots of swiftness,
that's for sure, in this deck.
>> Well, you need four for a ruin runner.
Yeah, you that's that's an illegal deck.
You're not allowed that one. Uh
>> true that
>> that is a stacked battlefield. Um
>> 12 might
>> and if you get through it, it spawns 12
might.
>> Yeah, that's surprising.
>> Yeah, big big old surprise on the other
side of that battlefield. Uh so
sideboard card in hand, that unyielding
spirit, it doesn't do anything right
now.
>> Doesn't matter. The two first paners are
invalidating essentially whatever is in
hand.
>> And this is a little bit of a situation
where we see maybe not in this match up
but the irrelia style as well fall down.
>> There are times when you have combat
tricks in hand when you need counters in
hand and times when you have counters in
hand and you need combat tricks.
Correct. And being able to to not have
both is really punishing in a moment
like this where there's not enough
utility to draw your way out of this.
>> Mhm. And now we're attacking with both
units into the ferris forrunners. We're
losing one in this case.
We're losing. That's interesting choice.
>> Um and still 12 might is being spawned
into the base. That is crazy amount of
pressure that is going to be hitting
the mastery back.
>> Is there any any reason you you'd pick
Aelia there? Is it the deflect? Maybe
you don't want to have to think about
that.
>> I think like
>> cuz you know you'll get over the
Eventually and at least you don't have
to pay for it.
>> And the ganking doesn't really matter in
this particular spot right now.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. What do we have here?
>> A lot of damage spells. It tells us why
it's the Aurelia that's gone and not the
Y.
>> Rocket barrage can be used on
Battlefields, by the way. Just remember
about that. It only works in base and on
equipment. So, we're going to start in
with a stupify to see what we're going
to be drawing. And here's where using
the spells and the damage abilities
before combat means Masi will not yet be
getting the plus two for being in
defense.
>> Um, so you can maybe skirt your way
around that uh with with damage to begin
with
>> and also we by playing stupify first.
Miy doesn't really know what's coming
like should I should I maybe defy the
stupify to deny the draw. Here we go.
That is what it's going to be.
>> So saying, "All right, I need I would
prefer to be at six for now. Plus, I
don't want to give you the draw."
>> Yeah,
>> because I already gave you two with
grave growth of the God Willow.
>> And Kaiser says, "Okay, I've got all the
rest of my uh my runes available." So
one up. So it's like, do you have
another defy?
We know the answer to that question. But
uh
obviously Luis Fishbod doesn't.
>> There's no way you're holding those
battlefields like
>> No, it it's too difficult at this point.
You would imagine.
>> Heaven might on the rune run. So
essentially two mechs and Aporo runs
that over in case of Master Yi. Now
we're going to be able to uh Was that
repeated? I think it was.
So, we've had the three damage and then
this would be enough to to take it out.
Unyielding spirit. Yep.
>> Finally going to forcing it. Forcing
that out of hand, but now it's Masi's
shields down. So,
>> he's still at three damage by the way.
>> Exactly. The first ones will have
applied already.
>> Yeah. So, if it would not be if it if
this unyielding spirit would have been
played for the first hex ray, then there
would be no damage on the unit. But the
problem is there's already enough might
to affect the battlefield in the base.
So just trying to um just trying to bait
Kai into using more energy into playing
more spells and and playing some some of
the runes permanently with the power
cost as well is making a little bit of a
difference. But it does then mean that
your opponent will be getting a point or
even maybe again the hold of the growth
of the god Willow.
>> I'm going to tell you this thing,
>> not holding the growth of the Godwillow
is going to decide this game. It does
certainly feel like that at this point
in time. Now, it's just a case of
deciding which units go in, which it
really is just which do you want to
survive for the next turn, like who do
you want on which, whether it's the
Plundering Power on the Grove or the the
mech or vice versa. We will of course
see the mech go to Zorn Warren's
decision to be made now on what to
discard. Uh what to draw off the conquer
trigger. We'll then get the plundering
parro as well on top of it. Is that only
two cards in hand? So,
>> correct,
>> decisions to make. Those are the two
cards that are being drawn by the growth
to the godwill essentially.
>> Huh. That, you know, when you put it
that way, when you put it that way,
that's a very interesting situation to
be in.
>> Yeah. And also remember that Master Yi
did discard one of his confront already.
I can't remember how many did we see in
the deck list at the beginning of the
match.
>> Same. I I can't.
>> But most likely one or two. So, it's
going to be hard to get into this
battlefield now on this turn unless one
of your units is entering ready by
itself or having a first mate that will
untap a unit and then go in, right? But
your objective now is trying to deny the
growth of the godwill. The problem is if
you do that then you're you're opening
yourself to a potential watcher.
>> Yes. which we're right around that was
what I was going to mention for for
Louis's next turn potentially is is
watcher which you have to be aware of.
We of course can see the two cards that
are being flicked through in hand. Um
>> one of them is being dead right now. The
rocket barriers doesn't have even a
target.
>> So it is uh case in point this might be
a window to play some units. Ston her
comes through. Is that a first?
>> No, it's not a first mate.
>> Okay. just the unit and now two points
for Kaisa. a card plus the card. Grave
of the Grove of the God will
>> goes up to seven. And now we're in now
we're in danger territory for like, you
know, watcher or time war like the big
Kaiser game ending spells. Not right now
in the game. But nevertheless, the more
you give Kaiser the opportunity to draw
into and have the time to play them,
>> the uh trickier it can get to hold on.
>> And what's funny is typically Kai'Sa
would just retreat the units to the base
and that's it. and just develop more
units, pass and just say deal with this,
right? Because you have to set up your
defenses. But in case against a master,
you want to keep your smaller units even
like on the battlefield because that
will deny the plus
>> y into y to get another draw. That was
what came off the first lecturing yortle
draw. And by the way, the tank keyword,
I know it's not going to matter in this
case, but there are so many examples of
when you can just attack with a watcher
and the tank together to like kill a
different watcher and not lose your own
watcher because the tank just soaks up
to damage.
>> Yeah, really important keyword to keep
in mind. And I think a lot of people
forget that it's on lecturing as well
because literally
>> normally you think, okay, now we're into
plundering power. We're just stacking
the one battlefield saying, okay, go.
You've got to deal with this big
battlefield and one mech. Who is going
to win? Um, honestly, I think it's going
to be a tough one. Maybe not impossible.
There are a lot of combat tricks
available for
>> one punch first would push the units to
eight. We have eight might on the growth
of the godwill
>> and only one rune available.
>> Correct.
>> For Luis Fisher.
>> So, this is not unbeatable right now on
the on the board state. But the problem
is now Kai'Sa has three cards in hand in
hand, right? And you're going to have to
now deal with this very uncomfortable
position where your opponent is so close
to winning the game that you're not
going to have room for breathing like at
all. If unless Kai'Sa will just
literally stop drawing any units, right,
you will not have time to develop and
deal with the B state at the same time
because we see Mi is only at three
points. Yeah, that's always the most
suffocating thing about Kaiser is like
>> charm not so fast and ruin
>> if you're playing into a Kaiser. Um you
I have we seen chosen champion Kaiser
this this game game three but I think
it's still in the champions.
>> I actually completely forgot. You're
right. So that's and not a card.
>> Exactly. It's always there to say okay
if the battlefields are clear there's
the charm to the base to remove the
whole time
>> when I was not thinking about it. Come
on.
Teleorn Hood and we'll get the draw. You
were just You're ahead of your time.
You're ahead of your time. Um,
>> now we're going to discard. Oh,
>> not so fast. Comes through. We saw that
one earlier.
>> Okay.
>> So, but there's still that Kaiser in the
champion zone, right? To get the
conquer. You'll draw two off that.
You'll see another two cards when you if
you were to play it on and take out the
Celicorn Herder in a successful conquer.
Now, you have to break this big old
battlefield. So, you got the draw.
>> Now, we're doing the discard from zone
wars, I'm thinking. I think so. I think
you might be right. Yeah. Ruin ready.
Like that's not going to help me this
turn. Get rid of that.
>> Again, we don't see what was being
drawn, but I don't think it's a good
card. There was a hand the head.
>> Uh, it's a discipline.
>> Is it
>> discipline? We get another. Yeah, I
know. I was going to say that's a great
draw. You get to see another card. Like,
>> love that draw. Are you going to chain
draws?
>> Is that a punch first?
>> Oh, no. That that's a headshake. That's
too
>> It's guardian being played. doesn't
>> that six might your opponent still is at
eight.
>> So what was the headshake about counting
it up?
>> FaZe knows
>> that this is essentially to make it to
day two guaranteed from here for either
of them. Taps it
>> plus two. I know
that was
>> so it clears down but Kaiser from the
champion zone
>> is likely to be it cuz now phase is
tapped out
>> because we still have five might on the
Stellorn Herder during defense.
>> True. True. So any of any spell damage
it's going to be the piercing light.
It's going to take out the Stellicorn
Herder. Tap enough runes. Play Kaiser
from the champion zone. conquer both and
Luis Fishbod makes it to day two already
from round six undefeated on Kaiser.
>> Yeah, what a match and it's not an easy
match up for Kaiser as well.
>> No, there was some thinking there
>> and the inclusion of Urelia Fvent
actually makes the matchup way harder
when you think about it. There's also
some builds that are incorporating like
Nav'ori Scout for example, which is a
four drop with built-in deflect too. So,
it's not easy to target a lot of those
units with those spells, but we have
seen um Kaisa here navigate the game two
and three really well, I would say.
>> Yeah, very well.
>> Those are the the small decisions. I
mean, some of them were not decisions
like not drawing a two drop but having
instead like guardian angel on turn one
is not exactly your decision.
>> If I could decide that my opponent
doesn't draw a two drop, I would make
that decision every game.
>> Yeah, exactly. But there were some
decisions like what if we just adjust
the guardian angel towards the Urelia
Fant and then there's no way that
someone is going to clear her because
>> why would you pay deflect cost for
killing a unit and then it's still there
in the base, right?
>> I think that's such a fascinating thing
about the equipment um that came in with
with Spirit Forge is you there's there's
a cost to doing it, right? You're like,
do I want to Damp myself? Do I want to
set up for that? Does it hinder me on my
next turn? Or is the benefit worth it?
is the benefit uh to save my unit
enough? Um really interesting game. Um
down to the wire in in certain
circumstances. I think we we saw a
little bit of the limitation that that
you have in the Master Yi deck where
when your turn is okay, I'm trying to
catch up by playing one big unit and I
don't have anything else.
>> A deck like Kaiser is going to outpace
you and just go quickly over the top.
Yeah, but it was actually a very
interesting game to rewatch, I would
say, because for example, when the porro
was going into the growth of the
Godwillow and it was met with the
hexaguance
position in where our player chose here
to go into the next turn with the uh
with the Stellacon her, right? But there
were other options and you you had to
calculate which one is mathematically
better. I'm not certain which one is
better.
>> No, and you know, you give you that
option on paper. Do you want a parro or
a Stellorn herder?
>> Yeah. And the god Willow, you don't know
how much value you have to put on it.
But is it is it worth like using your
unguard from hand and then not playing a
unit and having only the porro on that
position on the grow of the god Willow
with the not so fast in the hand and the
four might then fight against the two
draw for your opponent. Like there's so
many moving parts there that you have to
calculate. But then if you just allow
that unit to be killed and then you
develop something in base and it just
dies to falling star, you just feel
like, "Oh, now now this game is ruined."
>> And then we consider, you know, that's
us playing with with almost perfect
information on the game of being able to
see both.
>> Correct.
>> You think you're in the seat. You're in
the feature match. You're playing
essentially a win and in uh for for day
two
>> and then you're like, "Okay, I I've got
to decide. Do I want to do I want to
keep this parro alive or do I greed for
the Stellicorn Herder?" Which I don't
even really think it's greed, right?
like Stellorn Herder on that turn is
>> any other deck I would say you probably
do it this way.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> The thing is just just the Kai'Sa will
pay less for power. And when you think
about it, killing a Silicon herd in the
base for for two energy, one power, I'm
paying that blind every time. It's just
like I'm slamming it two times.
>> Break the table. Get it out of here.
That's exactly uh that that situation.
But you know, that's what we talk about
like playing at the highest level of
these players. like these individual
decisions have that ripple effect
through and
>> we don't have the luxury of saying okay
well what would have happened if it had
been backwards so for for Louis fish pod
the turn of events is that they will be
in day two guaranteed regardless of if
they win or lose or draw the next two
rounds of course player uh phase will be
continuing to play their their
tournament is not over five and one is
still a very respectable score at the
end of round six
>> when you think about it it's like just
the day one and it's not even finished
and we're going to still have Swiss
rounds. How many Swiss rounds tomorrow?
>> Five tomorrow. Five tomorrow morning. 13
total.
>> 13 rounds. That means that this round
six was not even halfway through the
entire event. So yeah, there's a lot of
rift bound to be played out
>> and then we've got top eight after that.
So it's not just 13 rounds of Swiss
either. We've got so much Riftbound. Uh
for those of you at home, thank you very
much for joining us uh on your weekend.
Um let us know on social media what what
you're doing, how you're watching. Use
the # RQ Leal as well. If you're in
chat, we see you, too. Hope you're
saying nice things.
>> Yeah, I hope so.
>> Please say nice things. Let's hear some
nice things, I hope, in an interview.
I'm going to pass it over to Amy to hear
from our winner.
>> Thanks so much, James. I'm here with the
winner of our feature Max, Louie, who
has come with this wonderful Kaiser
list. I'm obsessed. Where did you start?
Uh I technically started with just
normal Kaiser after all the Bunnings
because I wanted to play something else
but I figured Kaiser lost nothing when
we I started with what is but what is
Kaiser bet against all the green decks
Ireelia Ye which I somehow managed to
win because I figured out the only way
you actually lose against them if you
try to fight by counter spells.
>> Yeah, that totally makes a lot of sense.
So I saw all the online list where I
played like get excited even more spells
everything for the sideboard all only
spells spells spells was like but the
best part is just more might
>> more might
>> and then we went through a lot of things
figured out for the best unit in wet and
then we joked about playing more for
cost cards like more Kaisers or anything
but when we tested with a lot of friends
who also have a problem in wet with
Annie or else they don't can play more
than three Kaiser. Yeah,
>> we need a fifth of fourth for and we
figured out rumble is the best one.
>> Yeah. And then you're giving your mechs
more advantage.
>> Yeah. And when I figured out, okay, for
good, it beats everything in the mirror
because everything every other foreigner
is six might. I have six seven on
attack. I get my forunners back. And
when I just looked at all the two drops
and was like, we can also play the
vision mech.
>> Yeah.
>> And so I had seven mess. needed a
seventh two drop and was like but we
have to have gem jammer because if you
only stack one battlefield with lot of
might sometimes you need ganking
>> exactly and then you can just make that
happen
>> and then just have you stack all the
four runners in one
>> be like okay I go to the other one my
opponent says it's like no just gank
over
>> it's genius honestly
>> that's how it went and that's how all of
my matches went today it's like oh all
of my opponents expect a lot of spells
>> and just go away might might don't play
a spell until turn five or so when it
matters
and then I just blow them out.
>> I love it. I love it. I think it's
absolutely genius and you've shown
through your straight in the tournament
so far that that tactic is working. Are
you ready to go all the way?
>> I hope so. I also managed shout outs to
a lot of friends of mine who test with
me because
>> the make idea was mine.
>> Oh, okay.
>> But in the end, I was the one just
saying, "Okay, let's do it.
>> I'm going to do it. I'm going to do it."
>> Just you say that's good. I trust you
up. Let's do it.
>> Are any of your friends here playing it
too?
>> H my girlfriend is here.
>> Oh, amazing.
>> She's right now. I hope she's for two
tuna with us trying
>> and one a lot of friends from Poland.
Like 20 people from our town.
>> That's absolutely incredible. The Rift
Found love is definitely with you guys
in Poland. Thank you so much for giving
us a really brief catch up on the
inspiration behind your deck and how it
works, how it fixes those awkward
matchups. We're going to throw it back
to the casters for some more action. All
right.
Thank you, Amy. Did I hear Luis Fish say
Berlin is uh is their base? If so, hello
Berlin, my old hometown. Uh I should
have played more card games when I was
there, but I did not. Uh I know you
spent a lot of time in
>> I spent a lot of time as well.
>> Honestly, my German not good enough to
uh to translate cards and my card game
play not good enough to know every card
just from from the pictures at all
times. We're going into another round.
We don't need to talk about my history.
uh we can go into another interesting
round in round six. We're still in round
six just as we finish things up. We want
to drop into the last game of our second
feature match and we picked another
interesting matchup here as we've got
Ahri Inquisitive and Draven Showboat. So
Ahri was undefeated coming into this
round. Draven does lead 1 and zero in
this series. And we have now the game is
most likely being starting started by
the Ahri because of the loss, right? So
we're going to have turn one. Yeah,
growth of God willow. Of course, it
makes sense. Uh again, a game with
growth of God willow. Look at that. Two
games in a row. So we're going to be
having um three and wait score.
>> Yeah, I I think we may have a slight
issue with the scoreboard right now. I I
believe coming into this that the AR
player that we were we're looking at
following was undefeated. So,
nevertheless, we'll we'll follow this
game and we'll we'll get an update on
scores as we go through. Um,
>> because we definitely heard that there's
an undefeated
>> I I saw with my my own two eyes on the
on the standings that there was an AR
undefeated and as as somebody who has a
an an off deck of Ari, I was quite
intrigued as to to see how it would play
in the meta with players of the RQ
caliber. Meanwhile, over the other side,
Draven Showboat. That is a scary set of
cards in hand. Draven plus uh sorry,
Darius plus some spinning axes there.
>> That is 10 might.
>> Yeah, that is really strong.
>> Yeah, we have the Titan. Um it looks
like it's a shock down between him and
the two sand soldiers, but it's not.
It's just the battlefield is just a
little bit pushed to the side. Uh so one
first point for Thomas over here on
Draven mid-range. And I'll be honest
with you, this this particular matchup
is not looking that great for Draven
over uh sorry for Ari because you just
giving you want your you want your
character to do something which is
holding and going into battle against
opponents. But unfortunately Draven
wants you to do that. So he wants to get
into the fights. He wants to utilize his
tools to essentially turn them into card
draw. And in this case, the spinning
axes, the Dariuses, the cleaves, blood
rushes, whatever you play in the D in
the Draven deck is going to convert now
in the card draw because you most likely
will push over the amount of defense
that the AR will put out unless the area
has some really nasty setups being done.
But without a sona, that's probably very
hard to do,
>> which is fair. It is hard to do without
a a sona. Um, I know that this deck does
in the main board play Yeah, they're in
hand. Blitzcrank is one way of
disrupting your opponent's uh
battlefield. And that's what's going to
happen here. Don't see a whole lot of
Blitzcrank in general, but what it'll do
is when you play it to a battlefield,
when you play it to a battlefield only,
it will pull an enemy unit and begin a
showdown where the Blitzcrank is played.
And then when Blitzcrank holds, he'll
actually return back to the hand as
well.
>> What is very important to understand
about playing Blitzcrank is that it is a
net negative tempo. Yeah. to some degree
because depending on what what is
happening in the game in in this case
we're exchanging a five drop for a two
drop because then this blitzcr goes back
into the hand and we're not getting uh
you know we're not getting this energy
back right so the uh the defy def tries
to stop the right the wind that was
trying to get another point during the
opponent's t it's a very important defy
like it's very very important to play
this right now because otherwise Draven
would have not only get the point, but
then it would also trade with the
potentially with potentially the uh sand
soldier because otherwise you would just
be giving a card draw from the grove of
the godwillow. That cannot happen as we
can you know see in the previous match
we have seen the go actually help the
opponent so much.
>> Yeah, not allowed to let that happen. Uh
so falling star in hand if you care
about dealing with the blitzk or do you
just care about dealing with some sand
soldiers and say okay we'll take both of
those man. No wait no we dramped. Yeah,
dramping is going to make that tricky.
So, uh,
>> yeah, damping. We don't have any more
access to Darus into the spinning axe.
And that was potentially something that
would break any of the holds because I
would attack into for nine.
>> So, if you star the sand soldiers,
>> is essentially empty. Oh, we're killing
the Blitzcrank.
>> Going to be double blitz crank. I was
going to say Blitzcrank does return to
hand and then you don't really get the
effect again. It is like going to get
delayed, but nevertheless, we'll take
the Blitzcrank out from the top.
Blitzcrank also another thing about it
is it does have the tank keyword. So, it
does have to be assigned damage first.
That's another good reason when when you
pull small units, they just kind of
bounce off and you just say, "Yep, go to
the trash. I'll win that showdown."
>> The thing is, if you would just play the
Darus and that was one of the options,
then the problem is that the Blitzkr
just pulls you in and the Darus is a
four and it doesn't kill the Blitzkr. So
you can't really just set up um the
direct the second blitz crank. Uh if at
first you don't succeed uh pull and pull
again at this point.
>> Yeah, for a second I thought I'm seeing
double. It's like wait, he just got
destroyed.
>> These are the two main board blitz
cranks. So uh this golem is rolling and
it's gathering no rust as six runes
tapped.
>> Never seen that coming.
>> Nope. Didn't see that. Six runes and one
red. I wonder what that's going to be.
>> Well, and this hold becomes way less
efficient now because now trying to pull
this with a Blitzcrank, it will trade
one for one. We would need more support.
And we are building up runes here on
side of Ahri. Um because the Blitzcrank
is hold is costing us one green. So we
have 367 if I'm not mistaken over here.
Right.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it's it's seven. Um, I'm
just double checking if there are any
combat tricks in hand. Like even an on
guard would would kind of help here cuz
you can pull the forerunner in with a
tank keyword.
>> Correct.
>> You'd be able to to withstand the
4Runner.
>> But the problem is like if
>> throwing again
>> if you do this your opponent again has
two more units, right?
>> Yeah, you you're very right.
>> Unfortunately, in case of Ahri, those
three drops are essentially two drops.
>> Two drops. Yeah, exactly. That's the
other thing that's happening at all
times. It's a discipline that's going to
come through. So again will allow
Blitzcrank to stay alive. Trades against
the Ferris 4Runner
>> and yeah now it's two three drops come
through.
>> But the problem is now you are now
you're completely tapped and the Draven
can do whatever he wants.
>> Yeah that is scary. Although you know is
up at six. That's what I was going to
say. These holds this one sand soldier
>> on the other battlefield over on the has
just been getting cards. He's like cool.
I'll I'll guard this battlefield and
just draw you a card every turn. That's
all I need. And you know, we said that a
a Darius plus the spinning axes is is
scary situation to be in, but uh if you
can't play them both.
>> Well, now he has access to it.
>> Yeah. And that's basically going to be
an all-in here in order to uh
>> I don't think it's even scary. It's
like, okay, I'll clean both
battlefields. I'll draw two cards and
just setting up the field as well.
potentially. Now Arya has a problem if
she doesn't have a watcher.
>> Yeah. Which
>> and even if even if there's a watcher,
you're only going to be able to clear
one of the battlefields and the other
one is going to either draw your card or
have a bigger unit.
>> And Ari has been dramping throughout
some of these turns with the crank
consistently. So it is difficult to to
deal with. So that will be that
battlefield getting cleared out. Then of
course we know the other one will uh get
cleared out by the mech as well.
So, this is a bit of a problem over
here.
>> Ari does not stabilize particularly well
from this spot. It is hard, as you said,
without the um uh without the watcher in
order to do the singularity won't get
the job done here because the Darius is
too strong at this point.
>> Also, good sequencing. Wanted to just
call it out. Thomas over here could have
attacked one by one because in theory in
every other deck that would have made no
difference, right? he would still attack
with a two might into a two might trade
and then conquer with the second me. But
in case of Draven, you want to attack
together because then you are actually
winning combat.
>> Yeah, that's a very good point. Um that
is a very very good point. So I think
that uh Hagashi's
main goal now is restock a a base with
as many units as you can and try on the
next turn to double conquer. It's only
the one pass.
>> Student pass didn't doesn't even play
the Ahri from the chosen champion zone.
I wonder whether that is going to end up
being too slow now not playing it this
previous.
>> Why Why do we save so much energy?
>> What is the play?
>> Yeah, I'm curious now.
>> Oh, you're actually asking. I thought
you knew what the play was. I'm trying
to think of what is that much energy
worth on my opponent's turn. Right.
That's that was exactly my question is
like you're saving this energy for
something. Yeah, but I'm not certain
what four is like. What is the point
exactly right now?
>> I guess is the point. Do you not want to
DM? Is it 2, four, six? You've got
eight. You're going up to 10,
>> but your opponent is going to just No,
you cannot leave the battlefields
because your opponent can have a watcher
into double conquer, right? So now the
fan is set up to essentially play around
at least the watcher to some degree.
Yeah,
>> we have another set of spinning axe and
a right the wind which can hold points
essentially in in case of you use the
right the wind during your opponent's
turn. So, rocket barish to
>> deal with the spinning axe
>> to deal with the spinning ax
>> because then you're going to singularity
on the back end is my assumption.
>> The student goes up to three.
>> Yeah, student goes up to three. So, you
you I guess looking to singularity
Darius and the mech. The problem is
there's another spinning egg.
>> Yeah, I know. That's what I was going to
say. The problem here is spinning ax and
you have just tapped out everything. You
kind of have to at this point
>> in order to make it work. So Darius is
not going to fall here.
>> That is a crazy position right now
because not only you have a live Darius,
but also now you can try defeating the
opponent here with the Darius if you
just do the right the wind. Yeah,
exactly. Although uh Yeah,
>> although that would not get him a point
because he's going to just join. Yeah,
exactly. He'd be
>> as a surprise defender to some degree.
So maybe it's not worth it.
>> And now the Daryus can go back to base.
We play any two cards readies goes into
the Grow of the God Will
>> and then on your opponent's turn.
>> Yeah,
>> you can ensure you're going to hold like
if you have to ride the wind to a
different battlefield to just
>> you will draw a card for having
>> set up to hold safely on the other turn
as h it's going to be
>> it's not Darius and Draven that are
showing up as a duo in this. It is just
two Darius.
No one needs the brothers at this point.
It is going to be two Darius, one
conquering each battlefield. Uh that is
going to put Thomas at seven
>> basically the point uh the winning point
for the next turn. And I don't really
know if there's anything
that Ahri player can can pull here in
order to do it. Double watch.
>> You're convinced it's the best play.
It's the best play in the game.
>> It's horrible, man. Nothing does
anything.
>> I think is there a singularity in hand?
Without that spinning axe, you'd be
feeling great. I mean, singularity plus
like a smoke screen or something.
Anything.
Singularity and just something.
>> Is that even Wait, what?
>> Is that against the odds? It is against
the odds to pull the other one. Read the
card. It's going to say give extra
might. And it's going to go to the other
Darius. So, both Darius will
>> No, no, no. Oh, wait. Hang on. What did
I miss?
>> No, no, you didn't miss anything. The
against the odds works when there's
opponent at the battlefield per
opponent, right?
>> Yeah. Per opponent, of course.
>> Exactly. The charm back to the base.
>> Come on.
>> That's so funny. Uh, okay.
>> Those of you that missed it, we're
laughing because Lothar earlier in the
day was went down a rabbit hole on it
and then it happened.
>> It was not the best play. Definitely.
>> Sometimes, sometimes there's something
>> it has to happen, you know. It actually
happened twice now during the day, you
know.
>> I think it validates you actually. I
think it did. Yeah.
>> Although that that one with the the
first attempt of charm to base was
>> that was anyway. Yeah. Okay. So, do we
have a follow-up? Yes, we do. And that's
double conquer and
>> the fist bump. That is Thomas advancing
in round six. Looks like he will pick up
uh the fourth win of the day as uh
against the odds.
>> Just wanted to flex against the odds
stays in the tournament as well as that
is the end of round six for us. It's um
>> been an interesting day.
>> I wanted to just quickly summarize this
game. So what I feel like
>> that actually it kind of went exactly
how I explained it before. Blitzcrank
was effective. Yeah,
>> it was getting you card value, but the
problem is it was not getting you tempo
value. And you actually, when you think
about it, we had two two times
Blitzcrank getting a tide runner, which
is 10 energy and two power being spent
to kill two units,
>> right? Then it sets up defenses, but
because we are tapping out and we're
still potentially getting the Blitzcr
back into the uh into the hand, a Darius
with a spinning axe or a cleave just is
a complete blowout and we are not able
to come back into those games typically.
Yeah, that's that's a massive difference
and that's a very fair point about the
way that the tempo played out. Uh, and
we'll keep up our tempo by going over to
an interview with Barcode
and we are back on the floor right now
with one of the key players of the room.
It is Antony Lopez. I mean, yeah, don't
be shy. We all know that you're a very
good TCG player, but on reefbound, how
is it translating?
>> Uh, it's translating pretty well. I've
come from other TCGs where it's a bit
faster. So, there is more management to
learn, more stuff to learn, but the
tempo is still the same. The way you get
card advantage, it all translates
between each other.
>> I mean, yeah, this is some definitions
that we all know and they are all the
same in every single TCG. Right now you
are playing in the main event, right?
How are you doing in this event?
>> At the moment I'm still 5-1. So I'm
still in the race. So that is pretty
nice. I'm pretty happy about it.
>> How long have you been playing Reebound?
>> I've started since set one. I did the
very first regional qualifier at Houston
and I haven't stopped playing since
then.
>> Okay. So I mean you've been playing for
a pretty long time now. Oh, so you know
the game pretty well. Which deck did you
choose to play for this event
specifically?
>> I pretty much chose a comfort pick
because of the ban list. So I went with
Kaisa because it's the deck I played the
most, prepared the most for Houston
through the set one. In set two, it was
still okay. And after the ban list, I
think it's one of the top three decks.
And by going through the representation
in the room,
most people think it the same. So
>> yeah, it's a pretty solid choice to be
honest. I mean there are four decks at
the top of the metag game. I mean most
of players think so and I think that
Kaisa is a pretty solid one. Speaking
about the preparation specifically
remove that smile.
Speaking about the preparation, how did
you prepare for this event specifically
and what do you do as a almost
professional player?
It's mostly testing sessions with uh my
good friend Inas and also partner in
every TCG. I always test with him.
Usually we play we play by remote
dueling a lot of times. And sometimes I
also play remote duel on barcodes
discord. You should join up guys. It's
very fun in there.
But most most I would say most of the
preparation of course is with Enas my
buddy from think twice. So yeah.
>> So that's pretty cool. So you have an
overall very good preparation and do you
think right now that it translates very
well into this event? Do you feel
confident when you are playing?
>> Yes, it's but I think it comes from the
experience from playing under high
pressure in other parts of uh games. You
just learn a lot and you just understand
the the game dynamics a little bit more.
So you're not as lost even though it's
kind of new because it's impossible to
have
he's seen everything in such a wast game
because the the game three has so many
branches in rift pound it's impossible
to just know directly what is coming. So
yeah
>> makes sense. Coming to the tournament
what were your expectations? Did you
expect to go top eight to win it all or
did you did you just want to make day
two for example? Well, I'm just saying
I'm here for the best of Kaisa and we
know Kai'Sa is the third most
represented exo. I'll do my best.
>> You're going to do your best and I know
that you're going to do very well
because of your experience and your
preparation which is of course very
good. Speaking about preparation, there
is going to be the set three unleashed
very soon. Is there any legend that you
particularly like in this set?
>> Oh, I really like Leblon. I I think it's
going to be very very fun. The signature
spell. I love it. I I just love them.
The way you can just create game states
out of Norway with this card is amazing.
Very good card design.
>> The mechanics are indeed awesome. I am
myself a Leeblank enjoyer and I'm
waiting it so hard. But for now, what
you are going to wait is the next round.
So guys, take it away.
>> Oh, hi everyone. We're back here. RQ Al,
I'm Blevens. That is Amy. We are here in
the pre on the precipice of round number
seven, which is crazy to say. We were
talking backstage about how it's got to
be what, like noon now. Maybe it's what,
round three or four? It's round seven.
It the day has absolutely flown.
>> I feel like I've just kind of lost it.
I'm I don't know where the day has gone.
I I need to find it because we've been
having so much fun that it's flown by.
And I'm at home.
>> Yeah, we've seen a ton of different
types of decks. Even we saw a Kaisa
match when we cast last round. There was
a Kai'Sa that was mech Kai'Sa. Like I
haven't seen that since before Spirit
Forge was released. Like people were
brewing that deck. Really awesome to see
all these different types of decks do
well. We're seeing a lot of players rise
to the top and a lot of these other
decks. I did a a little walk of the top
tables in between or while the last
round was going on and I saw a lot of
different decks.
>> What did you see?
>> I saw
Draven. I saw Aurelia. No, I I mean we
saw we saw the things that you would
expect, but I also saw uh we saw Victor.
I saw a lot of Rexi. Actually, a lot
more Rexa than I was expecting. Decent
number of Fioras. There was a Darius up
at the top. And I'm when I'm talking top
tables, I'm I'm imagining all that whole
row is EXO and probably the first few
rows are EXO. I did of course see Allan
playing Ezreal with the full headcam on
and I'm like I wanted to like get down
and and ruin his shot but I'm like oh
he's playing a very important match
right now. I should probably not tamper
with this even though I wanted to. Um
but yeah, just really diverse up at the
top tables and of course once you start
going back you can see literally
anything.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And that's exactly
what it's all about. And you can see
that people really have brought their
best. They've gone, "This is my favorite
legend.
>> Here I am to show that I am the best."
And that's why we've got these even what
some might call unusual decks up on
those top tables because they're proving
it.
>> Yeah. Well, I I've talked about it
publicly a lot that my absolute favorite
thing and the thing that has gotten me
way more interested in competitive
Riftbound from a player perspective is
the best of Rising. It's such a cool
thing to have that amazing commemorative
>> trophy for lack of a better word, but
also I can play the trophy as my legend,
which is amazing. And you know, players
are coming out in droves trying to get,
you know, maybe they really love that
legend. They, you know, we we talked to
the Lucian player from round one. like I
finally get to play my main in League
which is awesome. So going for a best of
having that awesome piece of uh
riftbound history is amazing and we're
seeing players have that own their own
little sub tournament in you know if
you're playing for a best of if you're
Lucian you're not playing necessarily in
the field of almost 2,000 players that
everyone else is. You're trying to win
this little tournament of about 50
people and that's way more palatable for
a player like me.
>> Yeah. No, I definitely agree. And even
though that's still a huge feat and it's
going to take a lot of doing, there's a
lot of players that are looking
>> right at their way into day two of this
event
>> with those legend with those legends
with those champions that are less
conventional with the ones that have
more to prove because people go, "You're
playing what?"
>> Yeah. No, literally, I need to read the
card. I guess
>> uh
>> we saw a lot of that and it really just
makes again for me I'm old school player
been playing card games for 20 years
been playing competitively for almost
that long and there's a lot of
tournaments that really if you don't win
>> it's kind of like what what did I what
was I doing here there's so much to play
for there's so much in the main event of
course there's a ton at the event itself
you don't even need to necessarily play
in the main if you don't want to there's
a lot to to that is going on in these
regional qualifiers including some
really awesome stuff with cosplayers and
we're going to actually throw it to
Barcode who's going to talk to one right
now.
Okay, I'm right now with Eloine who is
cosplaying this very beautiful
Misfortune and I can tell you this
cosplay looks absolutely incredible.
First of all, how are you doing today?
Uh it
>> I'm actually doing absolutely
incredible. First question that comes
into my mind, how did you do this
cosplay? Especially the guns which look
absolutely amazing.
And that looks absolutely awesome. I've
got a question for you. Is Misfortune
your favorite character?
It's a bit hard. Yeah,
>> it actually makes sense. It makes a lot
of sense. So maybe one day you will be
able to do a Velcros cosplay. I'll be
waiting to see if you can do it. But
another question that comes into my
mind, have you ever done another cosplay
than this one?
>> The League of Legends.
>> Wow.
Okay. What are some other characters
that you've actually done as cosplay?
A lot of misfortune.
>> One of my favorite characters to be
honest. Okay.
>> It's been 10 years already. Yes,
>> that's absolutely incredible. And
finally, I mean, this is an event in
France. How does it relate to you? And
how do you feel here in this event with
the French audience and the French
crowd?
That's actually very nice. Thanks a lot
for your time. That was absolutely
wonderful having you here. And for you
at home, don't go anywhere because we've
got some more content coming your way.
Welcome back. Regional qualifier alil.
I'm still Blevens. That is still Amy.
And I've got to say, uh, it was almost
super super awkward because I was
actually going to cosplay as Misfortune
for this right here. So, it would have
been a really awkward like, who wore it
better? And I So, luckily, I just went
with some regular clothes instead, but
we avoided that. Uh, that snafu was
avoided. Uh, but here we are in again on
the precipice of round number seven.
We've been talking about metadiversity
at the top tables. We've been talking
about what is going on in this
tournament. We actually have a little
bit of a look into the standings here.
Who at the top is doing well and what
are they playing? Let's take a look
here. We've got some featured players of
course. We've got Marshall from
Riftbound Report at 4 and two with the
Rexai. Still alive. Still alive. Anyone
else jump out to you, Amy?
>> Well, here we go again. This feels very
familiar territory. Alan ZQ 6 with
Ezreal.
>> Obviously, we have to have a little bit
of a different build, but we're there.
uh rap solo 42 with Draven Vins of
course we've just seen 6o Draven and
then we've got a few on the right hand
side there of course and we've got a
second page for you we've got some
alternative legends here as well my boy
set sadly going two three at this point
33 with that Teemo Lucian doing good
Kasanova bringing that home
>> yeah we've got uh my buddy T who as one
multiple best of Garens there. Not doing
so great right now. But here we go at
the top tables. We've got Kai'Sa in here
as who we just saw. That's the Mech
Kaisa that we just saw. We've got Excio
who is actually a Legends of Rune Terra
player from back in the day. Of course,
we see Allen as well. But we got a lot
of different players on there and even
more interestingly to me, a lot of
different legends, Amy. And I think
that's the beauty of it right now is
that we do have a plethora of legends.
And even within that, we've seen so many
different builds today like that
highlight of the mech Kaiser that we've
just seen. So even within this, you see
repeats, you see Draven, you see
Aurelia, you see Kaiser, but actually
when you get down to the nitty-gritty of
it, these could be entirely different
from one another.
>> Mhm. Oh yeah. You it we saw two Kaisers
on stream and those two Kais were
absolutely not closed at all. If you
were playing against, you know, if
you're playing around one thing and then
they play a bunch of mechs on turn two
and three going, "Oh, I have prepared
very poorly for what is about to happen.
>> This is not it."
>> Uh, but we are here into our match.
Round number seven. We've got a Fiora
finally and Urelia on the right side
here.
>> Yippee. I love Fiora. Set was my
favorite deck from set one. And then
Fiora felt like a natural transition. Of
course, we've got body and order
domains, lots of removal spells, but
then we also have some big units. It's
all about being mighty.
>> Yes, absolutely. We can see here three
set brawler on the side of the Fiora.
And this is a relatively standard
looking version of the hook Fiora. A
couple extra cards here. We've got the
Buru, Captain, and Sea Monkey, who you
don't always see in those versions, but
nice to hit off of the hook. And then
Urelia there with the main deck Draven
and the main deck Vex. You love to see
it.
>> Aelia can be a little bit troublesome,
forcing you to pay extra for some of
those spells. Is not that fun.
>> Yeah. No, not not fun at all if you have
to pay extra for those there. But
really, really interesting matchup
coming here. Fiora. Hook. Fiora is one
that I was actually looking a lot into
when Spirit Forge first came out. At
first, I thought it was a meme, which is
of course why I I gravitated towards it.
I thought, "Oh, no one's going to want
to look at this." And then it did well
in some Chinese events. And from there,
it was uh actually played quite a bit
and and became a relatively sort of tier
2 metad. Now, I think with the the
bands, it's actually a decent pick here
as we see uh animation module actually
still here in the event as we jump on in
to round number seven.
>> Round seven, a colossal matchup between
might and calm. We've got two very
different play styles going into the
frey against one another, but which will
prevail? both starting off strong with
those lowcost cheap units to get into
the board to start making a board state.
It would be typical of Fiora at this
point just to push forward and start
taking some points on those
battlefields.
>> Yeah, and speaking of those
battlefields, we've got Trafarian War
Camp, which we saw really do well in the
Draven last round. We've of course got
the Zon Warren on the side of Aurelia.
Trafarian war camp. Really interesting
one for Fiora because if you have a four
might unit and you move into Trafarian
War camp, that counts as becoming
mighty. And we see that right here.
There's Fiora
>> going to be mighty there.
>> And that's what we love.
>> It's such a beautiful combo being able
to immediately make yourself mighty by
using the battlefield itself. You didn't
need a buff. You didn't need a spell.
You didn't need anything special. You
just moved on in and became mightier.
And when Fiora is mighty, she gets
deflect ganking and shield.
>> Yeah. So good. And that shield is one
that I have seen forgotten many times.
And yes, many of those times have been
for me. Uh I am like counting. I'm like,
"Okay, she's five. I got that. Yep.
Deflect. Okay, I don't want to target
her. Ganky, she can move over. Okay,
I'll attack it." And they go, "Yep,
she's a six." I go, "Wait, what?
>> Wait, wait a minute.
>> I did not want that to happen, but it
did happen." And uh we moved on with our
lives there. But see a very strong
battlefield. Eight might on the side of
the trifarian war camp. Not you don't
normally see eight might on a
battlefield this early in the game.
>> N but that's exactly what these mighty
style decks excel in. putting big
tremendous board states, putting a wall
in front of your opponent and saying,
"Can you deal with this?" Because my
guys are pretty big and you want to get
them out early and flourish. You want to
be able to overwhelm your opponent with
might alone.
>> Yep. And here is a card that I think
started off in a lot of decks decks when
Spirit Forge came out. last uh the the
previous pre-ban meta did not really
have them uh as much, but Heart of Dark
Ice is a very strong card, giving you
three might. You're able to activate it
to give three might to any unit that you
would like, and that of course can
trigger the blade dancer of Aurelia. It
effectively can give any one of your
units accelerate
every single turn if you need it. And of
course, adding that three might as well
is very, very strong. We're seeing this
porro go in and tussle. That is the
biggest porro I think I've ever seen. A
defiant dance plus this dark ice is
absolutely phenomenal. An eight power
porro might porro going into now just
six on animation side taking out that
really early lead. The the answer was
clear. Yes, I can deal with your mighty
guys. Yeah, I was talking about how you
don't usually see eight might on the
side of uh of a battlefield. Well, uh
how about on the other side and it's one
singular porro. Uh
>> though he be small, he be mighty.
>> He be very mighty indeed. But one thing
to note though, we look at the rune
count on the side of Aurelia. It is two
runes. So, uh, you know, you ask what it
cost and, uh, the answer may just be
everything. But
>> it was a board clear indeed. And now the
question is, what is Fiora going to do
here to rebuild that board and keep the
pressure on?
>> So, it looks like we've got a lot of
choices here. There are a lot of units
in hand. They have a lot of good
effects, but I think ultimately we need
to start with a big boy. So, I think
this is likely set. It is indeed. And
when they are played, they get a buff,
and you can spend that buff to get plus
one might on a turn. So it can give
itself an effective eight.
>> Yeah. And it's a really cool unit with
Fior because when you play it, it comes
in as the four. The trig it's ability is
a triggered ability that gives it a
buff. That going from four to five with
the buff that is becoming mighty. It
procs the Fiora. The second time you can
do this is you can remove that buff to
give him plus4. Well, you remove the
buff that brings him down to four. That
puts an ability that when it resolves
will give him plus4. When that happens,
he becomes mighty again. So, you get to
you get to double dip the chip. That is
that.
>> Oh, it's the best when you get to
reactivate abilities like that and just
keep going.
>> And Odyssey is one of the reasons I
really enjoy playing this deck is
because of that synergy between Fiora
and Set,
>> right? It's it's really good. I mean,
ironically, Fiora is the best user of
Set Brawler, including even of Set
himself. So, it's a really really strong
card in this deck. Once you start using
Fiora worthy, you can start accelerating
him or rather you can start readying him
and it gets really really strong and
he's just able to control the board and
he's really hard to deal with cuz he's
massive.
>> Yeah, and that's the thing. And you can
then just kind of keep piling that
pressure on cuz even if you spend that
buff, okay, well, I'll put a pit rookie
into play and then I'm going to just
keep going with all of this nonsense.
So, I'm going to make sure that set is
giant. He's ready to go straight away
thanks to Fiora. And then we can just
move him straight into a battlefield.
And we are scoring a point.
>> Yeah, we're scoring a point. Not going
to contest that. That eight might set
who's now going to be a nine might with
the buff. We did of course see that
Fiora
uh legend proc there to get that chneled
rune exhausted.
>> And we drew some cards. Thanks, Zorn
Warren.
>> Thank you, Zarren indeed. And now this
is really I mean we can see the rune
disparity. It is massive. Four runes on
the side of Aurelia and a lot on the
side of Fior. And we're seeing our good
old friend first mate to just bring Set
back into safety.
>> Yeah, honestly not a bad thing at all.
That's exactly what we want to do is be
holding on to Set and be able to make
him kind of Oh my goodness. Oh.
>> Oh, that board state became huge very
quickly.
>> A lot of units and our good friend
Baited Hook. An absolutely fantastic
card reminiscent of cards from other
games as well. You're able to turn your
units into bigger units is the long and
short of it,
>> which I mean, who doesn't want to do
that? Especially when you're playing a
deck that revolves around being mighty.
Whenever a unit is above five might, it
is considered mighty.
>> Mhm. Absolutely. So, you're able to
you're able to turn your units into
better units. But the the thing that I
found was actually very very strong
about the hook specifically is you're
able to go in and conquer a battlefield.
Then you can hook that unit at the
battlefield away, get a better unit, and
put that unit in base. It's build your
own Lucian. You can get in, get your
point, and then get out.
>> And you're like, "Yeah, actually, I
don't need to be here anymore. I'm going
to jump back out of here." And it works
ever, ever so well. It's been used in a
plethora of decks and I'm not surprised
to see it in this one now. Yeah, it's uh
it's been a really really strong
addition to the deck and really Fiora
has has weirdly enough become the de
facto baited hook deck a lot of the time
I think you know outside of maybe Ranata
hook which I think there's some
believers out there in uh has not seen a
lot of success at the top tables but the
Fiora hook deck certainly has at least
in early Spirit forge and we may be
seeing it here at 6 and0
you really can't say much against You
really can't. And we're in round seven
right now. We could see a progression of
that. Um, Aligai has been just slowly
getting Aurelia ready, putting on our uh
our equipment, keeping it safe, giving
ourselves that little bit of protection,
but staying in base because it's not
safe out on those battlefields yet.
>> Yep. Speaking of equipment, there it is.
Our BF sword there going on the unsung
hero. That is the wombo combo of FR.
We're making her mighty. That's going to
proc the legend. And also, if this
unsung hero dies while mighty, you're
going to draw not one but two fresh
cards.
>> What?
>> Really good
>> lunacy.
Especially in a deck that tends to be
card hungry,
>> then a really great thing to do is get
that BF sword on the unsung hero. And
what's even better than that is uh
sometimes you just get to hook it away
>> sometimes. And that's that's the nice
thing about this is actually this is I
think one of the things that Fiora decks
have struggled in the most is card draw.
Like statistically that is what they
have faltered to. That has been the most
difficult thing to overcome is actually
just being able to get into the cards
you need. And this is one of those
combos that just helps push you ahead.
And obviously we get the trigger of Zorn
Warren there as well. And that continues
to help our card draw. So this is going
very well for Animation right now.
Plenty of power and we've got the card
draw that we normally can suffer from.
>> Yeah. And we're going to be able to uh
potentially score this fourth point
here. Keep up that point tempo. Get to
those even point thresholds. But first,
let's take a look in the hook here.
We're going to hook away the unsung
hero. see what we can get off of the
baited hook and go from there.
>> Let's see what we're going to reveal.
What's going to replace that down? The
BF sword is still lingering, waiting for
a new friend.
>> Yeah. And and the beauty of it is the
baited hook checks the might of the unit
when it is destroyed with the baited
hook. So, the unsung hero was at five.
Yeah. Uh so it's going to look for five
or uh up to six rather in terms of might
and that is basically every unit in the
deck.
>> Who we got?
>> Maybe have made a decision here.
>> Who's here? Who's here to play?
>> Have to imagine it's not a harness
dragon cuz that would almost certainly
be a windmill slam. It's actually just a
another unsung hero.
>> And honestly that's kind of fine. Like
it's not the best. But again, we're
cycling through the deck, and that's one
of the many things that this deck has
had trouble with in the past. And by
removing another unsung hero from the
deck, you're lowering the chances of
that being your top deck when you go to
draw cards. Thinning the deck is helping
us to get to winning.
>> Yeah. And even just moving it off of the
battlefield is good in this case. It
also frees up the equipment if you uh so
needed it. uh not really needing it
right now, but you can re-equip that
unsung hero with a BF sword and uh yeah,
get the card draw engine going again,
which is really how this deck gets
humming and really uh can take over a
game.
>> Yeah, that's how it kind of digs its
teeth in a little bit. And Aligu is
going to be looking to try and jump back
in there somehow. But it's going to be a
little bit tricky because you're playing
this kind of protect the princess
Aurelia
and at the moment at very least we don't
really have the power to move Aurelia
itself around without being in a little
bit of danger. We do have the equipment
that will save us once, but going
forward it could get a little bit
sketchy. really don't want to be putting
her in danger when the coast isn't
clear.
>> Yep. And we're equipping the set with BF
sword, making him even larger. And this
uh well, this smells like a challenge if
I've ever seen one.
>> Mhm. And that's going to circumvent the
fact that it's just sat there in the
base. Here we go.
>> Yeah, challenge cares not.
>> Scary.
>> Challenge cares not whether you are in
base. And there it is, the challenge.
Going to try to kill that Urelia
>> targeting between the two. We kind of
compare the might. And of course,
luckily, Guardian Angel's here to save
the day. Aelia does stick around, but
now with even fewer, oh my goodness,
another challenge back to back and
Aligod couldn't do anything about it. We
are completely wiped out. Ireelia just
nowhere to be seen. No units in play.
Severely on the back foot now, even
though Animation had to spend a lot of
power and put it to the bottom of the
deck to do that. It seems like it might
be worth it if they can hold on and
rebuild from here.
>> Yeah, the good news is that I did see
Stellorn Herder in hand.
>> We have that Heart of Dark Ice, which is
effectively going to be able to give it
accelerate anyways. So, we can at least
contest a battlefield here. get that
fourth point, draw a card if we would
like. I don't know that we're going to
very easily be able to contest the set
here, especially with two energy open
and having drawn a lot of cards. There's
a lot of cards in the range that would
uh potentially throw that off. Uh the
biggest of which is of course punch
first and uh well, Aurelia got punched
twice last turn with the challenges. I
don't know if they want to get punched
first this turn, too. Here we go. Here's
our Teleorn Herder who we know flew
around. It was a menace earlier. So,
let's do it again everybody.
>> Yeah. Let's see. We're going to start
the battle off here. And there.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> A defiant dance that's going to swing
the tide of battle.
>> Yep, that certainly does. Not only is it
a big spell, but it's also one of the
most powerful signature spells on the
block that can really pump your own
damage while also lowering your
opponent's might.
>> And one thing about Set, we talk about
how large Set is, he's really not that
good at defending. Yes, he does have a
BF sword and he's got a buff, but uh one
spell is enough. But there it is. Punch
first.
>> Punch first. Punch hard.
>> Oh, I know. We're going to hard bargain
that has animation spent too much power
and energy you doing that we're down to
just the three and now that shoe is on
the other foot all of a sudden where
Aligu has
more than enough right now in comparison
to Animation who might struggle to make
a comeback now.
>> Yeah, that was that was a big point
here. Of course, we're now tied up at
four. The issue of course is that
Aurelia has no energy up. That
Stellicorn Herder is a sitting
Stellicorn. I think that's the that's
the the turn of phrases. You're there
like a sitting Stellicorn. Well, that is
exactly what they are. And this first
mate or even the unsung hero can go in
there, clean that up, and all of a
sudden we are back in the driver's seat
as the Fiora. That was quite spectacular
to be able to
use enough pump spells to get that
Stella corner quite so big to be able to
kind of take animation module down a
notch. It might not last, but they gave
a really good go of it and I'm very
impressed.
>> Oh, absolutely. I mean, that hard
bargain play right there is what is
keeping them even close to staying in
this game.
>> Absolutely. Yes. We're we're we're not
so far behind right now that we won't at
least take another look at another turn
and see where we're at. Don't know if
that's going to be the case after this
next turn, but we will see. The top of
the deck can always get you back in.
>> It can. We've already had it a lot
during this event so far. Those top
decks have been quite spectacular on a
multitude of occasions and it can just
happen to you as well.
The unfortunate thing for Aurelia is
that we are getting to that oh so scary
sixth point on the side of Fior. We've
got a lot of might. We've got the baited
hook to potentially even put more in
play
and a bunch of cards in hand
>> and still the energy to be able to use
them. So actually, even though we spent
a lot and had to recycle a lot last
turn, we have managed to use minimal
resources to be able to take back these
battlefields to be able to score extra
points, get to that pivotal six point,
that turning point of most games. And
then it's just how much you want to
reinforce that position to try and
prevent your opponent from being able to
take back what you have worked so hard
to achieve,
>> right? Yeah, at this point you're
feeling quite solidly ahead if if you
are a Fiora. So, it's not a matter of,
oh, well, I can win this game quite
easily. It's what do I do to set myself
up so that I don't lose to the worst
possible thing. Yes, that's what you
need to be that's what needs to be going
through their mind right now that I'm
just going to play a bunch of stuff and
see what happens. Like, no, the Aurelia
is a very, very tricky deck. And if
there's a deck that can do it, it is
Aurelia.
And well, getting another set brawler in
play after drawing two cards from the
unsung hero and effectively moving it
off of the battlefield. That's a pretty
good way to stay ahead in this game,
>> I would say. So, again, it's about
protecting our assets at this point.
You're ahead. You just need to stay
ahead and doing everything you can to
protect your power, to protect the
things that are keeping you in this game
is so valuable right now. So keeping
that set with the buff safe, great.
First mate, okay, we're going to have to
leave him there. It's not necessarily a
problem. It's a low cost unit, a low
might unit. Might be able to contest
some things, especially if we've got
some pump spells in hand. We might be
able to help punch first if something
little comes our way. But also, you got
to remember we're currently looking down
at an Aelia board state with no units in
play. Doesn't mean we can't ready them,
but it does require extra hoops to jump
through to do that.
>> Ooh, and we talk about putting some
might into play. How about Spectral
Matron, who's going to bring back
another first mate to ready the other
first mate. Bring him back.
>> Yeah,
>> didn't even have to leave him there in
potential danger in peril. No more.
First mate does come back to base. And
now we are in a really strong position.
Being at six, you only need eight points
to win. You want to take both
battlefields. Well, that's exactly what
Animation set himself up to do next
turn. He's got every ball in his court
and can maneuver those units in any way
they like. And that's what spells out
the win.
>> Yeah, we see Fiora taking down game
number one. That is a thing that can
happen to Aurelia as you just run out of
gas if you all of your units go. It's a
tough one to come back from, but we see
the sideboard here. We've got the Fiora
worthy as well as Axan which we saw come
in against before. Those harness dragons
also very very tough for Aurelia to deal
with. Really only the not so fast that
can target it. But on the side of
Aurelia, we've got some adaptatrons
potentially deal with those baited
hooks. The charms which we've seen be
very good as well as rebukes. Even
factory recall is going to be able to
prevent those gear from being so pesky
and making the units mighty, which
hopefully might slow animation module
down a little. That's all you really
need to do. You need to react to what
your opponent is presenting. And in the
case of animation, the units themselves,
apart from our late game units, aren't
that big. Like everything is kind of
manageable when it doesn't have
equipment and it doesn't have a buff.
Yeah, even the even the harness dragon
is it's six might and uh Aurelia goes
>> that's that's nothing when when I ready
I'm already five might. I mean if you
look at me I'm getting another might.
Like it's very easy to deal with the
harness dragon. Ar dragon's ability
though it's a little bit tougher to deal
with. But
>> with not so fast you can act you
actually can deal with that. And if
you're if you are spending resources on
the hook and you are hoping and needing
for that harness dragon to come in to
deal with an Aurelia or something and it
gets not so fast that can really shift
the tempo of the game.
>> Exactly that. And so that's as as our
Aurelia player, that's what we're going
to be looking to do. And it's just about
timing.
>> Yep.
>> It's about the cards that you draw cuz
we're going to need the optimal cards to
be able to pull that off. We're also
going to need to manage our energy
incredibly efficiently because we need
to be able to react in tow when those
threats come to play. And we want to be
getting things like that guardian angel
on the board really early.
>> Yeah. And if we look back at that game,
we think about it, there was multiple
unsung heroes with a BF sword that are
keeping the cards flowing in Fiora's
hand. If you ever played Fiora or any of
those body order I I always want to say
body odor body order decks. Oops, did I
say that on stream? Uh if you are going
to play one of those decks, you know
that the card draw is the tough thing
there. You end up playing a bunch of
units, you're like, "This is awesome."
And then they go away and I go, "Wait, I
have no more units to play. What
happened?
>> I have nothing. Yeah, where are they
all? I I swear I had them just here a
minute ago." And the problem is that
there is so much removal in this game.
Yes,
>> there are a lot of ways to push and pull
your opponent's units around by the
scruff of the neck kind of thing. You're
like coming
>> dragged kicking and screaming.
>> Yeah. And and that's the thing. There's
there's a lot of ways for your opponent
to interact with your units. And so what
you've got to do is just not let them.
And if you don't have the card draw to
back that up, then it's just going to be
a nogo. So, it looks like Animation
modules made a really great case for
themselves in giving themselves enough
card draw with this build of the deck,
but also utilized his opponent's Zorn
Warren to gain card advantage. The
Trifarian War Camp was a great play for
round one for game one here. um in round
seven because you're bolstering your own
ability to become mighty
>> but then utilizing your opponent saw war
and going oh actually I can draw cards
over there yeah I'm going to wiggle over
there for a minute actually because that
is what I need right now and that's the
problem your opponent is accidentally
giving you an advantage war camp doesn't
particularly help Ireelia much something
that's pushing Ireelia to these numbers
that matter that do something they don't
have an extra effect, whereas Fiora's
units get extra effects from that quite
often.
>> Absolutely. And if you have even one
extra unit, that's already a plus one on
your side for the the war camp. So, no,
really good call out there where you
know, Zon Warren is basically the
definition of a symmetrical battlefield.
Any deck is going to be able to take
advantage of that battlefield. Whereas,
yeah, Travarian War Camp was pretty much
one-sided for animation module. We saw
how that played out. Well, speaking of
onesided battlefields, how about
Monastery of Herana? That is a
battlefield that procs specifically off
of buffs, which uh I think if I had to
guess, the Fior deck is a little bit
better at getting their units buffed
than of course the Fiora. Though, there
is there is adaptron, which for some
reason buffs itself and also destroys a
gear. I'm not mad about it. I don't play
Lucian and that doesn't completely
destroy me. Couldn't be me. Uh the card
also buffs itself. So in this case they
could conquer buff it and then also um
you know sometimes be able to spend that
buff if it is already there and draw a
card.
>> We were just saying we were just saying
that one of the problems this deck can
encounter is not having enough card draw
first game. Cool. Yeah. Z Morren, my
opponent played it. That's great. Game
two, Monetary of Arana. I'll do it
myself this time and then you guarantee
it.
>> Brilliant choice there of our
battlefield for this game too. I imagine
uh Alig might just be wanting to be
there to prevent animation from using
it.
>> Yeah, and this is an interesting change
up here. This is Fiora is one of the
decks that actually quite regularly will
change its chosen champion. We are using
Fiora worthy which is the three cost
Fiora. When a unit becomes mighty you
can pay and order power to ready it.
That is different. We saw the uh Fior we
saw the other Fiora used as the chosen
champion last game. Fior worthy now
coming in and now the BF sword all of a
sudden becomes its own heart of dark ice
like we saw on the side of Aurelia last
game. If you can play it, make these
units mighty, you can effectively
accelerate them or move them back or
whatever you need, it can happen with
Fiora worthy.
>> Playing Fiora early can be a bit risky,
but also it's a relatively lowc cost
unit. So, actually, you kind of want to
get that out of there, get it into play
and just start being oppressive.
Although, it's really tempting to keep
your chosen champion over there and kind
of have it for when you need it.
Equally, these two work really well
together. We've now got the set brawler
down with his buff.
>> Yep. And now you can see they they they
spend all of their energy. They play a
unit and then immediately go into the
tank because there's actually two
decisions that need to happen. Well,
there's there's one decision that needs
to happen. They're going to they're
going to always use the ability here on
the side of the legend. They got a rune
and then they got to choose whether or
not they were going to actually ready
the set brawler there. I think they were
actually looking if they got another
order rune, they might have done it. It
that is at least what the body language
led me to believe that they got another
body rune and said, "No, no, no. Can't
can't not yet. Not yet. Going to have to
wait." Yeah. And honestly, sometimes
that can be it as well. You've got to
manage your resources and if you don't
get the rune that you need, then it's a
nogo.
>> Yeah. And here I think I saw a brief
look at a brief look at the hand of
Aurelia and I do not see another unit
which I mean the good news is that
you've got your chosen champion. The bad
news is that we saw what happened last
game when it was a double challenge and
the game effectively ended at that
point.
>> Yeah, that's the problematic part.
Challenge is a problem.
There are units on this board right now
that can challenge an Aurelia.
>> Yep.
>> Aurelia can be challenged in base. We do
have the guardian angel out early as we
assessed earlier. That was an really
important element, but it's not going to
help her a lot.
>> Yeah, that's the that's the look of
someone who has been painted into a
corner. They know that they have to do
this. Uh you can't really Yes, you want
to protect your rally, but you can't
really just wait forever. Uh just going
to equip the guardian angel and say
please please please please please
please please please don't have two
challenges here.
>> I yeah if if this is another backtoback
challenge that would be unbelievable
to be honest with you.
>> Salvage also works as a as one of the
challenges because you just need to get
rid of the guardian angel. Salvage does
that good enough. I didn't see if there
was a challenge or not.
>> I think we're going to try and draw some
cards. Looks like we're going to spend
the buff.
>> Yeah, why not?
>> Here uh to be able to draw cards cuz I
think we're going to try and get into
that challenge. I didn't see what the
top deck was.
>> We're going to go ahead channel a rune
ready set with the ability of Fiora.
>> Yeah, there was a little bit there was a
little bit of a shortcut there. If you
if you blinked, you may have missed it.
We saw the conquer with set. The
triggers go on the uh on the chain the
monastery for Anna. spend Set's buff and
then when Set conquers, he gives himself
another buff. So, they just shortcut it.
They didn't take the buff off and then
put it back on. No need to do that.
However, there is that window where Set
loses mighty and then becomes mighty,
which is why we see the legend there
exhausted to get an additional rune. And
when it became mighty, it also propped
Fiora worthy, which then spent an order
rune to ready the set again.
>> Just keep telling me about that combo.
>> I love it. I love it. It's so good. It's
just like, "Oh yeah, I'm going to do
this." And then, "Oh, wait. I basically
get to just double my money. This is
fantastic. I'm going to go again." Yeah.
>> And yeah, it's that beautiful part where
>> you just you never run out of buffs.
You're always buff.
>> You just always buff. It's sets going to
the gym all the time.
>> All the time.
We also saw the Fiora worthy who
normally won't get into the fray is fine
to do so if you have a good old first
mate. We see a sea monkey and a Dorne's
blade. Let's just put a lot of might
onto a battlefield and say, "Yeah,
Aurelia, do do what you want."
>> I think when you see your opponent
struggling like this, you kind of get
the notion that it's safe to just go,
"Cool, I'm just going to go wide with
this board. M
>> I'm going to create this completely just
undefeatable
amount of units and try and basically
say well I think I've got this game in
the bag if you don't do something about
it.
>> We do see the charm there which is going
to kill a set brawler from the set
brawler.
>> Great idea. Really want to be removing
that effect of being able to spend the
buff to be able to increase his might.
uh being outside of your own turn.
Animation won't be able to activate
that. So, the set does go down.
>> Yes, set goes down there. And that is a
good chunk of the might that was on the
side of animation module now gone.
Also a pro a uh a mighty procker for the
legend. And a lot of other things really
kind of come offline when you don't have
that set brawler. But we see a salvage
and that cannot be that is not something
that Aurelia wants to see when you are
trying to get rid of the guardian angel.
Very scary.
>> Yeah, you go ahead kill a gear and draw
a card. It's a two for one.
so good there just being able to not
only kill a very important piece of
gear, but also draw that card, which
again we've talked about is a really
hard thing to overcome on the side of
Fiora here.
But we need to see are they actually
going to be able to try are are they
going to try to take on this Aurelia in
combat with all of their runes up? That
is that is tough.
>> Scary. It depends what's in the hand,
right? If you have things like punch
burst, it's worthwhile. You think, okay,
well, you know, this is their only unit.
They've presented one singular unit this
entire game, and I don't think they have
another. So, if I am able to do this
now, that's great. But equally, if
animation module needs to take their
time, I think that they've
>> taken the nod from their opponent that
no other units are coming into play
particularly quickly. So, I think you
have the time just to build up this
board. It really could go either way.
And I think it thoroughly depends on
what cards are in the hand right now,
what we have access to, what we're going
to be able to use to kind of minimize
the effect that Aligu might be able to
have with the cards and the amount. Oh
my gosh. Okay. And Ashan's coming down
and just immediately equipping that
Doran's Blade.
>> Yep. That's a weapon master, which then
equips the Doran's Blade, which then
makes Ashan become mighty. I have to
imagine that the Ashan was drawn off of
the uh salvage or else I feel like that
ashan may have uh
>> yked the off that
>> yeah would have yked the guardian angel
but uh I mean still fine even even if it
wasn't it's still a fine unit right now
mighty
>> works we like it a menace when it comes
to being mighty but also just having
another strong unit in play and again
not overextending passing the turn on to
Aligu.
It's going to bring Aurelia back.
Try and yes, put another Guardian Angel
into play especially right after that
Arshan. Actually really fortuitous
timing there.
Yeah, very very good timing there
because when Axan when Axan steals the
guardian angel, it uh it basically never
goes back because if you kill the Aan,
it uh it saves the Oshan and the
Guardian Angel dies. So, not great.
>> No, we don't want that. So, fortuitous
timing there for Alli. Hope probably
feeling pretty smug about that one, I
got to say.
>> Yeah, and we're seeing a hard bargain
there to stop the hidden blade.
absolutely needed there because again
there are not any other units on the
side of Aurelia here. So really just
grasping on to this princess. Absolutely
needs to protect the princess or else
the whole kingdom may fall.
>> Really clutching on here. Everyone's
trying their hardest and utilizing every
resource. Oh no, there's another Arc
Shine.
No, you got to be kidding me.
>> Oh, and a punch first and a rebuke. Oh
my goodness. Look, a repost even. Look
at this. Oh, this is
>> this is bad.
>> Yeah, this is this could absolutely
uh spell the end.
>> Oh, there it is.
>> Yeah, say it with me. Yoink. Oh,
Arshan goes ahead, takes that
equipment. We were talking so highly of
guardian angel being just that the
guardian angel of Aurelia. Aurelia now
strip Bear is just a little bit exposed
to the elements now
>> and we are seeing the full complement of
Ashons here. We've got a lot of might in
the base. The Aurelia, I mean, there are
some pump spells on the side of Aurelia
to to take this fight, but it is going
to be tough to try to navigate this,
especially through punch first, which we
know is there, especially through the
repos, which we also know is there. I
mean, this could be the end of Aurelia
right here.
>> It depends whether you're brave enough
to go into battle right now. Wow,
there's a lot of power still standing on
Aurelia's side and I can see a lot of
dances in that hand as she does love to
dance and when she does she gains might
and your opponent loses it. So it is a
very scary position to be in. Is it
time? It's time.
>> Oh, that is the I'm crunching the
mountain burst here.
Nah, I'll let you figure it out.
>> I won game one. Let's just do it.
>> Yeah. Uh I think I think we can all
agree that we've all made that exact
same play. Yeah, we've
>> I've played this deck and done that
play.
>> We've all done the we're we're we're
trying to be We're trying to put our uh
our math our math class on and No, no,
I'm I'll make you do it.
>> Oh, we still have the guardian angel.
That's going to help out. Um if you're
animation as well. Ali has a lot of
decisions to make themselves now as
animation module has kind of forced the
matter. Of course, we get that first
Defiant Dance.
>> Yep. Defiant dance is going to make it 9
to5 if my quick maths is correct. Uh
10 even. There we go.
>> So, we still got a ways to go.
>> Still have quite a ways to go. I
>> And we don't really have enough energy
to back it up, but I don't know. We can
do one more.
>> Yeah, we can play one more define dance
which I believe will make it
>> 1313 I think.
>> And but then we do have the guardian
angel which will save a Yep.
>> at least. So then we're not left
completely dry.
>> I mean this is not factoring in the
punch first that we know is there and
the repost that we know is there. We're
not factoring that. And yeah, animation
module just says, "Okay,
>> yeah,
>> let's let's let this happen.
>> Sure. Yeah, go for it." We I get Doran's
blade just comes back to base. Aran just
chilling there. And there we go. We just
going to have managed
>> to tackle down the beast that Aurelia
can provide for this. I just honestly
being able to overcome that is
phenomenal.
when Alli made such a great comeback to
the initial
impact that animation was providing with
all of those units.
>> Yeah, and and don't get me wrong, this
is a a a nightmare scenario for Aurelia.
However, I really like the play there of
not committing that second that that
second spell there because I do too. You
know, you can make the fight there
and you might win, but are you you can
win the battle, but are you going to win
the entire game is the question. And I
think they said, "Yeah, I can spend
these resources here. Maybe make a run,
but I'm not actually going to be winning
the game. I'm going to be spending way
too much. Not do enough. I'm just going
to take what I can get here. Kill off
almost all of your board and go from
there."
>> Boots of swiftness come down and I
reckon Yep. We're just going to start
building up.
>> Just taking the, you know, animation,
you're not going to win yet, so that's
okay. We're gonna just let this happen
for a bit. I'm going to build up my
board.
>> I'm going to Heart of Dark Ice your
action. Just Here you go. I I want to
use my card. I Hey, I played it. I get
to use it. Why not?
>> I got to respect it. I got to respect
it.
>> Sometimes it's about sending the
message.
>> Alex jumps back to base. got two open
battlefields. Alli doesn't have anything
to put in them right now, but that's not
that that might not last forever.
>> Yeah, I think I saw a Stellicorn Herder
in the hand. So, we may actually start
being able to
claw our way back. And we do actually
have quite a few runes. But that is a
spectral matron that is going to be
bringing back your pick of favorite
smaller unit in the trash here. Looks
like we may
>> Yeah, I think it's I think it's got to
be our first mate. And that's going to
ready Ashan to be able to dance around
the world here over to the monastery for
Anna. Get up to that sixth point and
keep up the pressure.
>> Wanted to hop on over to the monastery,
check out if anyone's there. Has any got
a buff I can spend. Uh, not right now.
Okay, but still good for later. And we
still want those precious, precious
points getting up to that pivotal six.
And hopefully we'll be able to close it
out soon. It would just simply take that
hold point and then taking the aspirants
climb. But we do need the extra point
due to the aspirants climb. So we are
going to need at least one extra turn on
top of that. So Alli does have a little
bit more time thanks to their own
battlefield.
>> Yeah, this is this is the pivotal turn
here. Even though next turn, like you
said, Fiora is not going to win next
turn, per se, but it's about how can
Aurelia set up here to actually put
themselves in a position to win. They've
got time.
>> Yeah, they've got a little bit a little
bit of time.
>> A little window.
>> Not not a lot, but sometimes a little
Yeah, absolutely. And especially when
you can get a little bit of time with a
Stellacicorn herder, sometimes that can
lead to a lot of great things. Little
bit of Stella corn in my life.
>> Pop those booties on and off we go to
Aspirin's climb.
>> Yep. We shall see.
>> There's a lot of decisions. This is a
very very It's been a We've been a long
day. We're on round seven here at the
regional qualifier for Rip. Oh, hello,
>> Adaptron.
>> Well, well, well. Haven't seen that card
yet today, but I'm very glad that I now
am. And we got Oh, we got the opponent
reading the card. That's my favorite.
We've done it twice now today. Oh, yeah.
Have a little look. Just remind myself
what that does. Fantastic.
>> Yep. It's uh when the Adaptatron
conquers, you can destroy a gear if you
do buff it.
>> Wyatt has all that taxed again. It's a
It is a It's an evil card is all I can
say as a player.
>> We love that for Alli because finally
their opponent's battlefield might be
quite useful. We could use that buff to
draw a card.
And that that's unusual for an Aelia
deck to be able to use Monastery of
Herana. But for now, we're just going to
utilize that to jump on over to
Aspirin's Climb and score a point cuz we
got to start doing that. We need more
points. We need to get back in the game.
>> Otherwise, it's going to spell disaster.
And we know that we know that Animation
can't win next time. Ashan isn't that
scary right now.
Yeah, he's not he's not that scary.
Still he's still scary. Still still a
little bit scary, but we are he's over
there. It's fine.
>> Yeah, he he's all the way over there. We
are seeing animation module in the tank
here deciding what do they want to do?
Can they do anything? Maybe hidden blade
or something might be an option to
potentially try to stop this adapter. It
is likely going to hit the Doran's
blade, I would imagine. May m maybe the
the guardian angel, but I would think
the Dorne's blade
>> is probably a little bit more
troublesome right now.
>> It's a tough decision.
>> I see I could see it as either, I
suppose.
>> Do we have a response to that?
>> That's what I'm trying to wonder if
there is a response. I guess we could
see something like challenge. That is
action speed. So, we could
>> It's Ouxion speed in this case where you
can challenge the Aon onto the Adaptron.
I don't know if I would want to do that.
>> No consideration, but yeah, we're going
for the guardian angel.
>> And there we go. We get a buff. Okay, we
get to uh the other ability of Aurelia
Blade Dancer is that when you conquer,
you can pay an energy to ready the
legend, which of course allows you to
dance around the battlefields, which is
what this boots of swiftness is going to
be able to do.
>> Challenging that Arshan, who now is a
little bit squishier now. The guardian
angel isn't there helping it out. And
we've got some significant Oh, wait. I
say significant maybe not. Punch first
coming in to add an extra five onto that
Argan bolstering us up to 11. Defiant
dance coming in toe to to bolster
adapter try and debuff Archan from that
punch burst. God, there's some
mathematical jump rope going on here.
Yeah, and we talked about it uh just a
couple of turns ago where they could
have actually used that defiant dance
earlier to maybe win a combat or tie a
combat. I don't I don't quite remember,
but they said, "You know what? I'm just
going to cut my losses here. I'm going
to I'm going to destroy some of your
units now. I'm going to save this defant
dance." And here it is absolutely
massive. Having that might lead here is
going to not only destroy the auction,
it's going to also destroy the gear.
Doesn't matter if the adaptron's already
buffed. It can only be buffed once. But
yes, I found out the hard way. It can
kill multiple gear. It doesn't matter.
And to add insult to injury, it cost our
opponent a punch first as well.
>> It did. And those punch first are so
imperative for a deck like this to be
able to hold on to for the right
moments. And Divine Dance just kind of
came in and went, "Actually, no, no, no,
no, no, no. I'm going to make that a lot
weaker cuz I do not fancy letting that
resolve
>> at all. But we are looking like we've
got a
>> scrabby.
>> Yes, the salvage there is going to be
able to destroy the boots of swiftness
which is going to put us back at what
looks like potentially 9 to9
>> and drawing one as well on guard
boosting it back up again. It is
endless.
This is back and forth.
>> Both players are expending a lot of
resources. Whoever wins this showdown
could set the pace for the rest of the
game.
>> Yeah, if I mean if Aelia loses this,
>> it is not good for them.
>> It is very, very bad.
>> A lot of resources on this fight and
they are not going to have a lot left
over. If they win, it's still an uphill
battle, I would think, considering the
amount that has been lost. But they're
at least going to be able to take down
this action. They're going to be able to
take down that additional gear. They're
going to have a big or they're going to
have a a four might
uh adapt here and um you know, from
there
they are going to be in an all right
spot, but it's still an uphill battle.
>> Fair enough.
>> At least they don't lose right now.
>> Exactly. Adaptron has put in so much
work right now. now I think deserves a
pat on the back regardless uh going up
against this Arshan and so many spells
have been slung back and forth and it's
about noting whether you want your
opponent's
spells to resolve and in what order but
we're going for the repost
>> oh repost is absolutely
huge it's going to be that one might
difference
insane is going to be enough. That is
going to prevent the adaptron from
conquering. It is going to destroy the
adaptron itself. That is going to have
>> completely decimated the runes on the
side of the reel. Completely decimated
the cards in hand, the resources,
everything. It's kept the auction in
play. We're going up to seven. We're
potentially even going up to eight. With
only six runes and a single card, well,
we'll have two cards next turn. It is
not looking good for Aurelia. Animation
module might only have two cards in
hand, but they have three units in play,
one equipment, and enough energy to at
least play something out of their hand.
They're going to be going up to eight
here, and they need one extra point
because we do have Aspirin's climb in
play. So, yep, just bolstering that top
one there. Basically saying if you can't
take two, then that is game over. And
it's doubtful, but we'll take a look at
the top deck. See if it saves us.
>> Hey, I see Stellicorn Herder. That's a
start.
It all starts with Stellicorn Herder.
We've got the Heart of Dark Ice. It's
not It's going to cost us a rune. That's
fine.
>> We can ready it.
>> We don't need to save these runes for uh
for later.
>> Celicorn could draw us a card. It could
be it could help us out.
>> Okay,
what have we got? We've got 12 versus
six right now. There it is. animation
module comes to be mighty themselves
winning round seven of our regional
qualifier here in Leo. Yeah, and more
importantly that is a Fiora at 70
at an RQ. I don't know that we've seen I
I'm going back through the the database
here in my mind. I don't know that we've
seen a Fiora perform this well this
early in a in an RQ in recent history.
The last time I remember it doing well
was in the Chinese the Chinese uh
regional events a while ago. Early early
Spirit Forged. I don't know that we've
seen Fior really perform since then.
>> Well, there we go. It's the first time
for everything, at least over here in
Europe. And I'm very thrilled to see it
doing well. It was just such a shame
that Aurelia didn't manage to quite put
up enough of a fight even though that
you could see it was there. The the push
and the pull and it was just which cards
were in hand.
>> Absolutely.
>> At the end of the day, the repost at the
end there really did just cherry on the
top
>> and just you could see the writing on
the wall from there.
>> Yeah, it's it's so funny when you're
playing a com deck, you're like, well,
I've got access to all of the counter
spells and then your opponent plays
their own counter spell. Oh yeah, wait
wait wait wait wait.
>> I I'm the counter spell deck and they go
I
>> sorry sorry sorry bro
>> don't know what to tell you other than
uh that adaptatron is gone. Uh and it
was absolutely crazy. I mean again I
mean this is just like the last round we
cast where it's it's not just the cards
you have in hand. It's when you are
choosing to play them picking your
moments you're you're doing the little
the the the psychological dance of of
hey do I have it? Do I not have it? Are
you going to go in? Am I going to go in?
Am I going to be able to get a two for
one off? All this stuff,
>> it's important. Everything matters.
>> Super important. All of those little
values that you can acrue over the
course of a game really end up paying
off.
>> And all of those micro decisions when
you're thinking about what you're going
to spend and how much you're going to
put into a combat, how much you're going
to say, "How much am I committing to
this showdown? Is it important that I
win this one now?
>> Can I just let this one glide by? Can I
just let that happen?" And those are the
really key impactful moments that can
spell out a game's entirety. And that's
kind of what we saw there where Aurelia
just wasn't quite able to keep pace. And
every single time we thought, oh, a
comeback's coming, it just didn't quite
happen. Like when we finally had um we
finally had that wonderful equipment and
then Archan came down, even after a
first one had to come down, we were
like, "Oh, you got to be kidding me.
You've got to be kidding me." So, it was
just a back and forth that just seemed
never ending between the two.
>> Yeah. And and we saw Urelia, you know,
really kind of struggled in that second
game. They only had the Aurelia at
first, and they really valiantly
defended the the Aurelia, but we saw the
dust settle. I was like, where where did
all my where did all my runes go? I
thought I had the aren't I supposed to
get two of these a turn? Where where in
the world did they go? Uh it was like
when I first started playing spear
forge, it was just all of my decks. I
just I just spent all of my runes. I
don't know what happened. Uh that's what
happened there to protect the Aurelia
and then when you're able to get that
little that that little bit over the
top, take out that unit, all of a sudden
the Aurelia player is playing from
behind with very few runes. Uh and still
played very very well. We pointed out
number of times where
>> they made decisions that were like,
okay, I am playing to win this game, not
to just win this combat.
>> Exactly. And that's exactly where we saw
like the pause with that defiant dance
could have been played earlier, but
actually it was more advantageous to
leave it until there was that back and
forth of a combat where they felt like,
"Oh, actually no, I am going to put my
all into this." Unfortunately, in that
very slim chances of those last few
cards in your opponent's hand being
exactly what they needed, that huge
counter spell being able to come back
actually
>> was really almost disappointing cuz you
held on. You held on to that defiant
dance knowing it was the right thing to
do.
>> Yeah.
>> And then it still got countered.
>> Yeah. It's always, it's so funny when
you think of when you see repost, you're
like, "Oh, I'm gonna gonna counter a
time warp. I'm gonna get plus 10. It's
going to be so great." It's like, "No, I
just need to counter one."
>> Yeah.
>> A one cost spell to get plus one.
>> That was enough to win by exactly one
and still uh and still be able to uh get
the win there. But we have got a nice
little interview here for you. Let's
throw it on over.
>> Thank you very much, Blevens. and Amy.
I'm joined by Animation Module.
Congratulations on your win.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Congratulations. That was a round seven
win on the Fiora. Uh how was the game
for you?
>> Uh the the G the game is the most tense
I had for today and even for even
including yesterday.
>> Okay. And it's hard to believe that you
can win the combat from Fiona.
>> Yeah. You you you made the comeback
happen with Fiora. Why did you pick
Fiora for this tournament? what makes
her good?
>> Uh because there was one big reason I
think most of people don't understand
how this deck works and that is a hu
advantage for me. Also it's closed deck
list. So like I have some spicy cyborg
cards which it can be very good. Uh and
also I think this deck has a good meta
against uh uh how can I say has a good
matchup against the meta decks.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Whi which decks do you think is
good for Fiora about the meta?
>> Yeah, I think in main deck is for sure
is the driven because I can dodge the
combat very much my first mate or hook.
So we just uh accumulating the power on
board. Yeah. On the base and apparently
I'm doing that better than D.
>> Nice. Well, I mean that's the way to win
right now in the meta. Congratulations
on your win. Best of luck for the rest
of the tournament. We're gonna send it
over to Barcode.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. I am here with Kasanova. We
are used to hearing his voice usually,
but now he decided to step into the
spotlight. Kasanova, so happy to have
you here. How are you doing? No, I'm
doing well. I really enjoy getting a
chance to play. I mean, I'm often in the
booth. I'm often standing with like we
could we could change spots, you know. I
got to interview you in a second here,
but we'll have to we after this we'll do
the reverse interview, right? Yeah.
Yeah. But but yeah, it's been it's been
nice. I mean, I decided to pick up
Lucian like 3 days ago. I mean, I I was
uh playing Rexite for a while. I was
winning some skirmishes and then I
started playing against like my
teammates and some of my friends that I
test with and I couldn't win a game for
like three days. So, I was like, well,
let's try some other stuff. uh didn't
have much time to prep and after playing
like one or two games on Lucian I fell
in love with the deck and I was like why
have I not been playing this before like
why did no one tell me this deck is fun
like nobody told me this deck was fun at
all definitely never said that it was a
fun deck I promise
>> never never ever you hear that Blev
>> yeah absolutely
>> but not only the deck is very cool to
play but it's also very strong indeed I
mean it is not a tier one but I think
the deck can sneak into the top eight
probably or maybe in the day two. How
would you rate the deck right now?
>> Yeah, I mean I think it's like probably
like a high B tier. It's like right
under all the the top decks, but it
attacks the meta in a pretty decent way.
It's pretty good into Aurelia. It's
pretty good into Draven. And then I
think you kind of struggle with some of
the spell decks, but you have all of
these tools at your disposal to still
get good around it. And because it's a
combo deck, like sometimes you just draw
it and you have it and you just uh you
could beat anything when you you find
the combo. So yeah,
>> exactly. And speaking about beating
everything, how is your tournament going
so far?
>> Yeah, it's been going pretty well. You
caught me right after a loss, so kind of
horrible timing. I don't know why you
guys would do this to me, but no, it's
it's been a lot of fun.
>> We try our best.
>> I'm I'm I'm 5'2 right now, so I'm about
to go play a win and in uh to see if I
can make it to day two. Um overall, it's
been great. I've been beating the match
ups I expect to win. Uh I actually lost
the matchups I expected to lose, so it's
really gone as I anticipated Lucian. And
from here, I just feel like I need to
lock in and and win one more. I think
I'm playing pretty well. So, I'm I'm
excited.
>> So, the next one will be pretty intense
for you because you have to win it, but
on the other hand, I mean, of course, it
is cool to perform well, but speaking
about the the the atmosphere in general,
how do you find the atmosphere here in
the venue in Leil? It's been amazing.
I've loved Leil. I had a a nice little
walk over here in the morning and
there's like a nice little cafe by where
I'm staying and I mean it's been just
incredible being out here. But also just
in the venue, plenty of people coming up
to me talking about, you know, letting
me know they love the content or even
just wanting to talk about Riftbound
with me has been so much fun. I
absolutely love it. There's nothing I
like more than talking about Riftbound
and I think people could guess that from
how much I yap when I'm on the desk or
how much I yap in my content. So I I
love it. I love being here with
everybody and it's just great that I get
to experience the the full event whereas
oftentimes when we're working, you know
how it is like you're you kind of get
stuck just doing all the work and you
don't get to fully embrace it all and
enjoy it. So,
>> exactly. And that's absolutely cool to
see you. I mean, this smile and this uh
the experience that you have, it's
absolutely insane. But for now, we are
going to let you rest a little bit and
to prepare yourself for the next round
because it is just around the corner.
Don't go anywhere and get ready for last
round.
>> We've got a moment or two to get ready
for the last round, but we are we're
nearly there. Nearly there on round
eight. Thank you very much, Barcode, for
talking with Casanova. Um, I will say of
all of the broadcast team, I would put
you up there as being able to to do well
on the day. Cass is doing really well. I
know I would not. I I would definitely
>> put more effort into playing your deck
and learning it. Utre. My my game plan
is to show up and try and and play to
like sadly I'm not in the main event,
but I'll I'll go beat up people in side
events. Uh and I'll try and win one of
the prize wall medal cards in
>> going to be your deck of choice for now.
>> Uh
>> well, actually, no, we it's already
going to be in unleashed.
>> Yeah, exactly. That's what I mean. It's
it's unleashed. So, I I kind of have to
change up. I I I want to play Leblanc,
but at the same time, I feel like
there's some really like weird Aurora
decks that could come out. We you
mentioned Aurora Poppy earlier today,
right? I like legitimately think I might
try and make that work. Just
>> Aurora Poy with Vanguard Armory and the
the the Elder Dragons just chilling in
the base.
>> That sounds the right amount of jank for
me to play. That that's what I want for
that scenario. Um you know, we we're
getting close to the end of day one. Um
and I think looking at the statistics,
there's pretty much every champion,
every legend still alive for day two. I
know we were looking at was like an on
was
>> we were looking from the from the uh
round before because we don't have yet
the every single result from this round.
So we can't really be certain about it,
right?
>> Yeah, there's still a few tables playing
uh in round seven right now. So we don't
have that data yet available.
>> But in the previous round, I remember
checking like the road for every single
legend that is, you know, when it comes
to the metal foil. Yeah.
>> And the best legend the best worst
legend
>> Yes. with the lowest performing score
currently.
>> Exactly. Was four and two. And that was
on and there was another legend that I
can't remember.
>> But still alive. Still alive for day
two. Of course, if you get that six win
point or 50 and three, uh you can of
course qualify.
>> Actually, I lied. Garin was one and
three.
>> Oh, no. Wait, wait, but someone else but
someone else could have been better with
the Gar. So, no, I did not lie.
>> Well, we'll see. We'll see how that ends
up playing. Uh that also is one of those
things that I think is a little bit
different for for seasoned competitive
players perhaps from from other card
games where you know you have a bad day
and you just go I'll I'll 03 drop or
I'll one three drop but if you play out
the rest of your rounds
>> you can still be the best of your legend
if you're metal card hunting.
>> It's one of my
>> most favorite things about playing in
ripon tournaments because you see more
people actually try till the end. You
know, it's like you have you're playing
a little bit less of a known legend, a
less popular legend, right? And you're
going to be able to maybe fight for that
grand prize because you're just going to
win four last rounds.
>> Yeah. You know, and suddenly you just
skyrocketed standings and maybe someone
else who played the same legend as you
lost four rounds in a row. You never
know.
>> Exactly. And then you'll you'll end up
better on that best off placement. So it
it is one of the unique things we have
with regards to prizing that uh keepsake
that uh you know big
>> celebratory moment of like you are the
best of from this tournament. Love that.
Love that we have uh the ability to
crown not just one winner of the
tournament but winners across all
brackets throughout. We'll keep a track
of those stories as we go through
tomorrow as well.
>> Correct. But I wanted to say one more
thing. Before the this before this
round, there were still a few players of
course with 6. There's going to be more
than few of them. But I didn't see that
many Dravens.
>> Yeah,
>> there were like two Rexi in the top
five. Um there was a Allen with the
Ezreal of course at six and zero as
well. No surprise over here. Uh then we
had Master Ye. We had Victor Colin was
zero and playing on the secondary show
match. And I'm not certain if he
actually won or not.
>> Yeah, I haven't seen that result either.
>> Yeah, but there's there's very wide
array
of decks that are being in the top right
now, which is awesome to see. So, this
tournament is really exciting to watch
from a perspective of viewer that wants
to see different type of decks and right
now I was not casting this FA match, but
I was watching it without sound and I
was like, yeah, this is really awesome.
You can see different play styles. This
is the baited hook Fiora, but it still
has some kind of mid-range when it
doesn't have like this baited hook
setup. The play um the level of quality
of play from the F player was actually
very high. It was a pleasure to watch,
you know, and it's not something that
you were enjoying in the previous meta
game maybe when they were, you know,
just more prevalent popularity of of
other like legends like Draven and was
just
>> flooding over everything else.
>> Yeah. And you mentioned the uh the
diversity of the decks being played. Of
course, that means they have to come
from different domains. uh and for newer
players while we've still got a moment
uh before we get into the next round. We
have been breaking down the domains and
their profiles all weekend long. So Amy
and I had a moment to chat about some
yesterday.
>> Back pals, pros and pro players. We're
here back once again to shine the light
of Riftbound upon you. and we're going
to be chatting a little bit about the
domains, what they do, what the
differences are, and how you might
employ those strategically in your
decks. My name is Amy Wley, and I am
joined by the wonderful James.
>> Hey Amy, let's talk about some some
domains from from Rift Band.
>> Let's do it. So, first up, we're going
to have a little look at the body
domain. That is our first one that we're
going to be chatting about, and it's a
very aggressive start. Do you want to
give me a bit of an overview about how
you see body employing in the game?
>> Yeah, so body as a domain has a lot of
late game power especially um especially
when we look at kind of like set
brawler. Um these three cards do
represent three different parts of the
domain. So I think we'll kind of take it
step by step for each one. Uh set
brawler, everybody in set one is very
familiar with this card. Um can really
close out games with immense impact. uh
the ability to kind of like you know
play around buffs uh to get him to to
power himself up with extra might makes
combat very very difficult to overcome.
So body one of the basic things is just
like playing really big units or units
that can get very very strong uh and
making sure you're going to win win
showdowns before they even really start.
>> Absolutely. And that's what it's all
about. It's about having those high
strength units utilizing buffs as best
you can. It's a fantastic mechanic, but
only when utilized well. And that's
exactly what units like set brawler do.
And you want to build these large
resilient board states that create a
kind of wall that your opponent just
cannot overcome.
>> Yes. Uh and the one thing I will say,
the downside of body units does tend to
be either some setup to get there or
high cost. Um so body needs a way of
getting around high cost units. one of
my favorite cards. I am a degenerate
Dazzling Aurora player. Uh Dazzling
Aurora kind of helps you just, you know,
cheat that out. Like, how do I get a a
high cost unit on the board really
easily? Well, I'll just play it
basically for free. Uh you get that
Dazzling Aurora. It is obviously high
cost to get to Dazzling Aurora, but once
it's on the board, once you're able to
get that uh trigger to pull creatures
and units from your deck, you just get
to to kind of, as you say, build a giant
wall of units and just stand there
steadfast and basically assume your
opponent can't get through you.
>> Yeah, exactly that. And that's exactly
what he's trying to achieve. It's not
necessarily the most aggressive in the
early game, but in the late game, that's
when you kind of make that comeback. So,
it's okay to have that slow start. You
allow your opponent to do their thing,
and you're kind of doing your own thing
in the meantime. You're kind of like,
"Oh, yeah. Don't look at what I'm doing
for a minute, la." And then all of a
sudden, your board state's just out of
control.
>> Yes. But you got to get there. And one
of the ways of getting there. You
mentioned letting your opponent do their
thing. And I'm a player that doesn't
love letting my opponent do their own
thing. One of my other favorite cards is
from Body is Sabotage. Um, it's an early
game card. It does of course make you
recycle one, but what you get for that
is you get to view the opponent's hand.
You get to pick a non-unit card and say,
"No, you're going to discard that. Get
that out of the game. I don't want you
using that early.
>> I don't want to see that anytime soon."
That's so right. And that's the thing.
You do have a little bit of control. Not
a lot, but enough just to allow you to
keep ticking over.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It tends to be just enough
to last through that early game. Um, I
think for me, body also is one of the
most
not undiscovered, but I I I think
there's a lot of flavor in in the units
from body, especially for like kitchen
table Riftbound is the way that I would
say of like jamming games with friends,
one v one, uh like free-for-alls and
2v2s. There's some interesting units in
there from Origins, from Spirit Forge.
I'm like, try some stuff out. Yeah.
Okay. A lot of body cards aren't
necessarily in the meta right now, but
there's some fun stuff to play around
with.
>> There really are. And there are a lot as
well that have deflect as well. we can
utilize that and that then kind of slows
down our spell slinger decks in the
format. So that kind of gives you
another element of controlling what your
opponent can achieve based on your
units.
>> So we've talked about slowing people
down. I think that is probably where we
need to look at our second domain uh for
our discussion and we're looking at
calm. Yeah. Um, calm is a domain that is
a lot more about controlling your
opponent. Um, and whether that's through
slowing them down with counter spells,
uh, and things like not so fast, which
of course was brought in with, um, with
spirit forge, or just spells in general,
really spell heavy, uh, in the in the
calm domain. Yeah, calm, quite the
opposite of body, seeks to have balance,
hold positions, and use defensive tricks
and disruption to bring that game to a
close. Kind of not letting your opponent
achieve what they're trying to by using
these kind of combat tricks like on
guard and then holding. We're using stun
to prevent damage going through and then
obviously lots of action and reaction
cards which help it just to function
freely.
>> Yeah, I will say calm as a domain I
think is probably one of the domains
that relies on your experience with
Riftbound being uh a part of what
factors into the cards you choose. That
sounds really strange. And for those of
you that that may be uh uh newer to TCG
players, when you're playing a deck that
contains counter spells, you need to
know what is the worst thing my opponent
is going to do to me and hold my counter
spell and stop that. Because if you use
it on on just a card that's going to
draw one or something like that, that's
not good. If your opponent has a rebuke
in hand, for instance, that's why you
want to not so fast because that's the
big game ending like play. So, it's
difficult because you need to be able to
balance what's coming next while playing
uh calm deck. So, I think that's
something that that newer players
definitely need to like dig into is
like, hey, you got to know what your
opponent's running to.
>> And I think in that respect, the domain
is very aptly named.
>> Yeah.
>> Calm down or don't play everything right
away. You need to almost envelop that
element of calm yourself and think,
okay, what's the strategy I need to
employ? What are the potential cards,
you're so right, that my opponent could
bring against me that's really going to
mess up what I'm trying to achieve? And
that's why calm, I think quite often, is
the domain that relies a lot on your own
knowledge. Yes. your knowledge of the
game, your knowledge of the cards and
what people can achieve. Whereas, we
just looked at body, that is a lot more
free in that you can probably deal with
anything that comes your way. You don't
really mind what it is.
>> Yeah, I I'll say it as the Aurora
player. Everybody always says, "Well,
Aurora players don't win the games. The
deck wins the game." And I'm like, "No,
I win the game. I get to play cards,
too. I'm all right." But I will say
compared to playing something like an
Aurelia who leans into calm one of the
second card we had that uh discipline um
or we had on guard but discipline is is
the same uh principle where you have to
think okay well if I'm using this spell
and I'm getting a target okay I can
untap now I've got to think two more
game actions down the road in order to
to decide okay is that enough to win the
game this turn and for me as an Aurora
player
>> I'm not in that mentality I'm just like
let's wing it off the top of the deck
Yeah, you have to be a lot more
methodical. You have to, like you say,
it's like a game of mental chess, but
just be yourself. You're playing the
mini game there. And really successful
players that are coming with calm into
an event are just that. They are coming
in with that methodical, meditated
approach and they know that they can
take their time and they're just going
to react to what their opponent is doing
and then kind of play this almost
protect the princess strategy of I've
got a few units.
They're the kind of core of this and
then I'm going to use these spells and
actions to really put the pressure on my
opponent.
>> Yeah, it's exactly that way. you're like
is you have a lot of spells, a lot of
actions that you can utilize in order to
keep something safe, but it's
understanding that game plan around it.
And one thing that I think players are
going to have to understand as we go
towards unleashed a little bit more is
the stun mechanic, which has been pretty
much within the calm domain for now. Um,
we know Vex of course is going to have
that coming into the game uh with
Unleashed. I'm expecting to see it a lot
more. But we had rune prison already as
a card as one option for stunning, but
that ability to say, "Okay, no, you're
not really going to um be able to
participate in this combat. I will
correct myself slightly. We of course
have Leona uh from previous sets, which
relied heavily on stun, but it is within
the calm domain. We'll see more of it
within the calm domain. Um people got to
get used to saying, "Okay, I'm going
into a showdown, but maybe I'm not going
to be able to survive through it because
all that might's going to go away."
>> And that's what it's all about. It's
about managing the damage that's coming
your way and thinking about how you're
going to reduce that or stop that
entirely so that then you are swinging
the advantage back into your court. And
that's what calm's all about. Being
calm, being mediated, making every move
meticulously and knowing when to utilize
all of those cards. Thank you very much
everyone for joining us. We're going to
scoot off back to the action and we'll
catch you up soon.
Welcome back everybody. We are in
between rounds seven and round eight. I
know that there are a couple of rounds
still still going on or a couple of
games I should say still going on from
round seven. I believe there have been a
couple of judge calls and stuff like
that that you know surprising. Exactly.
We're getting right down to it at the
end of the day. So,
>> I have some breaking news though.
>> Oh, breaking breaking news.
>> Yes, Alan lost the match. But that's not
the breaking news.
>> Bad news. Well, if you're
>> breaking news actually the fact that
Garen is in locked in for day two.
>> Garen is locked in. Garen is locked in
for day two.
>> We're Are we confirmed? Confirmed. Do we
Do we know that?
>> I mean, I'm saying that with 99.99%
certainty. So hopefully I'm not wrong.
But from two different sources, I've
seen that Garen is confirmed for day
two.
>> Drop another old league reference and
say confirmed on Saint. Uh
that's a real old one. If you're with me
on that one, uh yeah, your the your age
is at least beginning with a three. Uh
anyway,
>> oh my god references. Well, we don't say
you don't look like it begins with a
four. You're all good.
>> I can shave and I will be then like more
like three.
>> That's that's very very fair. Well, it
is a close shave for players now that
are looking to get their final points to
join
>> everybody in round uh day two, I should
say. Round nine begins tomorrow morning.
We're waiting for round eight now. So
remember in the way of competitive
riffbound, three points for winning a
series, one point for tying a series,
zero points for a draw. So you need to
reach that six wins or five wins and
five draws. Uh sorry, three draws. Don't
don't be in the draw bracket if you can
help it. Try and get out of that mess.
>> Yeah, if you're in the draw bracket,
then you are actually meeting more
people that are drawing. So you have a
higher chance of drawing
>> drawing. So it's not great. Yeah.
>> Yeah. You just win is the the easy way
of putting that. Uh that was one of the
things that we thought coming out of
Bolognia, like you mentioned Allan, his
Ezreal deck. I think so many people were
like, "This looks like such a good deck.
I'm going to play this deck. I cannot
wait. Draw a lot of cards." And you
finish game one and you look at the
clock and you're like, "What do you mean
that took 40 minutes?"
>> Like, "Oh my god."
>> Oh, now I'll sideboard. Okay. And now
I've got to make decisions and and get
through games. So that's half of it at a
tournament is finishing your round in
enough time. But funnily enough, um, one
of the seven zeros that we have
currently in the game is on Ezreal and
he apparently has one of the best
eyeers, if not the best eye blockers,
but we cannot be certain because again
the round didn't finish it.
>> But overall, I can tell you like from
right now what it seems like we have
Ezreal, Fiora, Fiora, Urelia, Fiora.
That's crazy. That's that's a lot of
>> then we have Draven Victor Colin who was
already featured on uh one of the
matches is seven and zero with the
Victor.
>> Nice.
>> Then we have Azir uh but that's Giovanni
which I don't think is Rock IO rock who
was I don't believe so.
>> Then we have another Urelia. Then we
have a Kaisa. And then we have Urelia.
Ulia Azir Urelia Draven Rex Rex Kaisa.
>> So were you keeping track of that at
home? cuz there's going to be a quiz in
like 5 minutes. You're going to have to
recite it all from memory in order. I
want to know all of those. Uh submit
your your pie charts, your graphs on
social. I want to know the breakdown.
Somebody
>> But even if you just superficially
listen to what I said right now, you're
going to be like, "Oh, that's a lot of
different legends."
>> Yeah, that is
>> in the 70 bracket. Like really, there's
quite a lot of quite a lot of like the
spread is pretty big.
>> Not a lot of you saying Draven, Draven,
Draven, Draven, Draven, Draven, Aelia,
Aurelia, Aelia. three Fioras in the top
bracket. Like that's pretty pretty fun
because it's one of those decks that I
feel like was under the radar kind of
similar to Annie.
>> So I'm really looking forward to the
rounds tomorrow when that when we're
going to have the best players like
against the best players and then we
actually going to see proper results
between some of the matchups.
>> Yeah, cuz I think that is one thing. Um
again, we're talking about the like
highest as yet level of Riftbound. So,
I'm looking forward to getting the clash
of styles with the top top players
tomorrow as we go through our top eight.
But we got a lot to get through before
we get that. As you said, we're getting
things ready for round eight. And while
we have a couple more minutes, let's
head over head over to barcode.
>> Absolutely. And I'm with a very special
case actually here in the venue. I'm
with a guy Roman who was very tired in
the morning. I saw him. We had a little
talk together and he told me, "Oh,
I think I'm not going to do well because
I'm very tired." And now tell us a
little bit more about the tournament.
>> Well, it seems that being tired for me
is when I'm the best cuz at least now I
am 70. So, it seems that I'm in good
condition finally.
For the moment, the tournament goes well
obviously, but that I didn't expect to
be that far in the tournament. I'm
pretty surprised and I think it's mainly
because my opponent are doing mistakes
other me being strong but I'll take it.
>> Okay. I think that you are actually very
strong. This is always the good the
bright side that you have to choose but
yeah speaking about um your preparation
in general. How did you prepare for this
tournament because there was a ban list
recently so everything got just uh
shaken a little bit. How did you choose
your deck and how did you approach the
preparation in general?
>> Uh, honestly here I'm playing Aurelia
today and I was playing Aurelia since
the beginning of the set two. So even if
the banist hits her a bit with dreaming
three obviously or maybe four on power
of power as well. Uh yeah. Yeah. But to
to switch I was playing uh firstly uh
president Aurelia and I switched to an
aggroish version uh which uh is not
reliable relied to protect the queen and
I think the deck is very more uh
versatile
and with the band list it's only um it
was only a matter of uh cuz we are
losing uh drawing power with drumming
tree and Scrapip that I was playing in
the first version and we were um with a
friend of mine. We were building the the
deck list with some training and today
it seems that the new deck list work
well. I mean actually it seems to work
very well. Wish you best of luck because
there is still one round before tomorrow
but at least you are ensured that you
are going to be there tomorrow. We wish
you best of luck to be in the top eight
and seeing your smile is very good as
well considering the fact that you are
not expecting that at all. But that
being said, we are going to go back to
the desk. Back to you guys.
>> Thanks Barcode. Yes, I have had
confirmation. You can probably hear some
noise in the background as well. I've
had confirmation round seven has
completed. Pairings are getting drawn
together and that means we're very, very
close to round eight. We can't make it
go any faster is what I will say.
>> I'm very excited though to see the
undefeated decks. We're probably going
to get an undefeated deck on the future
match. So
>> that's going to be probably something
spicy.
>> I would I'm very excited to see it and
break it down because uh one we're going
to see the deck list as well, right?
>> So we're going to be happy to see what
potential techs people are doing in
their decks to have an edge over some
particular matchups. And I would love to
see another Fiora. What about you? Yeah,
I I could do with seeing some more Fiora
just because we don't really see it very
often. We haven't passed it yet today.
And I know in in previous times there
have been multiple versions of Fiora.
You had the version that kind of had
hook at the beginning of Spirit Forge
somewhat dropped off a little bit. I
think people went h actually, you know
what, Fiora is just pretty good playing
good units, just making them quick.
>> You can play, I would say, successfully
both archetypes, both the mid-range
version or the hook version. It really
depends on your own play style. I feel
like the non-hook version might be a
little bit more stable, but the problem
is that the most stable Fiora is like
has the floor and the ceiling very close
to each other, while the baited hook has
like a floor that is way lower, but a
way higher floor.
>> Allows you to go up and up.
>> You're able to pop off less
consistently, but actually sometimes you
just need a day when you're going to be
popping off in multiple games and that's
it.
>> Some people just have that luck, right?
You go into a tournament and you're like
I hit my my perfect hand like most of
the day. I I drew I'm playing hook and I
get hook every single game. And like if
you have that
>> from Bologna like uh you were casting
Bologna with Sabi who who went to second
place with the NF Aurora and he said
>> always had it.
>> Yeah. He was like I always had it. That
was like one of the best days of my
life. You know it's like he had it. He
had every time and because of that he
was winning so much. That's the heart of
the cart. You know, sometimes you'll
just have that stride where you're going
to be having always the card that you
need.
>> And then you'll also have the days when
you're playing Aurora or Hook and it'll
be at the bottom of the deck every
single time and you'll never draw it and
you'll be like, "Well, I went."
>> But no one is talking about that, so we
don't hear about it. Yeah.
>> Exactly. No one No one tweets about
their failures. That's That's the other
thing. So
>> you remember when someone pulls out a
Baron Nasher, you know, and then someone
else pulls a Baron Nasher and someone
else pulls a Baron Nasher. No one else
is making posts about not pulling a
Baron Nasher. Yeah, I would quite like
to pull a Baron Asher. An ultimate
Baroner. Uh Rift,
>> I will post about it if I will get one.
>> Riot UBS, you know. Yeah, I would love
to pull that. If you can if you can sway
that in my favor somehow, it's not going
to happen. Those those that that's not
possible. It's a little randomized
>> odds of actually opening. Uh probably
very very slim odds and uh very slim
odds for our players that are not
finding themselves so far uh at least
with five wins cuz of course you need to
get six to make it onward. So let's take
a look at the standings. See who is at
that tipping point of going through to
the next day for day two. Only three.
Oh, we're going in reverse ordered.
>> We're we're revealing this in reverse
order. So we get we get a little bit of
suspense as we go through. So, uh,
obviously this list of players are are
in a position where they have already
qualified for day two. That's the
important thing. A six in the front
column means you're good. You can, uh,
you can be in a good standing
regardless. But some some big names in
there. We saw Vins earlier on the
featured matchup there as uh,
>> there's a lot of players. Uh, Luis
Fishpot 6 and one has ended up dropping
one game, but still finds themselves in
Dayton that bottom there. Six and one.
>> There is a six and one. Yes. So, there's
a Darius in there as well.
>> Lovely to see the Darius. Two Azros over
here. Uh, two Dravens.
>> So, Mastery. Yeah.
>> Yeah. There's actually there's four
Aurelia on this page.
>> That's cuz I think we're going to swap
over and see a few more Aurelas. Yeah.
On the next page, there's a few more,
>> but that's still like that's not that
many top 32 after seven rounds because
it is the most popular deck.
>> Yes, it is.
>> Right. So, you expect them to be
converting anyway like just because of
statistics. Yeah, that's very true.
>> Look at this. Squirtle is in place one
uh with the Azir
>> evolving as we speak. Uh waiting to
>> but it's more like a sand turtle right
now, you know.
>> Yeah, I see what you're doing there. I I
see it. I see it.
>> Exasio playing with the Rexai. Ah, maybe
we'll get him on stream. Who knows?
>> Uh spoilers maybe. I guess is you
actually don't know. Okay. I thought
this was one of these ones where you're
like I do you know and you actually
know.
>> Maybe I do and I'm lying right now.
Maybe you wouldn't lie to me, would you?
Uh,
>> no, never.
>> Here's the uh day one metag game of uh,
as said earlier, Urelia, the most played
deck of the day. Interested to see what
the conversion rate is into day two.
Draven follows up with Kaiser as well.
There's a bit of a a shelf there with
Victor Masti, Rexi, which I think if you
if you pulled people at their nexus
knights, I don't know that Victor Masti
and and Rexi would be the next three
decks under that that people would say I
like the most play. Maybe Victor. I
think Victor's had popularity for a
while, but uh
>> Victor has a lot of um people who love
the character and a lot of haters as
well. It's like love it or hate it
essentially. And because of that, I feel
like it's popular. It always was
popular. Even in set one when the deck
was not doing that great and it was not
really favored into like the most
popular deck, which is Kai'Sa,
>> people loved playing him
>> because it's just an arcane character. I
feel like there also people just
connecting with the idea of creating
tokens and so on. Yeah.
>> So, the identity behind the character is
pretty cool.
>> And some people pulled the art.
>> Look at that. We have on Azir. So, I'm
assuming that's Squirtle.
>> Is that was that someone else?
>> Uh, we'll we'll find out as we as we go
through.
>> And we have Exasio on Rexi.
Awesome. That is I'll be honest. I think
this is the first time we see this
matchup ever on screen
>> at regional
>> that we've casted. Let's put that caveat
and that way we're we're right
regardless because we have
>> someone will fact check me and say
maybe not
>> who needs the truth build our own truth.
>> No one will check that.
>> Yeah, exactly. So we had some Azia on
screen earlier uh today. So obviously
that works across uh the what we call it
is cascading equipment in in line with
utilizing a lot of tokens. You send one
token in with a with an equipment on and
then it it ends up trading and then you
put another one on. Really efficient use
of the additional buffs from things like
brutalizer that when you equip it, you
get the extra bonus.
>> Yeah. And then we have a Rexai which
seems to be the red hybrid version. So
very similar to the one that we have
seen already on um on the show match.
But the thing is there are three blood
rushers over here in main and also void
hatchlings which is not something that
you always see. Many people prefer
Poutiporo in the current uh environment
because they do die less to Kaisa for
example.
>> And interestingly a difference to what
we saw with Marshall in round two of the
day. Um this is Darius instead of Ferris
4runner where the the version we watched
earlier today was only really recycling
for 4Runner. This deck at least in the
main board just saying we don't need
forrunner now. I I wouldn't be surprised
to see one maybe in the side.
>> I guess maybe like two or even three
there because you essentially would side
it in against everyone who's not purple.
>> Yeah, I imagine so. As you said, Rebuke
in in that dynamic is is so important.
So, we'll see that as we go from game
one to game two. But uh for the main
board, we are expecting that's like
aggressive like when you put a a Darius
in there as well. That maybe shortcuts
past the needing Rex eye for accelerate
in that moment cuz you just play Darius
and then follow it up with something
else.
>> Yeah. And you also the access to free
blood rushes allows you to be when
you're going when you're going second,
you have access to a a fill card
essentially because when you're at odd
number of runes in Rexai, you don't
really have the typical way of using
that one because almost everything costs
two. you will have most spells costing
two. You will have most units costing
two, but then suddenly you have that one
odd uh rune that is just floating there
to be
>> so you can threaten with something
>> and that blood rush is perfect for that
because not only it allows you to be um
you know repeated when you need it to be
so then it goes into
sorry even number and it you have more
impact to it, right? But the plus two
will change a lot of the potential
concurs which then will trigger void
borrowing. So that's why in the Rexite
deck, you probably also play power not
power, the um the daring porus which
have built-in assault because it's so
important to over your opponent as early
as possible to trigger the voider to
potentially start your cardro engine
right in Rexite. That's why assault is
one of those key mechanics that you're
going to see in the Rexai builds. And as
I explained in the first hours of this
broadcast 9 hours ago,
>> a long time ago now. Yeah, there are
three different archetypes typically
over Rexi, but in this particular one,
blood rushes are very important because
you're going to go wide. So, blood
rushes are going to be having the most
impact potentially because you can
change um the outcomes on both
battlefields by using just one card,
right? Because you can split the
directions like two tokens. One gets
free might attacks into the battlefield
A. The other token gets plus two with
the assault and attacks the battlefield
B. And now you're able to impact both of
the battlefields at the same time. Wow,
>> this is a very neat addition to the
Rexai and it's I feel like Rexi and
Darius are utilizing those strategies
the best because of the yellow inclusion
in their archetype which creates the
tokens.
>> That is uh an in-depth look into uh
blood rush there. If you followed Lothar
down that Rexside tunnel, uh
congratulations. You probably good
enough to be like the tunnel.
>> Hey, I came I come with some jokes.
Sometimes it works. I'll tell you that
much. Uh right, this is not something to
joke about though. Both of these players
are locked for day two, of course, but
really important to know your score
carries over in the sense of like we are
looking for highest placement for the
top eight. You're acrewing the maximum
mana points. So looking to be 8 and0 at
the end of the day.
>> I know it's super far away from the top
eight, but it also matters in the top
eight because the highest seed in the
top eight will choose am I going first
or second in the match.
>> In most cases, that's going to be like
I'm going first. If if someone goes
first and after Swiss, he's most likely
going first
>> the entire tournament. Exactly. All the
way through to the finals should you
make it. Uh so it is really important.
So here we go. Azir comes out with the
first uh sand soldier from Desert's Call
already. Now we get to see how much of
this go wide strategy comes from the
Rexai. Both of these decks very similar
in that way though. These board states
might get out of control.
>> Yeah, pretty fast as well. And also
playing the Rexi is a heads up play
because it allows you to go into a
battlefield with four might which might
be something that Azir will not try
>> to like battle right. So for example we
know that most Azir are going to play
disciplines and they're going to play
unguard for example right but unguard is
like a secondary choice. Uh in this case
here, you gonna we're gonna leave one of
the sense soldiers to die, which will
trigger then the conqueror from Verer,
right? But the problem is with this that
you will lose your potential accelerated
unit that you typically also wants to to
have to like finish the game, right?
Okay.
>> But if you play a two drop instead of
the Rexai, then you cannot kill the sand
soldier. So you have to go to the auto
battlefield and you give your opponent a
point. Right. So, this is the decision
that here um is was making because he
had a two drop if I'm not mistaken on
turn one. Now, he's playing the void
first
>> first and foremost because of the fact
that void hashing actually has an effect
which will give him an other option to
look at the card, but also you typically
would like to play a two drop before you
activate the void barer to potentially
have
>> to potentially have a Nox was helpful
from the top. But now, this is crazy. I
did uh Excio recycle from the void
hatching because he he looked at it. I
didn't see whether it went top or
bottom, but
>> I'm not certain, but I think he did. And
>> if it went bottom, that means the that
means the uh the under Titan gets
revealed from that one extra. I I wasn't
paying attention because I I wasn't
quite thinking down that rabbit hole on
that. But yeah. Oh wow. That that two
extra uh energy is going to light this
game on fire with the ability to just
play out a bunch of of units in the
board and then be in a great spot. We
said like units will come really quickly
in this matchup.
>> That is a crazy opener. It doesn't
happen often, but when it happens, then
the Rex feels like unbeatable almost,
you know.
>> Yeah. One thing is Zia does struggle a
little bit with is actually dealing with
multiple units at once.
>> Call the weak is essentially like, oh,
I'm not going to play this card in this
matchup almost at all. Like kill the
one.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> So, uh, and it's going to get stuck in
the hand for for some time. Maybe there
will be a moment in the game where you
can play it, but it's going to be hard
to find that moment. But what's even
more important is that I don't know if
it's going to matter actually in this
matchup, but it can potentially come up.
The Hall of Legends that is the
battlefield chosen by Azir player can
actually benefit the Rexai as well
because you can first conquer Hall of
Legends tap for your void burer, put it
on the chain, and then do the uh Hell of
Legends, untap your void burer, you get
it a second time. You get it like a
second time. The problem with this is
that that potentially cost you more even
more energy, right? Because with each
cast of Void Burer, you are looking to
play a card from the top of the deck
anyway, right? So,
>> um but it is something that can come up
>> worth considering for sure. Like there
there is that that um aspect that may
very well uh come to fruition. Now we're
in that situation as you said, you're
trading your Rexai away, but it was to
get that early tempo, deny the uh the
point early on.
So now we have Azir with a
again. Can we put the brutalizer on the
bottom and the shield please? So we so
we can see the night now.
>> Yeah, that was something we were talking
about. Now now you can just it covered
up completely. We don't get to see
anything.
>> You just put a blanket.
>> Got to got to keep those warm in the
night in the desert. Exactly. I will say
just a little bit of housekeeping not
not for here but if you're playing at
Nexus Night O
there we go. Thank you. I think the
judges stepped in and said, "No, we we
actually probably should see that game
information uh to to be played out
here." It is a courtesy to your opponent
to to at least represent the public
information in the game in a way that is
accurate.
>> So, this unit has four might in this
case. Brutalizer only gives plus two
when it's being equipped during this
turn, right? So,
>> yes.
>> Um, was that three energy open for the
Azir or two? I'm actually not certain.
But the hand of this is one is the
biggest skill when it comes to playing
Rex eye. You have to make a decision
what kind of cards do I have on the top
of the deck and are those cards actually
potentially impactful in this position
>> of the board like of the board state
right? So is it worth if I attack first
with the token to the Tfaren to activate
void mirror get an opt additional
option?
>> Yeah. What am I likely to see? What what
are those two cards going to be? because
when they're revealed, I've got to use
it or lose it at that point. Um, so
>> so you need to know your deck in and out
completely to understand what are the
odds and what are you looking for and
how does it impact with the context of
the board state.
>> Yeah. And that's the sequencing down to
your own rune availability as well,
right? Because if you're tapped out or
if you're low on economy and and you've
not tracked that all of your cheap stuff
has come out already and you're more
likely to hit expensive units, expensive
spells, that kind of thing, that's where
you can really mess it up in the the end
of a turn and say, "Oh, now that has to
go to the bottom of the deck."
>> Yeah. Let's let's um say the blood rush
will come up, right?
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> So, you can attack with the token to the
Trafarian. you show the top two from the
top of the deck and there's a blood rush
and suddenly now you have an option to
change your mind about attacking the
other battlefield.
>> It's going to be hopeful into the
battlefield to absorb
>> it's gods.
>> Yeah, that is uh the beginning and is
going to be able to activate. I believe
that was a brutalizer that swapped
>> and this brutalizer now gives plus two
for this entire turn. So this particular
sand soldier is now five might. Yeah,
that of course comes from the uh weapon
master part of Azir plus there. There is
blood rush. We talked about it quite a
lot.
>> Whip the repeat. So it goes up to eight
and that is seven if I'm not is it seven
three and no it's 8 to eight. So it's
exactly the same if I'm not mistaken.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. 2 3 4 5. Yeah, I think that is
correct as uh
we will follow the math. Everyone's like
yeah let's just get rid of everything.
It's trade it all away. Uh at least now
you can conquer on the back end of that
with with the likes of a recruit or
whichever you should do as you said with
the trifarian war camp will now give you
>> the activation if you wanted it. Void
hatchling is going
>> if it was tapped but that was just a
clerical mistake at the beginning of the
turn. Okay. What did wasn't in the
awaken phase.
So see this if this was the case like
maybe it was worth attacking first to
the Trafarian to see maybe that's
something that actually changes my mind
but the deck that's something that I
learned very quickly when it comes to
anticipating what a player can do in
this game in riftbound it's not easy
players can have different mindset they
can have different play style they can
also have completely some something in
their mind that they want to execute
that you're not going to be able to read
just from the board state because maybe
something in the deck is actually
affecting the decision decision making
maybe something in the hand that we
don't see is affecting the decision
making. What we can do here is just try
to understand what the player is trying
to achieve.
>> Yeah, that's always one thing about
casting uh games of riftbound and and
watching them and and being a third
party observer is you have such
different information on the game to the
players and we may follow a line and the
player isn't even considering it because
they have one thing in mind that they
are trying to avoid. Um and sometimes
that that obviously play pay play pays
dividends in time. So just remember
players being in the featured match
being 7 and0 at the same time. Not that
there has been any mistake so far, but
it is all pressure that builds and
builds and builds at this moment of
playing uh for the undefeated streak of
8 and0 so far.
>> Yeah, I mean being seven and zero in
such a big tournament is already a feat
I would say.
>> Yeah, massive massive the beginnings of
building a real full career out of this.
We're only on the second event, but
these are the names that we'll be keep
here. is still far away.
>> But what I'm saying is, you know,
performance like that is the beginning
of etching your name into
>> I can argue with competitive
specifically if you can also
>> um turn into a two day two performance
as well, right?
>> Yeah, exactly. That that's
>> but this start is very very good for
you. Like 70 is incredible.
>> I like building stories. I like a little
bit of hyperbole, a little little bit of
exaggeration for people.
>> You know what's funny is that this
repairing war camp is actually
beneficial for both of those archetypes.
>> Yeah, it really is. is you're going wide
on the on both of these decks. So,
Trafarian War camp is pretty pretty
handy there. It also means that it does
nothing for both of them if the units
are even
>> well. One one of the sides will still
have more units. In this case, we have
the Rexai with plus four while the Azir
is with plus one. He equipped this
brutalizer if I'm not mistaken. So,
that's
six might all six might altogether.
>> Yeah,
>> there's a hidden blade if I'm not
mistaken on the Trafarian. Um, but it's
not being activated for now. Remember
also one more thing, Rexai kind of wants
to conquer every single turn. They don't
aim at holding the battlefields unless
they are certain they can just conquer
the other one in the upcoming turn
because you want to activate that void
burer as often as possible.
>> And what if is even important? You want
to activate the void burer even when you
don't have like energy open because it
gives you informations. Okay, it also
gives information to the opponent, but
you will know your deck better, so you
will be able to make better decisions
based on the information.
>> That that's an interesting concept
because as we were talking about
earlier, it depends kind of what's left
in in your deck. But yeah, I can
definitely understand that. I can
understand that point of view. Uh BF
sword coming through this time, weapon
master attached, and that'll be another
conquer for Azir. really low on economy
and they're all uh order runes as well.
So that means brutalizer won't be able
to be re-equipped on a further turn.
>> But if I'm not mistaken, he's guaranteed
one green in the upcoming turn. I I um I
think I might be a little bit off, but I
think he should be getting at least one
green.
>> You know who should know? RZA player bed
or Squirtle should you know that would
be in your mind if you've been you know
>> doing reps on this deck until this point
>> should have that fully in mind as you
are recycling and that's one thing that
going from a a novice player to a a pro
or you know expert player is one of the
things you got to keep in mind. We have
two battering rams in the in this hand.
So basically every single time you play
it to drop, you get minus two energy in
the cost of those two cards, but you
need to squeeze enough cards to actually
make a difference for them both to be
played.
>> Play them both.
>> Essentially, that's what you're trying
to achieve at the same turn. So another
activation of void. We're looking here
for some cheap cards.
>> Ooh,
all the cards.
>> Actually, actually, uh, it's probably
still
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> But I would say it still could be a
consideration. So this is now the second
spell of the turn.
>> Correct. And now he's going to be
>> the chain can matter. Yeah, I was going
to say does it matter
>> because you have minus two already on
the cost. So this is going to be minus
three on the ram cost after playing this
void drop. Then you get another two
drop.
>> Oh, you get the chain back to back to
back.
>> Oh, the reveals are satisfying.
>> All right, so he gets two plus energy.
He remember this is void rush. One of
those cards is going to be drawn. The
other one can be played. So here will
have overall five energy. The Darius
will not go ready because three cards
were already being played. It won't be
the second card of the turn. Correct.
That is uh that's some value
>> and he's the cost is correct. He needed
to pay one energy
>> for him and still should have
>> one more if I'm not mistaken. math works
out double bannering ram. Oh, that is
disgusting.
>> It that under Titan hit there was a big
change. Essentially, it allows to play
those two battering rams on top of the
Darius. Otherwise, the Darius will be in
hand, but this is a vile play. Like
disgusting.
Well, that'll tilt the favor back in one
way if we had a uh you know who's in the
lead bar on the the pace the game. It
obviously doesn't affect it in that
exact turn, but the the awaken phase
suddenly Rexi looks really scary.
>> Yeah. Now you have potentially 15 17 19
might.
>> That's a lot some we of course the Darus
untap, right? So
>> yeah,
>> he's down to four runes.
But that's okay. Goes up to six.
>> That was going to be my question is is
the economy damaged from that? Do you
care when you have this much might on
the board?
>> What was the most expensive card in the
deck?
>> Yeah, Darius. And it's there now.
>> And that's the second Darus because one
is already at the bottom of the deck if
I remember correctly.
>> I believe you're correct. Yeah.
>> You're going to have every single card
now cost you like essentially two or
one, maybe three if it's a captain, but
I think believe two captains were
already being played. So that
essentially leaves it to one copy. So
most of your cards is going to cost you
two.
Oh, that still feels like that is wrong.
>> But what I wanted to say though, Azir is
at six points.
>> Yes.
>> So there is potential like you know you
cannot leave now the battlefields. Um as
Rex said that's not ideal scenario
because you want to leave the
battlefields to rec. But the problem is
now when your opponent is at six and
still has access to the Azir Sovereign
in his champion unit. Here we go.
>> Yeah. you're going to be able to move
your units more efficiently to close out
the game. So, he's setting it up.
>> Are we setting up a rise turn
potentially for the next turn and then
you sweep in with Azir and and do the
old Shereima shuffle to win as uh yeah,
as you said, a lot of this Rexite deck
does want to be attacking. A lot of the
a lot of the spells as well when you
look at like blood rush and that they're
all, you know, helped out when you're
the aggressor, that type of thing. Like
there's there's a lot of uh stuff that
doesn't help hold outside of just the
might printed on the card.
>> Yeah. And the the problem is that as you
said, Rex is not the best at holding,
>> but if you have like cards of blood
rush, they don't really literally
>> Exactly. Exactly that. They they don't
help. Maybe you're casting it just to
get the plus two when you cast a second
spell on Darius. And we're really
delving into the depths of like how do
you get squeak out another might?
>> It it might have looked like a crazy
turn.
>> It did. It looked great.
>> Yeah. But it is not great if there's an
arise being held in the hand for Pedro.
>> Yeah.
>> Rex is borrowing. You can see the table
shaking underneath.
Something's something's going on.
>> Something is in the sand.
>> Yeah. Ah. Ooh. Thematic. Ah. The
shifting sands.
>> Did you watch Tremors?
>> Uh, maybe a long long long time ago.
>> This is like the perfect combination.
It's sands and and worms. And
>> it's like Dune at this point
potentially. Maybe.
>> Shout out to Kevin Bacon. Um, but if you
didn't watch Tambos,
>> although now that we're talking about
Dune, I'm like, Kevin Bacon was not in
Dune. That would be a very
>> How do you know? Maybe he was.
>> Oh, maybe. Yeah, maybe he's an extra.
This is far too serious a game to be
going down that hole on as both players
are 7 and0. Uh, this is game one of this
best of three trying to secure an
undefeated streak through day one.
Battering ram will go towards uh the
Trafarian war camp. Will
>> that wasite quite actually interesting
>> combat? Yeah, because there was one
open. If there was an unguard, they
could have actually go the other way
around because it would have been plus
two. Well, actually, no, never mind. It
was uh it was a three might unit, so it
would just be that trade.
>> Yeah. And and then of course we have
Rexite potentially representing things
like blood rush and and a few other
things. So there there's some some extra
questions to that. I would say probably
not the best two units you're seeing off
the top at this point. I they kind of
help but maybe not. Uh like
>> I'm not certain what's in his hand
because at this point it's like you have
to pay probably you will have to play
the captain.
>> So one card we know is an under titan in
hand because it got revealed from the
earlier. Um I think the color week
earlier went to the bottom. I because I
think that was revealed via the the Rex
side.
>> But the first if that was in this in the
void rush then
>> something else was in the first void
rush and I can't remember what it was. I
was too I was far too hyped about the
first void rush to remember what the
other card was.
>> I think there's a cold week in the hand
>> but I'm not certain.
>> Yeah, I can't remember whether that was
uh from the the the the legend ability
or from the void rush.
>> Are we paying for hall of legends?
Probably not. Are we? He's thinking
about it, I think.
There's one blood rush in the hand which
is basically useless for this particular
turn.
>> Yeah. As in for the for the following
turn. Yeah. Everything that you would
use that on is gone. Now Pedro is going
to look through the graveyard which is
in like important. The other thing is
it's somewhat important
>> counting the blood rushes. He's counting
the interactions over here. It
>> it's also important to remember what was
revealed and recycled earlier in the
game. Uh it's hard to do like it's so so
hard to remember. One of the matchups
when you're kind if you're not
accustomed to do the matchup, you're
you're not used to the fact that you
have to pay attention to what your
opponent is doing that much with his
deck to put the information.
>> Yeah, exactly. Cuz it's as good as
knowing it's in the trash for a while.
You only have to remember it later in
the game, but uh knowing that it's not
an option is really important. And here
we said Rexi can take battlefields
really effectively. Not so good at
holding and with only one rune
available. We know there's only really
one piece of interaction that's going to
going to ready Darius, go back to safety
just in case it is necessary next turn.
Is this a massive Arise turn? And even
if it is, is it enough to get through
this Trafarian War camp where all of the
troops are stationed for our Rexi? Well,
we have one, two, three equipments. So,
Arise will spawn four creatures. That is
how many units we have on Trfaren right
now. 1 2 3 4 5 six right.
>> Yeah, Darius is not there.
>> 23 might on the Trafan War camp for
Rexai.
>> So it then comes down to the math on the
equipment plus the Azir.
>> That's not That's also the second way of
playing out the round for Azir where you
will juggle the same piece of equipment.
>> Yeah. Not go in at once. So, you're
actually going to cascade as as many
people call it and you can go, okay,
I'll go one brutalizer in, one
brutalizer in. Uh, it looks like we may
be having a judge at least question or
call uh at this point in time as uh both
players of course
>> have like a listen in right now. I know
the question, huh?
>> Yeah, it would be good to know as it
looks like. So, uh to explain to to
newer players what is happening here at
the table. This is something that that I
think veteran players will understand
but but newer players may not. Um, when
you are playing in a competitive
environment with a judge, you are
allowed to ask a judge a rules question
specifically about the rules, not about
the game state, but about the rules away
from the table so that you don't give
your opponent information. So, for
instance, if I was going to ask you a
very basic question, it could be away
from the table of
>> can I equip brutalizer to a unit
multiple times in a turn and each unit
will get plus two? That's a generally
fair question. That's a very easy one
that a judge would be like, "Yeah,
you'll get plus two every time you equip
brute."
>> Well, that question was definitely
incomplete.
>> Yeah, it was. But I was giving you an
example because I was thinking went off
the top of my head. Uh, obviously at
this level, a lot of them are very
complex. Um, but
>> I do wonder what is he asking about.
>> Same.
What is very interesting about Aziz is
that because of how the entire archetype
works, all most of the decks have the
same fundamentals like cards that are
always implemented because you are
required to have the equipment. So all
of almost all of the Azir decks are
essentially almost the same at this
stage of our game. We're going to have
more cards with more expansions being
added. But I'm just like thinking like
nothing comes to my mind that was
actually ah the guardian angel. Maybe
some interaction over here. Is it
potentially about guardian angeling a a
recruit
>> being recalled and then it can be like
brought back to the battlefield with the
Azir?
>> It should survive, right? Like that that
that's fine because
>> it's going to have still the equipment
attached to it.
>> Yes. Yeah, that is that is I I'm pretty
sure what happens with with guardian
angel. We've seen on other things.
Normally not with tokens, but I I'm
pretty sure that the token doesn't leave
the battlefield. So it it just comes
back to the base. So,
>> so now we have potentially, if I'm not
mistaken, this unit has 4, 5, 8, nine
might.
>> It's hidden underneath.
>> Yeah, it should be nine. If this
brutalizer was equipped, it's nine.
Okay. So, it goes to halls of legends.
And now it's going to be brought into
the
>> with the Azia when it moves. Oh, okay.
>> And now we can re-equip the yellow
equipment.
Uh oh. No, no, no. Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. It goes back to base.
It doesn't re-equip anything because the
it's still alive, right? But it adds the
full might. So it added the nine.
>> Right. Right. And you're you're trading
the guardian angel for the full might of
the stack of equipment on the sand
soldier. Now we're going to bring it in.
This is a lot of might coming into the
battlefield. And uh we're going to do
the math as we go. This is important to
count it. Although Excios is going to
say, "Yeah, that's a lot of might." It's
25 to 23. That is going to be game one
going over to Azia.
This is where you can see how impactful
death grip can be in decks that can use
equipment and essentially double the
amount of might that you're getting out
of one equipment, right? For example,
Fiora and Azir are great examples of
that to some degree set as well. Like
set brawler can like for example buff
his own um you know buff his own might
with just burning the buff and then
death grip gets plus eight on something
else, right? Yeah.
Nicely played nice of a guardian angel
and then reus
of might and the same amount of utility
on the uh equipment attached to go to
the other battlefield and finish up the
game. Really nice sequencing.
>> Really good sequencing doubling up. And
that's what we're talking about players
having specific line in mind. And of
course wanting to clarify exactly that.
I imagine it was that death grip
interaction just to confirm
>> with the guardian angel.
>> Exactly. And again, maybe my example was
bad, but as long as you're only asking a
judge a rule question and not a game
state question, typically you will be uh
given the correct answer about a rule
specifically. Uh we talked earlier about
would Estasio have Ferris 4Runner in the
sideboard. And he does. The answer is
yes. That is not a surprise. I feel
pretty good. Hey to everybody in the
crowd. Thanks for joining us. Uh to
those of you that unfortunately did not
make it through day one, commiserations.
Hope you are enjoying the event as it
is. Those of you that are still in,
hopefully give a cheer. I guess you're
actually playing if you're still in.
That's actually kind of silly.
>> People waving. Let's wave back. Are we
on camera? We're here. That's lovely to
see you all. Thank you for joining us.
Uh if you haven't been able to make it
to either Bolognia or Le. Uh first of
all, we wish you here. We wish you were
joining us. Uh Utre is coming up soon
and then more events throughout the rest
of the year. We we showed you at the
beginning of the stream. So, after we're
done, if you want to find out what uh
where else you can find Riftbound close
to you, uh either use, you know, search
for it, Riftband events, or go back to
the beginning of the stream, we talked
about it to begin the day on what's
coming up.
>> And if you want to know, the viewing
area here in the arena is very nice.
It's a big like LCD screen that is
actually I don't know how big, but it's
way bigger than what we have behind us.
It's a really nice setup. There's a lot
of people enjoying viewing it in the
arena
>> and you get to dip in of doing side
events and you know if you you you want
to do as many of the different events
throughout the weekend as possible. Uh
I'll be in Utre. Um luckily I've been uh
selected as one of the creators going.
So I'll be there playing side events,
not playing the main event. Um I I don't
want that smoke. That that's not not for
me.
>> I will be either competing or maybe
casting.
>> I fingers crossed on either way for you
for making day two. you, as I said to
this corner of you, you're making day
two.
>> When you're casting, I'm making day two.
>> Exactly. So far, uh, you know, I from
Bolognia, I'm like, I made finals.
I feel good. I It's me, Alan. You know,
it's all good. And, uh, yeah, we'll see
who makes finals in
>> this. Oh, that is a
>> I was going to say that's the Void Ber
going at it again. Void Rush. We'll see
if we can get the back to back to back
again. And so this is a pretty quick
start. We have Arena's greatest trigger
for both players. We also have seat of
power again in the game. It's it's
working for both of those archetypes,
right? You are playing a white deck, so
seat of power makes sense. You have
potentially a free card draw, which is
something that Azir wants more
>> than Rex.
>> The struggle is real on Azir sometimes.
>> Yeah, exactly. Oh, the struggle is real
with this hand though as well. Oh, it is
always painful to have to pay full
price. No discount option available for
the Noxis Hope.
>> And there was no two drop as well.
>> Exactly. This is a real struggle.
>> This is rough. This is rough,
>> especially on Arena's greatest where
you're like, I really want to get out of
the gates quick and I want to, you know,
conquer as quick as possible. My
opponent is actually just going to play
Azir saying, "Okay, I don't see any
threat from you yet."
>> It's only fair. You got two under Titans
in game one. Now you're getting you're
paying for this with uh with the sub
bar.
>> Oh, and the on guard is going to match
it and just say, "Yeah, I'll take that
trade." And we'll see whether Excio has
a blood rush or something.
>> I see a salvage in hand. I think was
there a face breaker there as well? Not
100% sure. Uh I I know that. No, it is
not. I'm uh I'm hallucinating uh cards
in hands.
>> Most like we're going to just see a
developing here a Ferris 4 and a six
energy and one red. What can it be? I
know, right? But it also on its own,
>> sure, it's going to be good, but that's
>> Arises.
>> Yeah. Multiple Arise BF sword is gonna,
you know, be good for this turn and then
even better on the Arise turn.
>> Mhm.
>> Because it's going to give you that
extra uh presence for the Arise Soldier.
So, BF sword goes onto sand soldier. Of
course, that is coming from the legend
ability that Azia is able to make once
he played that equipment.
This is a It's kind of funny because we
have the arena's greatest, but both
players were had definitely not ideal
hands open the game. So, the game kind
of slowed down by default.
>> But the thing is now there's potential
swings and they can go both ways. The
>> the salvage in hand is an action speed
spell. So, it can flip one. Oh, never
mind. It's already being played. And the
fight. And here we go. Now this does
make a huge difference because one you
know that one defy is already gone
>> and two one of the servers already say
both
>> both players get information that is
very crucial. But what is even more
important, Exasio here has to think
about the fact that if I put the Ferris
Forana on one of those battlefields, it
will most likely die,
>> right? Any equipment is going to
basically make that sand soldier enough
to um uh uh uh to trade, right? And now
rely the troops, rally the troops was
being played, which draws you a card.
And then
if any unit if you play any unit this
turn they get instantly buffed.
>> Okay.
>> So you want to play as many units as
possible. Ideally it would be the yellow
two drop that creates two tokens that
will create seven might on the in the
base instantly or on the battlefield
>> depending what you want to do. So
>> seeing not wanting either the void rush
or the unit there from it. Obviously as
you said you want the one that is going
to create multiple units. There it is.
Here we go. That's the ideal scenario
for the rally the troops.
>> Yeah. So, now they get buffed up. It's
uh pretty pretty useful at this point
for rebuilding into this game or at
least building in. I I guess we should
say that as Rexai hasn't yet established
uh control of the game.
>> It's build your own sand soldiers.
>> It is. Yeah, they they're actually the
same. They're like
>> same same but different.
>> Yeah.
>> You know what I mean? the Spider-Man
meme at this point. Like
>> that was from um that was from the
comedy with um
>> Oh my god. Who who who created the
studio on Apple TV? Did you watch the
series?
>> Uh I did.
>> Never mind. All right, we're going too
deep again. But all right, so we get the
trade or not trade even just defeating
the the ferris forrunner. Two mechs are
being created to the base and it's still
awkward. You still have a lot of might,
but dealing with the first FA without
losing anything, that is probably as
impactful as it can be.
>> Oh, there's a rise coming through.
>> That's a big tell, by the way. If this
turn you play a rise like this, that
means that you do have a second one.
>> You got another one cuz
>> there's no reason to play it yet. Not
right now. Right. So, it's like you are
trying to establish like a turn. You
probably had something else to play in
from this hand, but if you play just
>> just slam it like this. Yeah,
>> this is most
>> just trying to smother out the game at
this point of say I'm just going to
create two of giant like uh units. I
will say though with only two equipment
on the board and one of them being
brutalizer. We're in another situation
where it's like holding is not the
easiest with this this ward state for
either player because like brutalizer
once you pass the turn is going to drop
off or at least the the active added
bonus of being equipped that turn. So
yeah, it's some interesting math is
about to come through on Estasio's turn
because you have to deal with both
battlefields which means the Arise ends
up not doing all that much. No, when you
think about it, he paid six energy and
one rune for the power. Yeah.
>> To draw a card from the seat of power,
right? Yeah. And create one unit.
>> Yeah.
>> Because the other one will die.
>> Yeah. Cuz you'll end up trading around
and
>> not even trading. It's just the mech is
going to go over like basically the
board state dictates that the sand
soldier dies without doing anything.
>> Yeah, that's fair. So the player plays
deliberately the arise to change it to
one cent soldier and a draw a card. That
is 100% atel that you have a second rise
in the hand.
>> Yeah, that's fair. And uh going to look
through look for is there a blood rush
in there? I don't believe so is uh
haven't seen it this
game at this point. We are right down to
the the corn the key moments of a series
like this. So taking the time to check
through the trash. which hasn't been all
that much for now. And we do have 28
minutes left still on this round. So,
uh, good to do your due diligence while
there is time still to do it
>> at this point.
Not the end of the world, but that will
be the trade coming through or at least
the, uh, the conquer coming through for
Estasio on the arena's greatest
will. Now,
>> I'm thinking about triggering it because
there's a small difference if you would
trigger it from the second battlefield.
>> Okay.
>> Because you would draw a card first. Ah
two more.
>> Yeah. And that not even that depending
like if you draw the card first and then
you trigger void burer then you would
affect the decision. It would affect the
decision potentially what you can play
from the void burer because you you get
one top card and then you see one more.
>> So it gets you more informations. You
you will have a more informed decision.
But at the same time if you does this
blood rush like change anything over
here? Most likely not. Like it would
only change the fact that I want to push
with the token instead of the mech,
right? And that's essentially it.
>> Whereas now you get a mystery card
>> and we still have five energy open. And
it's so hopeful.
>> Yeah, it's so interesting because
essentially Rexai works like this. I
sacrifice my units that are worth
nothing and I get more units and I just
>> play cards. I almost have no interaction
during the opponent's turn. at least by
default in game two and three that
changes. But the Azir plays a similar
strategy. His units are also
mass-produced,
>> but they are worth more
>> but they're being supplemented by the
cards from uh uh from the equipment or
they're supplemented by instant speed
either buffs or
like counter spells like defy and maybe
wind wall in some decks. It's such an
interesting archetypes because they they
kind of are similar
>> similar in different ways. Yeah,
exactly. Uh, I was getting excited for a
moment there cuz I thought that Valing
was quite cheap, but it actually cost
three. Every time I see one, I'm like,
"Oh yeah, you're going to play lots of
things. You you got to reduce by two
cost."
>> I remember people played them and
they've played like they have no minimum
cost
>> and you know what? I actually thought
that for the beginning for about a week
I was like, "Oh, just play it for free."
No,
>> that that would be absolutely mental.
Yeah, there was a point as well where I
thought uh Fizz could be played at
reaction speed based on based on some
historical knowledge of cards in the
past. I was like, "No, it's it's not
that. It's not that at all." Uh I went
to do it in a game and my friend was
like, "No, don't do that." And what
we're going to do now though is focus on
this one as Azia goes in. We'll bring
with the Shereima shuffle over the sand
soldier to
Cedar Power. Now we have desert call
calls in two sand soldiers. Now the hold
is pretty big on that seat of power that
is 10 might but on the b on the base in
the base sorry we have already f 5 9 11
14 16 might waiting in base two open
energy for Azir signals maximum plus for
might because that will be double and
goard. Uh, but we already saw one
Enguard being used, so we know it can
only be one Enguard because there only
two in the deck.
>> The other thing it could be, right, is
hidden blade if you're looking to take
out a unit, right? Like the old
fashioned way of from hand.
>> You just stab it actually, you know,
>> that blade is
>> it's not that it's not that hidden.
>> No, exactly. But not in the game frontal
blade.
>> Yeah, that's that's with bravado that
you're you're stabbing them at that
point. But at this point,
>> you know what? You know what's funny?
The hidden blade when it's actually
hidden, it's not hidden.
>> It's not hidden. That's the point I'm
saying it's actually hidden
>> cuz in the deck you're like ah I know
what that is but two mana represented is
oh sorry two uh two two runes
represented is is way more of of a of a
hiding strategy. There's a there's a
void rush in uh in hand forio. It won't
be the the card of choice for this turn.
It's going to be the Darius. Could very
well be followed up with a void rush.
>> Mhm. Now he's playing it first because
if he chooses to play a card from voider
>> Yeah. Then it's important to have a like
if could be another void rush and then
the void rush will play two cards and
then dy cannot untap. Yeah,
>> there are some clunky things that can
happen to this is the sequencing of like
you you are kind of like there's a
there's a gambit aspect to the top of
the deck at this point where you're like
h what do I get? This will be the second
uh spell of the turn cast or at least
the second card played
>> here. The modality of blood rush
actually affecting this uh this board
state because one assault goes to the
big battering ram, the other assault
goes to Darius. Now Darus becomes a
nine.
>> A that's huge.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And now we get to um resolve the
back end of that conquer. You know
what's funny is that I do play a lot of
Rex myself, but there's no way I can
predict what's going to happen this or
even read or anticipate what the Rex
player can do because there's so many
options.
>> Yeah, exactly. And that's what I mean
about there being an aspect of
randomness to it is you are somewhat at
the mercy of the top of the deck. You
are at the mercy of doing but it's just
it's like a think about playing Rexi
like like building a a a branching out
tree of decisions. So essentially every
step you take gives you another branch
like that you can take after that
decision. So like tunnels kind of kind
of I made the Yeah, I made the
comparison to a tree. I should have made
that comparison to like
>> the roots can bury. Yeah, that's that's
all good. So it's going to be a big old
trade over a lot of the units on Cedar
Power, but it will result in the recruit
the buffed up recruit staying alive. So
draws first.
>> Yeah, good good sequence. hits the the
void rush as well. So,
>> but now the question is, do I actually
play the void rush?
>> Yeah,
>> because if I don't hit a two cost from
the top,
>> I cannot advance my board state.
Exactly.
>> So, you might not want to risk it. And
maybe you'll just
>> play something from handed, but spin the
wheel.
>> We go for the void rush. High odds of
actually happened in game one. And we'll
see what the reveal is. Is there going
to be another Titan reveal?
>> Yes. See, now maybe there was something
in hand that was actually playable
instead of this, right? So maybe there
was a unit that could have been played,
but
>> this
>> we we lost the discount essentially on
on the hidden blade and the blood rush
over here because void rush does give
you the discount.
>> But the thing is this hidden blade not
so hidden anymore can be played still
within this turn even though there's no
>> true cuz you could just hide at the
battlefield.
>> Not just hide it and I think it is a
solid consideration of actually holding
this.
Sorry I laughed.
some slapstick comedy. Um
we What happened?
>> Uh yeah, I'm not sure what the the
judges uh
>> there was the card draw from seed of
power and then the void rush void.
>> Yeah, it looks like the players are
confirming that everything is okay as um
>> yeah, as you said, you can hide the
hidden blade if you want. Again, not
>> with this board state when it's 66,
right? The hidden blade actually matters
for tempo and not it doesn't matter. The
opponent will draw cards like the game
>> will quickly end.
>> Can hide.
>> Is that two?
>> Two hidden blades.
>> Oh, that one's hidden.
>> The not so hidden blades.
>> That one's hidden as well. Guess what it
is.
>> Yeah, I wonder what it might be.
>> Two hidden cards in this list and one of
them got revealed to you already this
turn. But I think
>> that's a 50/50 where it is.
>> It's it's really important. Yeah, we
track the hidden blade. one fight was
been played already.
>> Yes, that that is, you know, these
things are actually significant having
them there with the resources that were
available because as you said, we're at
six. So, Exasio is trying to hold here
to go potentially up to eight or at
least to seven and put the pressure on.
Um, we know that our Azir player Pedro,
we we believe that second Arise is still
to come. So, there is still some uh
potency left.
>> Those are two ready units maximum. You
cannot do more from Arise. Imagine if
every single unit would
>> that would be that would be nuts
>> anyway but he doesn't have even access
to the Azir so rain anymore so you
cannot like just go and finish up the
game with movement from the from the
accelerated unit.
>> So now is about cascading potentially
yet here we go the equips for the
recycles to begin with. What does the
math dictate? Of course that brutalizer
gets equipped now. That's a that's a big
old sand soldier.
>> Yeah. And using the hidden blade on the
first unit. this actually draw might
matter because the energy is open.
>> Yes. Yeah, that's a good point. Um but
of course to re-equip now we're either
looking at arise to to create sand
soldiers that then weapon master their
um equipment onto them and that's
exactly what is going to happen here.
>> So shortcutting that way through. I feel
like at the end of this turn, um, Pedro
is going to have limited runes
available, but is in a make or break
situation. It doesn't matter.
>> Might not matter because he might just
win.
>> Yeah, exactly that.
>> So, we have the weapon master on two
weapons, so we're also saving a little
bit of energy. But the thing is, you
have to count. Do you want to use the
second weapon master already? Or maybe
you use it on the shield instead, and
then you attach the brutalizer by just
paying the green. So the unit goes to
eight again because on the board state
on seat of power it's eight. So you but
you kind of need nine
>> but if you do nine then you don't your
unit doesn't die.
>> So your equipment you can't re-equip you
have to eight and now go to attack to
the battlefield. Go for eight and
essentially have the ability to
battlefield so that you can then
reconquer after. Now, this is where the
hidden blade though makes a problem on
the second battlefield because you have
to then have another unit in order to
clear it out. And a battle
>> only have three units ready.
>> And a battering ram plus a buffed up
recruit is surprisingly difficult to
deal with while cascading.
>> I'll be honest with you, I didn't
realize there's a token there.
>> Yeah, it's there. It is indeed there
with a buff up. So, it
>> the token is more hidden than the
hidden.
>> That's so true. Even though it is right
there, but we're gonna switch things
upside down and and actually focus on
the battering ram first. So that's uh
threatening with
>> yeah eight might above the seven. So
sequencing it this way
>> the death grip
>> is going to be enough to transfer
massive amount.
>> This is an insane amount of might that
is eight transfers to the sand soldier.
That sense soldier is already.
>> So now that will survive on the other
battlefield or I guess you have to
cascade this first one. Right. Do you
have enough? Like this should be enough
to clear.
>> Yeah, it is. Right. And then you equip
the other equipment over to the
remaining sand soldier. Hands
through. The math was there for Pedro
and advances.
>> Eight and zero on day one at RQ Leil.
>> Really good sequencing by Pedro over
here. Well played by both players, but
really enjoyed this match. Um Death Grip
being the final push that was needed for
this game to actually finish. I think we
thought the death grip he didn't have
enough. No.
>> And that was both games, right? Because
you had in in the first game there was
attaching it with the G and having it
bounce back and then you still had the
the unit available. So, uh really
impressive Azia performance and you
know, we we were speaking earlier to to
Azia players talking about how oh,
sometimes it it goes in an inconsistent
way. Two games consistent even with a
bad draw in in game two. and was a bad
start, but had two arises in the hand
already, right? So, there's like this
kind of making it up aspect of like the
card draw at the beginning wasn't the
best, but then you have the ability to
keep up with the tempo and also we have
to remember Rexai didn't have a two drop
and then the turn two play was no
hopeful.
>> So, the opening from Rexite wasn't the
best.
>> Yes, we did however have the highlight
moment of uh
void rush into Titan Rams. Yeah, love
that. Sadly, sadly didn't end up winning
the game, but again, that was a game
that we were looking at where one player
was going to be 8 and0, the other was
going to be seven and one. So, still in
a fantastic position uh for Estasio
going into day two. Ooh, that has been a
lot of rift bound so far as we're going
to find out how the rest of our uh how
our evening plays out. I will find out
very shortly whether we'll have any more
for you or what is coming next. But I
think for us, I am
I am really happy looking now after one
day of competition at the meta where
yes, some of the faces are the same.
Some of the decks the the same archetype
in theory, but I think the pace of the
game and and how Riftbound has been
playing out at a competitive level has
changed significantly following.
>> Yeah, I would agree with that statement.
Um definitely less cold shots equals
less looking at the top of the deck and
making a you know
>> uninformed decision twice and then
replay with fizz and so on.
>> And it feels like you're able to play
smaller units to a battlefield set to
like the beginning of Spirit Forge was
like you play a two might unit to a
battlefield. It gets run over. Your
opponent draws two cards and laughs at
you as they get a gold token.
>> Yeah. So I feel like in current state,
even though that is true what you just
said, I feel like it still benefits the
mid-range Draven that much because now
people actually leave units on the
board, right? You have actual fights
more and Riftbound is about those
showdowns, is about fighting on the
battlefields. It's about that kind of
interaction. So inherently speaking, I
think Draven is still incredibly
powerful. Maybe to some degree
>> even better than in the previous spot
because you have to look at this power
level being brought down.
>> Yes,
>> because the bands and now does Draven
lose more than the other legends gain
>> and good question
>> that that is not possible for me to
answer. It's just me just rambling about
it. But it is a potential situation
where the mid-range Draven deck can
actually gain more from the bands than
loose.
>> Yeah, I I guess I would say one of the
other things that is really noticeable
in the field is fight orflight not being
here um is a real big change to multiple
archetypes both both playing the card
and playing against the card.
>> Just think about it this way. If an Azir
would be playing in this meta game with
fight or flight, if he would just death
crypt something and that unit gets
>> fight or flighted. It's like okay well I
guess I just committed so many resources
and for two energy you just said nope.
>> Yeah. I just love like looping back on
our conversations to begin the day about
like okay how are they going to like
like how are the bands going to change
the meta? What are we expecting as the
presence in the meta? I think it's been
quite refreshing so far as I know
obviously we uh in day one we do track a
wider array of of decks. We've had a
couple of of champions and legends who
we thought were performing well and then
have since kind of dropped a little bit
but that is the joy of also following
the best of storylines throughout the
event and I think we got some good
contenders for best of
>> Azir obviously we've got um you know
players that are aiming for multiple
best of like Allan is aiming for for
another best of
>> a side quest. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Although has lost the game so not
undefeated on day one. I you know that
that's when expectations are so high on
a player where you're like they dropped
a game on day one.
>> One round one tragedy.
>> We'll catch up I'm sure with Alan
tomorrow on day two. But now let's catch
up with our winner from our final round
of the evening
>> over on the stage.
>> Thanks for that James. We are here. You
talked about someone throwing a round
earlier in the event. Well here's
someone who has not dropped a round. It
is Pedro. We just saw you go 8 and0 with
Azir. How are you feeling right now?
>> H I I like it. I I think Alir is a very
good deck. Of course, I didn't expect to
be 8, but I I had good hopes for the
tournament.
>> Yeah. Well, I was going to say, you
know, Azir is a deck that has been on
the fringe to say the least before the
bands, but we've seen a lot more Azir
and a lot more of these order decks.
What were your thoughts picking Azir for
this event? Well, air got a big problem
um against Draven
>> because uh Air is made so you need to
give combats and stuff but the main
problem was that you couldn't get the
last points because of fight or flight
>> right
>> so now that fight or flight is gone you
know you can end with arise you can end
with the accelerated air so that's the
big game changanger I think
>> well another way to end a game is the
way that you ended that first game in in
absolutely spectacular fashion with that
death grip with the guard Guardian Angel
talked to me about that. I mean, you
even had to call a judge and be like,
"Hey, does this work the way that I
think it does?"
>> Yeah, I was pretty sure it worked like
that, but didn't want it to mess up the
camera. So,
>> but yeah, that's the the power of a can
break holes of uh 30 m. So, that's one
of the main reasons to play it because
you force the opponent to waste their
tricks on attack your soldier that
doesn't matter because you will
re-equip.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's the main power of it.
>> Yeah. So, you've obviously done very
well so far. You said that your match up
against Draven has been better. Are
there any matchups that you're maybe not
wanting to see going into tomorrow?
>> I'm comfortable against everything. It's
true. Draven is not perfect. It's better
the hard
>> but I I feel good about the list.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And I mean, you are in
the best possible position you could be
in this event. And I mean, you said you
weren't expecting to be 80, but how do
you feel right now having actually
achieved this monumental thing in this
tournament right here? The biggest RQ
that we've ever had, by the way.
>> Yeah, I I want it to be tomorrow. I want
to keep going.
>> Uh I like how I I have been playing. I
like the deck. In fact, Rexai was my
first option as one.
>> Oh, really?
>> So, I knew how how he could attack me.
>> But yeah, both were close and finally I
I decided with a
>> Yeah. Well, talk to me a little bit
about that. you know, you were between
Azir and Rexi. I've actually, you know,
been talking to a lot of players who are
in that same boat and I I've actually
seen a lot more people go towards Rexi.
So, what made you lean towards that
Azir?
>> It's it's mostly what I I talked about
about Azir being able to break holes of
a lot of money
>> like Rexai got a problem. It is very
good attacking. It's not good at
holding. And cards like Ferose, you
waste everything to attack and then they
are to make us ready to get the
battlegrounds back. With a you attack
and then you have a 66 defending, so you
make it waste extra cards to protect the
battlefield.
>> Absolutely. One other thing I want to
talk about cuz this was another crazy
play actually from your opponent into
that game where they had almost nothing
on the battlefield. I was watching in in
the backstage going, "Oh, well, this
game is over." And then they conquer.
They get the void uh the void mother.
They get a void rush into a void rush
into a undertitan into a Darius. How are
you feeling going from basically nothing
on the battlefield for your opponent to
I think it was 23 might on a
battlefield.
>> Yeah. To be honest, I laughed but it
wasn't that scary in my sight because I
I got a sphere in my background. I was
only caring about falling a star or pull
the way. Those were the cards that
destroyed my plan. I knew I could uh get
through any mic.
>> So yeah, I mean ideally he didn't get
that but happens sometimes.
>> So absolutely. I mean that that is
really crazy. So obviously when you're 8
and0 in a tournament obviously you're on
the top you're thinking oh you know what
are we going to do going into tomorrow?
But take a step back. What are your
thoughts here on this event itself? I
mean being in this gigantic uh floor
obviously it being the biggest RQ. What
has been your experience with this event
as a whole so far?
>> It's very nice. It's I'm also with
friends so it's also a very good
experience. Uh I was also in Bolognia
and I I like a lot this events. Yes they
they are very good. People are friendly
everywhere and you know competing with
the friends knowing seeing what your
friend has done in each round.
Congratulations. It's not a individual
experience only, but you have a a people
people with you.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And I mean really
really uh fantastic performance so far.
Now answer me this. You know, you're
obviously playing Azir at a very high
level. Have you thought about the metal
card, the best of card? Does it has it
come into your mind yet or am I am I
cursing you right now?
>> Yes. Yes, of course I have heard about
it. Like
>> uh I made top 22 in Bolognia. So the
goal to qualify for the European
Championship was already made.
>> Okay.
>> So I wanted to compete but also have
chances with a metal card.
>> Yeah.
>> So Air was a very good option for that.
I think Rexai was too.
>> Yeah.
>> Um my the friend I I b was 70 with Azir.
>> So yes, of course it's something
everyone takes into account. the meta
game is super barri because of that. So,
it's a very good incentive.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I love I mean, it's
one of my favorite things about
competitive Riftbound in general. Of
course, we get to see all of that so
far. Now, I I don't want to put I don't
want you to spoil anything obviously for
the event. So, I want to ask you more
about that, but have you looked at
Unleashed at all? Have you thought about
any of the set three cards? Anything
exciting for you?
I I am not sure because
>> to be honest.
>> Yeah,
>> not going to lie. I haven't checked much
unlisted because I wanted to testing for
this event. Yeah,
>> but
>> for now I I like Leblanc. I like bike
but only because I have seen them. I
have no idea.
>> Absolutely. No, no, not a not a problem
at all. I did I did the same thing. I
I'm like this is the event for uh to to
focus on for sure. Now, if you had to
pick your path to a potential top eight
or to play through to tomorrow, what
would you want to see? What would you
want to face going into tomorrow?
>> You know, I I didn't want to see, but I
saw three and won them.
>> So, I believe I like the the three meta
decks, Kaisa, and Draven. I think Draven
is a bad matchup, but I'm comfortable
because it's the the one I have targeted
the most,
>> right? So even if it is still bad, I I
feel confident about it. But I think if
I had to choose one of them, I think I I
want to see Kaiser.
>> Absolutely. Well, makes a lot of sense.
And again, congratulations, Pedro, on an
80. Absolutely spectacular run. And good
luck tomorrow, but with that, we're
going to throw it back to the desk.
>> Thank you very much, Blevens. You may
think that we're done for the day, but
we're not. We got one more game. Let's
go. Let's get right into cast for today.
>> Uh yeah, I mean honestly
nobody can actually do this, but give me
more rounds. Keep going. Keep going.
Everyone will leave. And yeah,
>> 52. Oh, it's an in
win in for day two.
>> Annie versus Volibear. Win in moment.
Unfortunately, one of these players will
not make it to day two.
Okay. Uh I did not prep too much on
Volibear, so I'm excited to see what
version of the deck this is going to be.
I see. Was that catalyst. I see. I think
I think
>> that was double punch first and a
challenge.
>> Okay, then I I may have just uh
pretended I saw uh
>> There's definitely a punch first.
There's definitely a challenge there.
>> Okay,
>> Annie goes second.
>> Well, let's see if there's a deck hand
over here.
>> There's a deck hand. That's a very
aggressive opening over here. Already
basically at two points because what can
the Voliva do if it's not a hex ray?
>> Yeah.
Okay, so that is actually pretty big.
>> But importantly, we're playing Annie,
right? So Annie can recycle can can
return the the thermo beam. Not recycle
hard. That's a pretty big sale, I would
say.
>> But I'm just saying you want to have
access to that thermo beam, right? So
you'll be able to grab it back later on
in the game. That's actually really big.
So uh
>> important pass with four open for
Volibar
>> means no catalyst. I was wrong.
Oh my god. Double
>> deck. Sneaky
>> double. Oh, that's an Aurora in the
hand. There's nothing else.
>> And I think a uh Volibear signature
spell. Oh, I'm going to have to remember
what that is. Um by name.
>> It allows you to move a unit.
>> Is it Stormbringer? Is that what it's
called? Storm. Yeah, it's something
about that. I have not remembered Volar
stuff for a long time. I'll be honest
with you. It's not going to get used in
quite a while.
>> Stormbringer. We got time. Choose a
friendly unit in your base. Deal damage
equal to its might to all enemy units
here at a battlefield. Then move your
unit there. Yeah, cost six with two
recycles. I remember that all from the
top of my head and definitely didn't
read that from anywhere else.
>> I'm paying attention to Otsu's body
language and uh I think he's giving his
opponent a tell that he doesn't have
anything to do.
>> Yeah, sometimes this happens with
Aurora. Oh, that is painful.
>> Yeah, that is painful. Oh, he can't even
play the removal spells over here. O, so
basically Annie goes up to four points
will conquer minefields to up to five
points. And Volibus still didn't play a
singular card. And remember, this is not
unleashed. There's no way of summoning
an elder dragon from the Aurora to clear
like
>> three units.
>> This is you really need to hit a curve
of getting your Aurora on like turn
three if if possible. and uh and get it
out with the the catalyst and that type
of thing.
>> You know, you're looking for mobilize
into catalyst into Aurora as soon as
possible. I mean, oba power not being a
factor in the in the meta anymore. Um
does change the the Aurora matchups. You
are you don't have that definitive one
extra game where you get the extra ramp
from your deck.
>> Uh it is Aspirin's climb. It's worth us
paying attention to that. Um so we are
going to nine. Um, so if ever there's a
game for a late game uh turnar around,
this might be it. But I think with the
thermo beam already in the trash and
units being developed consistently for
Icari.
I know. I saw it and I'm like, I have to
say it
developed consistently. Uh, I think
unfortunately this is going to be one of
the rare games where just not a lot
happens. Is that a dead bloom
that could have been
>> when your opponent has flashed their
units back in
>> that is very conscious decision. That's
a very conscious decision.
>> You're like, well, my opponent's done
nothing for three three turns. So, uh,
when they inevitably have a dead bloom
and it goes to base, you can see I
nodding as well at this point.
>> What an outplay with the flash.
>> Got him. Got him. Um yeah, so uh
Volibear will of course come into effect
here. This is honestly one of those
really unfortunate games. I mean it's
not over over at this point, but you
doing nothing for like three turns and
then playing a dead bloom in base is
really punishing.
>> And then potentially we can't even play
the Aurora next turn because we will be
looking at maybe using the removal for
base. So then we have to use the
challenge.
>> Yeah. I mean, what else is in the are
you trying to hit another dead bloom
when they conquer? So, if you play
Aurora, you have to think what's the
most likely unit coming off the top. We
haven't had unfortunately. Yeah, that
was what I was going to say.
>> It might be the version which plays a
little bit more mid-rangey and has like
ferris for runners in the main, maybe
the um yon as well. I'm actually not
certain. So, there are possibilities of
what kind of build can it be? More
traditional Aurora or less traditional
Aurora? Yeah, cuz that that is the
difference between purple Aurora. Purple
Aurora is just like you you play mind
spplitters and then one or two big
orange units and you give your opponent
a thumbs up as you take everything out
of their hand. Um the orange and and red
versions are a little bit different. Um
so we we'll just have to to see how the
cards come from Aurora. But
nevertheless, the back end of that is
having access to thermmo beam, having
access to a lot of units to be able to
get to seven already. It means we're
representing a game-winning turn as uh
the end of Osu's uh coming turn passes.
So, we're still in Icali's for now. Um
>> and you're right about the term beam in
the graveyard in the trash because now
with the 3 6 7 8 10 runes next turn,
you're able to play the Annie from your
champion zone, get the beam, and just
destroy the potential Aurora even if
it's being played.
>> Yeah. So, now it really does come down
to like are there any options with the
Stormbringer? Okay, it's going to be
flash to bring him back away again. So,
obviously, one dead bloom is going to
have to go to a battlefield in order to
>> uh attempt to hold it.
>> Attempt to hold it, which I guess you
have to do aspirants, right? Because you
don't want to minefield your own units.
Um,
>> true.
>> That's a weird painful thing on Aurora
is it doesn't get units out of the out
of the trash very easily, especially the
purple version.
>> Exactly. Yeah.
>> Oh, it's a difficult spot to be in.
All right. And also we have the VI
already in the base which will just
basically use everything that is in the
in the trash to go over
>> any unit on the battlefield.
>> This is the Aurora games that you hate
uh when you're playing it. As you're
like late in the game, you have the the
the runes to do something. You draw the
Mobiliz.
>> Yeah, you draw the ramp. Very good card.
>> Yeah, it's great. Turn one, turn two.
It's good in the early game uh where
you're able to actually play it. Um, not
so great when you already have the the
the runes available for Aurora. And
really when you hit 90, you just want to
turn them sideways uh and hit that
Aurora, get the uh the reveals from the
top. This is thinking, do I just play
the Aurora now or do I try and play my
out? He he probably should still
remember that there's a telemo beam, but
it's like even if he plays Aurora, what
do you get? you you double stack your
one aspirants climb because I think
that's the only
>> two. Yeah, I think it really is.
>> And then um
>> I mean if there's a
>> So he doesn't even have access to punch
first.
>> No. So if there's for instance like the
the big volley bear off the top, you're
obviously stacking that that battlefield
quite a lot. Um and
>> there is a VI that we we didn't really
acknowledge so far. So with so many
cards in the trash for Icari, we're
going to have to see exactly how much
that is going to be. Ooh, will go to the
minefield. That is uh rolling rolling
some dice. You're really Oh, okay. Unit
that is Yasuo goes out. So, actually,
that's probably not the end of the world
to have one of the smaller units uh end
up in the trash. The first cards in the
trash. Okay, so playing playing the out
now to try and challenge uh to get rid
of the V. I like that. That's uh one of
the ways of course that Annie could have
come back in or at least close out the
game very very quickly. Um
>> the thing is like that storm bringing
here doesn't really make any kind of
difference over here because it has to
be a unit from the base that moves into
the battlefield. So
>> here what potentially can happen is
after this hold most likely Annie is
going to commit to a hold on the other
battlefield.
>> Yeah.
>> And try to win this way. But then we can
see relentless sorry relentless the
storm. Yeah,
>> you go back with your
whole go on the battlefield.
>> Yeah, I mean it. So mobilize will at
least help a little in the next turn. I
know that sounds really really grasping
at straws, but of course you are trying
to play Aurora or or Stormbbringer and
things. You're trying to play multiple
things uh if possible. So, it now comes
down to uh how much can uh any player
actually
hold? Do they want to hold? I mean, you
you could just sneak
>> just get one point for what what measly
sneaky deck, right? Just going into
aspirin climbing one point.
>> One card in hand.
>> I mean,
>> it might be he was just literally just
like playing all the cards, all the
flashes and so on and he wasn't drawing
many.
>> Depending on what that is in hand. I
don't want to say that you can turn the
corner too easily on Aurora, but the
best position games that you end up
controlling from behind are the ones
where your opponent has no way to draw
into more cards
>> uh and are just playing from the top of
their deck and you know that you're
going to see more from your deck and big
units. So, they have to draw exact
answers to your units. But, we are at
seven points so I don't want to count
this over for now. Annie's going to come
through. So, that means no thermmo beam
or it can take the thermo beam if
necessary. could just be falling star in
order to deal damage for now. I think
that may very well
>> deflect on the the del as well.
>> But if you're winning this turn exactly
and also what is important even if there
would not be an aggressive play this
turn
>> at some point you get to the eight
points and then concurring aspar will
get you another card draw right so then
you deal with the lack of card draw that
you had
>> at some point in this game.
>> Yeah. damage from falling star
>> six damage you now you just send in a
unit finish it off or I guess you have
to do be careful cuz there's punch first
>> um there there's a lot of things
represented at least
>> you know the thing is
>> even if he uses punch first you and you
live through that
>> then you need to have most likely enough
runes to play stallbrer the next turn
and if you don't have the six energy
then you're not going to be able to
>> from this position he would and it come
back down to depending on what was
holding and what gets killed by
Stormbringer. So I mean I think we know
there's no punch first, right? Like I
>> No, no, we know he had it in the open.
>> Oh, he has it. Of course he's had it.
>> I think even two copies.
>> Okay. It's been a long day.
>> Yeah,
>> it's been a long day. So that's what you
can't let happen is the heal coming
through at the end of of
>> committed now because he he did the
damage.
>> It was a cleave that was in hand was the
last card. So, how much is there?
>> 13. That's double ring. So, that's 15.
>> It has to be 18. Uh, no, it has to be
>> 15. 15
>> cuz there six points of damage, right?
So, you're actually okay. It should be
fine.
>> And now we have Voliba. Does he have
anything over here?
Let's see.
>> Those six points of damage are going to
be uh the make or break here. I'm pretty
sure it is just the basically everything
will die and then deck hand goes to one
>> that will remove one ring.
>> Okay.
>> Does this change the map? We are
>> probably does with skys
might uh sorry two might how do you call
it? Two HP left on the dead bloom
predator and there's still enough damage
that is going to kill it. Now we go to
seven. And that's essentially the same
amount of damage that the two units are
dealing.
>> So was there another punch first? Yeah,
there was. So you're able to do that.
Turn the corner on this fight. Certainly
Predator is going to heal up.
>> Six runes for potentially a
Stormbbringer next turn.
>> So it depends on where this goes for
Icali. If I stacks Aspirin's climb, it
could be the full clear. I think that
does keep
>> apart from the Annie.
>> The dead bloom alive. Yeah, exactly.
Apart from the Annie, but we know
there's a second Stormbringer, right?
>> So the following turn you have to move
the Annie to try and hold.
>> Well, he's going to move.
>> Is this actually going to happen?
>> That's actually not that bad.
>> And we can't like we're not going to be
able to play that Aurora.
>> No, that Aurora is never getting played.
If that Aurora plays, then they've
definitely won this.
>> Let's see. This is this is interesting.
And remember this Volt didn't play a
card for three turns,
>> which you know sometimes sometimes you
do end up drawing into exactly what you
need. That's not everything right now.
So what is it? Six. So you have to move
back. Yeah, here's now turn everything
and uh
Stormbbringer. You see I nod'll we'll
trade that with the one sneaky deck
hand.
>> Mhm.
>> And then moves in.
>> And then moves in. So, it's going to go
to three points.
>> Imagine that could have been a Yona.
That would be pretty sick. Although the
Yona would have not held that.
>> Oh, exactly. That that's the that's the
difference there.
>> Oh, right. The wind goes and
>> it the comeback. There was a glimpse
there was a glimpse of a comeback uh
coming through for Icari.
Well, it was closer than we thought it
would be, but this is it was closer than
we thought it would be because in any
order card game, this game would have
already finished. If someone doesn't
play a card for three turns, it's he's
most likely dead. But because we have
the the point system and the hold and
concurrent system, it actually allows
the game to actually be played out. So,
that's that's what I really love about
Rift Pal because it's so different
fundamentally from the other card games
that we have.
>> I feel like that game was the best way
that we could end today.
>> Yeah, a little bit. It had to be just a
little bit crazy to round things out.
I'm happy we got that. We saw an Aurora
game and it fell flat on his face for a
little bit. Um, you know,
>> Lothar, thank you so much for some great
cast with me today. I've enjoyed my day.
>> Enjoyed casting with you
>> immensely. We we've had a lot of fun.
We've seen a lot of cool stuff, but that
was only day one from us. Um, we're
going to hand it over to Amy and Blevens
to round things out.
Hello and welcome back here for the last
time today. Day one RQ Le that is eight
rounds in the bag. Amy, we just saw a
Volibear so sadly lose the winning in
there. But an Annie make it.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And I imagine many
other decks that we didn't get to
feature or have a look at today have as
well. So I imagine there's a lot in
store for tomorrow even. inside.
>> Yeah, there's definitely a lot in store
for tomorrow. And we actually have the
standings graphic here. Let's take a
look and see what we have in store for
tomorrow. Up at the top there is some
Azir, a little bit of Aurelia. Is that
three
Ezreals? Okay, we've got a nice diverse
bit here. But let's take a look at the
top 16
that we're going to be seeing at X and O
tomorrow. I mean, absolutely
fantastic lineup here. I mean, we even
see we did see Allen is in fact mortal.
Lost one there, but a lot going on here.
maybe
>> top 16 players and although they could
be running different iterations of these
decks, we've got Draven there in first
place on resistance alone. We've got our
usual expected littering of Ireelia,
especially with the play rate of the
deck. We were expecting it to have some
high conversion to day two. We have Rexi
Kaiser. We even have that uh Draven
further down as well. Couple of Ezreal
scattered in there and a Fiora.
>> Yeah, we've got the Fiora up there near
the top. Lot of Ezreal. A lot more
Ezreal than I was actually expecting
just based on how prevalent it was. So
maybe a little bit of a uh conversion
difference for some of these decks, but
really really excited going into day two
tomorrow. Maybe.
>> Honestly, I'm already ready. Like, I
could carry on. I don't know about you,
but I could carry on going. Um, I
imagine the players probably need a
rest, but
>> don't leave. Come back. We're We're
start the next round right now.
>> But I'm having such great fun that I
just want to carry on. But we we must we
must uh rest for the evening, but we're
going to be back tomorrow with so much
action. Uh do you know what time we're
going live tomorrow?
Definitely a time that we are going to
be going live tomorrow is at 1000 a.m.
And I knew that off the top of my head
and I didn't say it immediately because
>> drama this
>> I needed to count I needed to count up
to that number like one two it was 10
a.m. tomorrow. Be right back here for
more action. We've got plenty more for
tomorrow. But for Amy and the rest of
I've been Blevens and we will see you
tomorrow for day number two. Rulio.
I want to try something better right
now. I guess our people going to turn.
Let's blow this rush and see what Papas.
It's such pathetic neatness, but not for
long. You'll get kinks.
So much faster,
so much fun.
Let's stop from scratch.
Blow up the sun.
Come on, shoot faster. Just a little bit
of energy. I want to try something
better right now. I guess the people
falling down.
Let's move this into ashes and see what
Papa thinks. It's such pathetic
neatness, but not for long, cuz you'll
get
jinxed.
Heat. Heat.
Phil's men, I ask you, WILL YOU FOLLOW
ME TONIGHT TO BREAK THEIR spine and
reclaim what one's was mine.
Those crab
stab me, deceive me, never shall
tolerate their crimes again. Now let the
hunt begin.
Yeah.
7,000 souls scared and daunted in such a
ter.
Not too long ago, this village was a
golden scene of hope.
Call down the
fl
to live forever.
Yeah. Bring down the regime. I know how
to unleash eternal power.
Lead us to order. I am the
Yeah.
I am the lightbringer.
Now listen, c warriors, I ask you,
should my campaign come to an end,
there's way more to avenge.